comme tous ces
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans votre grande
émission d'actualité parlementaire on
est ensemble jusqu'à 17h et au programme
dans une heure les questions d'actualité
au gouvernement
c'est le temps fort de votre après midi
aux commentaires alice bardot dans
l'hémicycle et pour les réactions
quentin qu'elle met dans la salle des
conférences
à tout à l'heure avant ça les annonces
d'edouard philippe sur la politique
migratoire quotas pour l'immigration
économique délai de carence pour les
demandeurs d'asile
le gouvernement veut reprendre le
contrôle dans un équilibre entre droits
et devoirs ce sont les mots du premier
ministre est le sujet de notre premier
débat dans un instant la proposition de
loi du député aurélien pradié pour
lutter contre les violences conjugales
atterri au sénat cet après-midi un texte
qui a fait l'unanimité à l'assemblée
mais qui a été retouchée par la chambre
haute
ses priorités sont elles les bonnes
comment lutter contre ce fléau
alors qu'une femme meurt tous les deux
jours en france on en débat tout à
l'heure et vous pouvez toujours
commenter cette émission avec le hashtag
qu âgées
[Musique]
et tout de suite on va rejoindre alice
bardot dans l'hémicycle du sénat
dans une heure maintenant vous commencez
les questions d'actu alors comment ça va
se passer
et quels seront les thèmes abordés cet
après midi à l'iss l heure dans
l'hémicycle tout à l'heure on parlera
évidemment immigration tout à l'heure
edouard philippe a annoncé les vingt
mesures du gouvernement levée de
boucliers à gauche et tout à l'heure
c'est le sénateur socialiste gilbert luc
devinaz qui interpellera le gouvernement
sur la limitation de l'accès aux soins
de santé pour les migrants alors autres
thèmes au programme de ces questions
d'actualité l'assurance chômage pour
rappel une partie de la réforme est
entrée en vigueur vendredi dernier il y
aura deux questions à gauche de
l'hémicycle à ce sujet enfin je peux
d'ores et déjà vous dire que la séance
s'ouvrira avec une question sur la
situation des banlieues suite aux
violences de samedi dernier voilà tam
pour un rapide aperçu du programme de
ces questions d'actualité je vous
retrouve tout à l'heure juste avant le
début de ces questions d'actualité merci
beaucoup à l'iss pour tous ces
éclaircissements et vous l'avez dit le
sujet de l'immigration sera donc abordé
dans une heure dans l'hémicycle lors des
questions d'actualité mais on va tout de
suite si intéressé c'est le thème de
notre premier débat il faut reprendre le
contrôle a déclaré tout à l'heure le
gouvernement en présentant son plan en
vain mesures un plan équilibré dit le
premier ministre entre droits et devoirs
tout de suite le point sur les annonces
avec jonathan du prix hier le premier
ministre la firme
il faut reprendre le contrôle sur la
politique migratoire du pays
pour ce faire edouard philippe et les
ministres concernés on précisait une
batterie de mesures en matière d'accueil
et d'intégration des migrants reprendre
le contrôle c'est faire en sorte que
lorsque nous disons oui ce soit vraiment
oui et que lorsque nous disons non ce
soit vraiment non je crois profondément
sur ce sujet comme d'ailleurs sur
beaucoup d'autres à l'idée d'un juste
équilibre entre les droits et les
devoirs
l'une des mesures phares du gouvernement
concerne les quotas pour l'immigration
professionnelle
l'exécutif souhaite actualiser une liste
des métiers en tension ouverts aux
étrangers non ressortissants de l'ue
en prenant compte les besoins des
territoires et des partenaires sociaux
notre volonté c'est de faire des choix
en matière d'accueil fixer des objectifs
quantitatifs ou des quotas les deux
termes ne vont en matière d'immigration
professionnelle mettre le paquet sur
l'intégration par le travail
autres sujets au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement la
couverture maladie des demandeurs
d'asile les sans-papiers bénéficieront
toujours de là et me l'aide médicale
d'état
mais l'exécutif veut s'attaquer aux abus
en instaurant un délai de carence de
trois mois avant d'autoriser aux
demandeurs d'asile l'accès à la paix uem
à la sécurité sociale de base outre ces
annonces le gouvernement promet de ne
pas toucher au regroupement familial
il souhaite par ailleurs accueillir
davantage d'étudiants étrangers cinq
cent mille d'ici 2027 selon l'objectif
fixé
voilà pour le point sur les annonces qui
ont été faites à midi on va en débattre
en plateau tout de suite avec moi quatre
invités j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
bernard jomier bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur écologiste apparenté socialiste
ici au sénat membre de la commission des
affaires sociales également sur ce
plateau martin lévriers jour vous êtes
sénateur lrm des yvelines vous aussi
vous êtes membre de la commission des
affaires sociales sur ce plateau
béatrice giblin bonjour vous êtes
géographe directrice de la revue
hérodote et enfin bienvenue henri leroy
bonjour vous êtes sénateur l ère des
alpes maritimes membre de la commission
des lois justes équilibres de droits et
de devoirs a fait valoir
edouard philippe tout à l'heure est-ce
que c'est équilibré ou pas henri leroy
écouter ici
s'il s'agit de savoir si c'est une
annonce équilibré je crois que c'est une
annonce qui pour moi un objectif
purement politique
aujourd'hui on parle sur l'immigration
de 13% de l'immigration en matière
d'économie et donc mon là vous parlez
des quotas on vous dit que ça ne
concerne pas grand monde
tout à fait écoutez nous nous sommes et
nous avons pas
mariés depuis quelques années nous
sommes pour l'inscription dans la
constitution de l'immigration qui serait
débattue et votée par le parlement pour
savoir combien peut-on accepter
d'immigrés en france
voilà la position de façon très claire
de notre gros un petit tour de table
bien larges biais d'accords vers
l'ensemble des mesures annoncées par le
premier ni sous celle affichage l'
affichage politique on peut avoir on
peut être pour ou contre ces mesures
mais en tout cas ça s'adresse un message
qui est envoyé à une certaine partie de
l'électorat à la droite oui il va être
pas quand on emploie le mot quota
c'est dans l'imaginaire c'est ce sera
moins voilà est donc le premier ministre
dit sur ses 30000 à peu près qui
représente l'immigration économique
s'avère très peu très peu de monde
eh ben on fera moins c'est ça le message
qu'il envoie et il est doublé d'un
message sur la santé on y reviendra
j'imagine qu'ils exactement le même
absolument martin lévriers alors le
gouvernement sur les plates formes sur
les plates-bandes pardon de la droite
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec cette
analyse à moitié à moitié et en même
temps exactement parce qu'on ne peut pas
enfin quand on parle de quotas d'abord
c'est un mot que moi je n'emploierai pas
je j'ai presque plus de temps c'est à
dire qu'enfin la france se dote d'outils
rh par rapport au travail industriel
pour les dépassements mais le
gouvernement le fait je ne sais rien ne
cache pas mais je dis oh faut bien
regarder aussi je suis très à l'aise en
soi mais je fais attention à la
sémantique et on peut mal le comprendre
un quota ça pourrait vouloir dire je
vais accepter en france 500 malien c'est
pas le sujet oui on le place sur un
autre sujet qui est un sujet totalement
économique et en parle bien
d'immigration économique donc ça me
paraît très important et très positif de
le voir comme ça c'est une un appel
d'air vers des gens qui nous apporte des
compétences ils ont fait grandir la
france donc je trouve ça très positif
oui bien sûr alors tout à l'heure
béatrice giblin henri leroy a dit bon
les quotas justement sur l'immigration
économique ça concerne pas grand monde
ça concerne combien de personnes
exactement qu'est ce que ça représente
normalement la migration économique ces
trente mille personnes effectivement de
60 voix sur 260 milles de personnes qui
arrivent mais légalement
territoire c'est-à-dire le regroupement
familial c'est légal des étudiants c'est
légal et faux pas à vous se donner
l'impression que on pourrait arrêter
tout ça comme on veut quand on veut on a
des engagements et et on doit les
respecter et je pense que c'est
effectivement une fort bonne chose alors
trente mille c'est peu on peut dire
c'est un effet d'affichage c'est un
effet politique qu'est ce qui pousse à
prendre ces positions
sachant que l'immigration est une
affaire très compliquée et que toutes
les solutions à gauche comme à droite
sur yakafokon sont des solutions qui
quand ils sont au pouvoir ils n'arrivent
pas à appliquer ni les uns ni les autres
on en est qu un non sens donc on en
hausse mais je tiens à le dire parce que
c'est non pas qu'ils ont que c'est pas
bien que c'est simplement parce que
c'est difficile et compliqué qu'on a des
lois qu'on doit respecter et donc c'est
pas si simple de dire on ferme les
frontières plus personne va rentrer et
où on ouvre les frontières on accueille
tout le monde on sait très bien c'est
pas possible mais le contexte dans
lequel ça passe c'est dit en ce moment
on à 65% des français dans un sondage
d'opinion ça ne vaut qu'un sondage
d'opinion qui sont qui trouvent qu'il ya
trop d'immigrés en france c'est un
problème politique incontestable que ce
soit juste ou pas juste c'est pas le
problème il est ressenti de cette façon
là et donc il faut s'interroger
deuxième élément qui pousse le président
de la république et sweeney a
dernièrement il ya aussi le fait que
cela ne va pas forcément une priorité à
l'immigration ton regard des priorités
audi on est d'accord on veut bien que ce
soit pas une priorité mais se trouve que
c'est une constante et quand on fait un
autre sondage où marine le pen est à 45
% soit disant dans des élections
présidentielles qui aurait lieu en ce
moment on peut faire légitimement quand
on est en responsabilité de
l'immigration une question où on va
essayer de désamorcer désamorcer ce qui
est forte inquiétude et essayer de
rationaliser ce qui relève de
l'irrationnel espace carré difficile
c'est un sujet qui divise ans déjà au
sein de votre majorité
ce matin est bien la ministre nicole
belloubet un la garde des sceaux avait
les états d'âme on écoute chez nos
confrères de france inter on va
l'entendre dans une seconde
moi ce que je souhaiterais dire ici
c'est que je n'ai jamais pensé que les
quotas étaient la réponse
enfin la seule réponse ce que j'ai lu
sur les pays qui ont instauré comme l'a
dit thomas legrand sur les pays qui ont
instauré des quotas obligatoires
ça n'a jamais marché donc je ne crois
pas que ce soit enfin il me semble que
c'est ce que j'ai lu je ne crois pas que
ce soit la réponse
il m'a écouté vous entendez martin
lévriers les quotas d'immigration
professionnelle en tout cas pour nicole
belloubet c'est pas la solution c'est
pas l'idée du siècle et même alain
richard votre collègue est exactement la
même chose dans l'hémicycle ya quelques
semaines ça n'est pas la seule réponse
au jeu je reprends ce que j'ai dit tout
à l'heure et je vais je vais les payer
quand aujourd'hui trois cent mille
emplois sont non pourvus alors que nous
avons des millions de chômeurs il ya un
problème et on sait très bien qu'il ya
des métiers en tension et que ces
métiers en tension en france on ne
trouve pas encore les gens suffisamment
formés ou formées pour répondre à ces
métiers et il choquant c'est pour ça je
parle et d'outillage
je préfère nous tirage chose de positif
qu'un mot quota qu'on va qu'on va lancer
à tord et à travers avec des gardes
côtes après c'est comme quelque chose
d'ouvert mais totalement autres qui sont
ouverts ce sont des postes qu'il souffre
parce qu'en france aujourd'hui on n'est
pas capable d'y répondre
est ce que je trouve très intéressant
c'est que ces métiers en tension un
observatoire a été créée je crois en
2008 pour les référencer et depuis 2011
ça n'a pas été réactualisé long depuis
dix ans quasiment on parle de métiers en
tension 10 à 10 ans et c'est juste
ridicule
l'avant de la force qu'on a aujourd'hui
c'est non seulement de proposer sa de le
remettre en cause tous les uns et de
proposer au parlement de prendre la main
sur ce sujet là donc plus démocratique
c'est difficile henri leroy ce mot de
quota c'est vrai qu'il appartient à la
droite
il est très associée notamment à nicolas
sarkozy qui avait bien sûr parler
d'immigration choisie versus immigration
subie
vous le voyez lrm en fait de ce mot ce
qu'il veut mais tout de même ce
vocabulaire il appartient plutôt au
chant de la droite
oui je crois pas qu'ils appartiennent à
qui que ce soit les quotas on sait même
pas dans l'expression qui a eu lieu
jusqu'à maintenant on sait même pas si
c'est pour réduire augmenter sa
l'émigration donc
rien ne vous dit peut-être que ça serait
même pour augmenter dans certains
métiers en temps sur des métiers en
tension oui peut être
peut-être mais j'en pense qu'il faut
d'abord penser à la formation de
l'ensemble de nos jeunes pour répondre à
certaines à certaines défaillances dans
certaines professions
donc je crois sincèrement que le mot
quota aujourd'hui est utilisé à tort on
veut où on ne veut pas augmenter ou
réglementé l'immigration ont regardé que
ce soit les danois les
sociaux-démocrates que ce soit même
angela merkel à paris aux voix après
avoir ouvert ses portes veut pour le
moment diminuer l'immigration 23 pays
sur 26 donc je crois que aujourd'hui on
focalise sur le mot quota est ce que
c'est pour augmenter diminuer on n'en
sait rien s il ya une volonté vraiment
le président de la république refuse
d'inscrire l'immigration comme une
priorité pour la diminuer bernard jamet
le quota c'est un symbole de la droite
mais vous entendez martin lévriers mais
on peut aussi mettre des quotas pour
augmenter le nombre d'étrangers qui
peuvent revenir sur certains métiers
mais c'est un symbole ça fait partie de
ces notions qui sont lancés comme ça
dans les bars pubs qu'on a eus
l'immigration choisie
oui à un moment la sarkozie ah oui là on
a les quotas donc on en voit ça pour
dire à l'opinion publique
oui on se préoccupe de ce que vous
ressentez bon mais la réalité c'est que
ce sont c'est tout ça ce sont des
messages restrictif qui sont censées
répondre à une crainte de l'opinion
publique liés aux mouvements migratoires
je rappelle juste que on n'est pas le
pays qui est le plus réceptacle de
mouvements migratoires que les
principales migration c'est entre les
pays du sud dont il faudrait beaucoup de
temps pour parler des migrations et
parce que le sujet est complexe et
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas une
réponse
il n'y a pas une disposition qui va qui
va régler cette question là on balance
comme ça dans le débat public
mais un message quand même sens
politique un message politique etc
quand on voit la séquence quand on voit
le moment où intervient ces annonces
quand on voit ce qui est dit donc sur
les migrations sur la santé des migrants
le message qu'ils envoyaient c'est un
message de fermeture et remettez c'est
très clair il ya deux de fermeté et de
retrait de droits existants voilà donc
ça moi c'est quelque chose que je ne
partage pas
on ne ne crée pas la prospérité et on ne
satisfait pas au fonctionnement d'une
société tolérante et démocratique avec
ce type de message on peut avoir des
dispositifs évidemment d'organisation et
de choix collectif bien sûr mais comme
ça non vous parlez du message du message
de fermeture dites vous du message aussi
de fermeté qui a eu
emmanuel macron il a eu cet entretien
avec valeurs actuelles dont on a
beaucoup parlé et dans cet entretien il
a utilisé des mots qui ne sont pas
anodins
il a parlé des associations droit de
l'hommiste main sur le coeur dead aux
réfugiés pendant la campagne je les
avais face à moi ces droits de
l'hommistes la main sur le coeur c'est
tout de même un signal en terme
politique qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
béatrice giblin ce que je disais c'est
qu'on est dans une situation où il y à
un ressenti à juste titre ou pas juste
titre c'est pas mon point de vue un
c'est simplement un ressenti où on a
trop d'immigrés et contient les
événements par exemple de samedi à
chanteloup les vignes ou aux mureaux
avec une casse importante
il est évident que dans une partie de
l'opinion publique trop c'est trop
voilà ça suffit maintenant saïf
il faut l'entendre et je crois que le
liés à l'immigration vous voulez dire
bien sûr que à chanteloup les vignes
c'est effectivement très liés
l'immigration est sans doute un trafic
de 10 les à une situation que que à la
fois les élus locaux les élus
départementaux et les élus nationaux
essayent de résoudre depuis longtemps
donc c'est dans ce contexte là qu'on a
une annonce qui est qui est faite elle
se trouve qu'elle était prévu avant que
ça se passe samedi
mais comment on peut essayer de remettre
un peu de rationalité dans une situation
qui dérape dans l'irrationalité d'un
côté comme de l'autre
je voudrais juste dire qu'on n'est pas
dans une danse que j'ai entendu minutes
peut-être que j'ai pas tout bien entendu
dans une véritable restriction des
droits non n'est pas sincèrement là sont
alors entendu cela oui d'ailleurs par
exemple on attendait des annonces
relation la santé on va parler de santé
mais par exemple sur la question du
regroupement familial on attendait un
resserrement des critères et sanaa par
exemple il ya plus de contrôles c'est
tout et quand on parle de resserrement
de refus de l'immigration accéder moi je
rebondis une seconde sur la formation je
voulais remercier ce que vous avez dit
parce qu'on s'est totalement nous
engager sur la formation des chômeurs
des apprentis donc on va complètement
lançant ça vous jouez vous en remercier
et en revanche toutes les annonces qui
ont été faites sont pour moi équilibrée
au vous ne vous ne parlez pas par
exemple les seize mille logements qu'on
va ouvrir avant le mois de décembre lui
est possible pour accueillir ces
personnes qu'on a régularisé qui ne sont
actuellement dans des tentes
ça on va le faire c'est quand même
positif et on ne s'oppose pas on veut
faire du bon droit d'asile et un prêt
doazit ça veut dire un droit qu'ils
accueillent
mais pas n'importe comment aujourd'hui
on fait mal au gouvernement les gens
dormir dans la rue des anneaux exemple
on est venu dire même si ça peut en bêta
hidalgo tant mieux donc à une
instrumentalisation
non mais moi je suis dans une ville
jardon où les habitants wii sont obligés
de supporter des personnes qui dorment
dans la rue qui sont les salles
abandonne qui n'ont aucun niveau
d'hygiène et enfin pardon mais c'est un
choix de l'état donc si le logement est
écrite a ravi le gouvernement a fait
fermer le centre d'accueil portes de la
chine ouvre d'autres il l'a fait fermer
et ouvrir 2009 non non non non ça n'a
pas du tout été compensée c'est pour ça
que les gens sont à la rue donc j'ai on
va en rester à sur soi mais tout de même
on parle
l'état n'a pas assumé ses
responsabilités en matière si dessein de
les assumer très bien un mot revient je
veux pas défendre le gouvernement
le gouvernant a subi avec ça faisait
face qui n'a pas assumé sait qu'il ne
peut pas assumer aujourd'hui non il ne
peut pas il ne peut pas et quand quand
on est faits reason sont lentes on a
fait ça n'est pas quand on a fait une
enquête sur les forces de sécurité qu'on
a vu avec avec roissy comment il est
impossible de reconduire les gens dans
leur pays
donc le gouvernement subit c'est pas un
choix du gouvernement quel que soit le
gouvernement donne dans la nation et ben
justement ce sont des gens peut-être
qu'ils sont en situation serait
irrégulière il faut que ça aille vers
l'ac milan tout simplement
alors on va aborder on en a parlé tout à
l'heure début de cette émission on va
aborder la question du volet médical au
sein de la cai aux étrangers qui fait
partie des vingt plans des 20 points
annoncé tout à l'heure mais d'abord un
détour par la salle des conférences où
nous attend quand un calme est avec le
sénateur communiste pierre laurent
qu'at-il pensé et bien des annonces du
gouvernement trial 1,8 âme c'est la
question que j'ai posée à pierre laurent
qu'avez vous pensé de ces annonces c'est
ce qu'il ya là un tournant dans la
politique migratoire de la france selon
vous ou assassin's creed en une
surenchère ou moins bien ces derniers
temps de d'annoncer qu'ils prétendent
courir après les thèmes du front
national alors qu'on ne résoudra aucun
problème du chômage de cette manière
pour ce qui est des annonces ça me
rappelle des en fait des très vieille
politique quand on a osé venir des
travailleurs dans l'industrie automobile
par faure l'exonère de la campagne
française dans certaines régions on
vidait les campagnes pour remplir les
usines et puis on venait vie on faisait
venir des immigrés pour remplir les
usines renault à une certaine époque
donc en fait c'est une politique
d'immigration d'inspiration j'ai envie
de dire et ça sent beaucoup le
néocolonialisme cette conception du
rapport au monde et du rapport à
l'immigration alors pourtant il ya un
volet 1 celui sur la santé où vous avez
peut-être pu être rassuré on ne touche
qu'à la marge à l'aide médicale d'état
le gouvernement ne touche que et bien
aux actes non urgents ça vous rassure
pas du tout est là par contre je trouve
le symbole catastrophique
le simple fait qu'on ose toucher à ce
qui devrait être la base de la dignité
humaine
quand quelqu'un est malade on lui donne
l'accès aux soins et on le soigne et il
y avait une forme d'inconditionnalité
dont cet accès aux soins qui était
parfaitement légitime et parfaitement
humain humaniste le fait qu'on touche à
ça je trouve que c'est très grave alors
là on nous dit on égratigne les choses
mais on sait que on a un gouvernement
qui demain pour aller plus loin puis un
autre encore plus loin donc là on touche
à des principes fondamentaux et c'est
pour ma part extrêmement choquant oui à
ce délai de carence sur l ap uem à la
protection universelle maladie qui est
accordée aux réfugiés comme ceux qui
demandent l'asile un délai de carence de
trois mois va être mis en place
ça selon vous est une très mauvaise idée
oui absolument elle n'est justifiée par
rien parce que quand quelqu'un a besoin
de soins il n'y a pas de délai de
carence il a besoin de la ministre a
parlé de cette mesure qui avait des les
abus avec c'est comme toi moi quand on
lui demande quelles sont ces abus
combien de personnes sont concernées et
c'est qu'on n'a pas de réponses
convaincantes donc en vérité on flirte
dans ce domaine avec des thèmes qui sont
véhiculées par le rassemblement national
sans jamais prouvé que ça s'appuie sur
des faits pour en vérité aboutir à des
mesures particulièrement inhumaine
merci beaucoup et pierre laurent pour
cette réaction micro public sénat
mouhtam merci beaucoup quentin pour
cette réaction béatrice giblin pierre
laurent dit on n'a pas de chiffres
convaincants sur l'état des fraudes
est ce que pour vous le tourisme médical
est une réalité en france combien de
personnes qui viennent se soigner et
pourquoi moi je n'aime pas l'expression
tourisme médical
ça a été employée par le gouvernement ne
dit pas appel s'il rappelle que le
gouvernement l'a employé peut se trouver
que c'est bien qu'ils emploient voilà je
n'aime pas cette formulation se sont
décidés gens viennent c'est vrai c'est
parce qu'ils sont en situation
de santé ou de maladie est grave et qu
ils savent qui a peut-être une
possibilité ici de réussir à le faire
parce que j'appellerais exactement du
tourisme médical alors qu'il ya deux
jours qui viennent avec un jeu silent
par exemple on dit je viens de vous y
reçoit un exactement et on pense on
évalue on va prendre l'exemple des
dialyses dont on dit dont on dit qu il y
à peu près la moitié des dialyses qui
sont faites dans le cadre de la m e qui
seraient des dialyses fait justement
parce qu'on sait qu'on va le lavoir en
france c'est qu'on ne l'aura pas chez
soi
donc je ne dis pas que ça n'existe pas
je prenais juste la formule que je
trouve déjà un petit peu tendancieuse
voilà dans l'imaginaire jeu dans les
représentations que ça peut faire bon
mais ce qu'il faut dire c'est que
effectivement dans le cadre des gens qui
avaient fait une demande d'asile
d'entrée de jeu il avait accès
effectivement aux soins de la sécurité
sociale qu'on appelle lafuma rebond
voilà
d'entrée de jeu alors que 1 français qui
revient d'un veilleux ou quelqu'un il y
avait les mains de carole il a trois
matches la rance alors est ce que il est
raisonnable de mettre tout le monde à
trois mois sachant que en situation de
réelle urgence
il sera mené en diamant soigner à le
paladin donc on peut voir ça comme étant
un alignement
on va me dire ben oui mais enfin on sait
bien que ce sera pas comme ça mais ça ne
me semble pas un point de vue le plus
j'allais dire ma subjectif possible
forcément une régression majeure des
droits la guillette médecin qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
est-ce que c'est dangereux est ce que
c'est une régression majeure comme le
disent beaucoup à gauche où est-ce que
c'est plutôt un élément de justice si on
est à trois mois de carence en il ya
deux situations différentes qui sont
traités par le gouvernement la m e oui
les trentenaires et les demandeurs
d'asile qui sont en situation régulière
sur le territoire
en ce qui concerne la m e les deux
d'ailleurs l'europe le gouvernement a
demandé un rapport à l'igas et à
l'hygiène
l'inspection générale des finances a été
publié en dise envoya des fraudes
bon moi ce que je constate à la lecture
du rapport de l'igas et qu' il dise oui
à des fraudes mais bon c'est pas trop et
à priori ça reste marginal
la ministre parle de deux filières
concernant deux pays des ressortissants
de pays
européen à ce moment là il faut lutter
contre ces fraudes
mais comme vous ne mettez pas après ça
j'ai pas envie de les citer je suis
passé c'est pas ce n'est pas la question
la question c'est que s'il ya des
filières de fraudes on lutte contre la
fraude
quand lutte contre la fraude fiscale
c'est pas en s'en prenant à ceux qui
payent leurs impôts de façon régulière
comme tout le monde on attend on
n'atteint pas aux droits de ceux qui
respectent la règle parce qu'il ya des
fraudeurs quant aux trois mois les trois
mois c'est très simple d'abord un c'est
un recul de droit ou peut pas dire le
contraire quand vous avez droit qu'on
vous dit nous faudra attendre trois mois
vous pouvez le défendre mais c'est quand
même un recul des droits et il sera
totalement inopérant il sera totalement
inopérant c'est à dire qu' il va
produire probablement même des surcoûts
donc il est inutile inopérant c'est
encore une fois un message politique
c'est en lien avec la première partie
notre débat martin lévriers inutiles ou
inopérants voulez mais je vous rejoins
totalement mon cher collègue et je suis
un grand défenseur de la mget défendu
aux deux derniers plfss et je suis très
cohérent et très clair là-dessus mais là
et me était très en danger par justement
les rumeurs les fantasmes qu'on fait
autour donc rajouter du contrôle à la et
me pour démontrer qu'il y a si peu ou
qu'il y aurait si peu de fraude tant
mieux s'il ya très peu de fraudes
ça prouve que la haie mais très utiles
et heureusement que c'est a ému existe
ça prenne de santé où j'ai passé par où
je vais le dire donc au moins on tuera
cette controverse très triste sur la hem
c'est une bonne nouvelle sur la puma
très simplement
à partir du moment où vous êtes protégé
toute façon pour les soins d'urgence
justement par là et me il est normal de
rentrer dans le droit commun des autres
je pense aux veilleux monfils ferry
veilleux quand il va rentrer pendant
trois mois il n'aura pas le droit à la
sécurité sociale donc il n'y a pas de
raison de distorsion de ce type là je ne
suis absolument pas choqué par ce par
ces trois mois de carence henri leroy ce
sont des signaux de fermeté de la part
du gouvernement vous avez écouté
à croire que les journalistes quand ils
font un reportage ne prennent pas les
bons chiffres mais vous parliez tout à
l'heure de valeurs actuelles valeurs
actuelles a fait tout un dossier dessus
et a montré que la fraude n'est pas
négligeable
et d'ailleurs le rapport qui a été
publié par l'igas hier par son directeur
le hier le 5 novembre le notre système
est décrit comme un des systèmes je
prends je reprends ses chiffres les plus
avantageux pour l'ensemble des d'aider
des gens qui viennent en france vous
pensez que ces insurgés à dire mais le
tourisme médical
le président de la république lui-même
l'a utilisé en disant que vous avez des
gens qui viennent en touriste pendant
trois mois et tout de suite à prix se
mettent à la et me donc je crois très
sincèrement que aujourd'hui c'est très
simple si on veut vraiment arrêter quand
on regarde la mva et me était à 75
millions en 2010 aujourd'hui elle va
atteindre presque le milliards neuf cent
trente alors que nous avons aujourd'hui
on est en train de baisser les
remboursements pour les français qui
sont à la sécurité sociale
on est en train de rembourser
partiellement aujourd'hui vous avez une
catégorie de personnes donc on a une
inégalité de traitement
on ne vous avez une catégorie de
personnes qui sont soignés sans
restriction aucune
alors que vous seriez allé plus loin que
le projet du gouvernement mais bien sûr
sur fond de fuite ce jour là demi-finale
d'urgence à une jolie leçon du panier on
va déposer d'ailleurs un amendement pour
l'aide médicale d'urgence pour les
maladies qui présentait caractère
extrêmement urgent pour les maladies
contagieuses
mais on n'est pas vraiment pour la
melons mais pour l'aide médicale
d'urgence tout à fait martin léveillé
vous lirez agir veut donner la réponse
moi je pensais qu'on était d'accord vous
étiez pour la haie mais je me rends
compte que voulait la réduire quasiment
à peau de chagrin avec tous les risques
de santé publique cela comporte et un
homme et un homme monsieur oui quelle
que soit sa couleur et j'ai pas dit que
ce n'était pas un homme mais en parler
de tourisme médical
le président de la république lui même
l'a dit dans
ce que vous avez appelé le passage
devant valeurs actuelles
donc il a bien dit vous avez des tas de
touristes qui viennent un pays étranger
la fraude
cottereau quand vous prenez ce rapport
et que vous regardez les chiffres c'est
pas négligeable
c'est extrêmement important par dizaines
et centaines de millions donc de
minimiser effectivement pour commenter
une décision me paraît si vous voulez
très restrictif bernard jomier question
les inscrire finalement ces mesures
parce que vous entendez la république en
marche qui est dit finalement cet
équilibre est par exemple la m
ils n'y ont pas touché de temps que ça
alors qu'on annonçait peut-être un grand
bouleversement et en même temps il ya
les mots du président de la république
et puis il ya des signaux politiques qui
eux sont vraiment vers plus de fermeté
les mots du présent la république qui
vise il fait de la politique bruit voilà
mais quand ce si on s'en tient au fait
effectivement moi je donne acte du fait
que le dispositif d'un émeu est assez
peu touché
en fait il ya la mise sous entente
préalable d'un certain nombre de soi on
sait pas encore exactement lesquels oui
donc elle n'est pas remise
globalement ils soient non urgentes au
gouvernement sur ces questions de délais
afin que dire aussi qu'on ait des sur
des délais très théorique
vous prenez même la mvc 3 mois
théoriquement théoriquement est ce que
vous connaissez quelqu'un qui a fait un
dossier de m e si vous arrivez à le
faire en moins de six mois à 20 je vous
invite et 1
mais non au conflit
qu'administrativement derrière qu'ils
ont dit qu'ils avaient exactement la
constitution des dossiers la réalité
c'est que pour accéder à ce droit là il
faut plutôt huit ou neuf mois et qu'il
ait des livrets pour 12 mois
donc en fait vous avez sans arrêt des
ruptures et quand vous êtes
professionnel de santé je vous assure
en ville que vous prenez en charge vous
suivez un patient comme ça en fait la
moitié du temps vous le soigner
gratuitement et donc c'est des réseaux
de ce sont ses pas pour rien que les
associations elles attirent l'attention
là-dessus meyer qui est un droit formel
et que le droit réel n'est pas le droit
formel etc la réalité c'est que c'est
très compliqué par contre et c'est juste
les filières organisées elles elles
savent se débrouiller et moi qu'on lutte
de façon plus efficace contre ces filles
en réaliser oui bien sûr mais encore une
fois pas en s'en prenant aux autres qui
ne sont pas malhonnêtes qui sont des
gens qui ont migré qui sont en mauvais
état et c'est qu'ils ne vont pas bien et
qui veulent simplement être soignés et
dont le coût moyen des soins
rappel est très inférieur au coût moyen
des soins de nous des français bat régis
blanc le mot de la fin
dans ce débat je pense que il faut
continuer à avoir une attitude
responsable vis-à-vis des gens qui
doivent être soignés c'est incontestable
je pense que la france là dans sa très
grande majorité et que vous avez raison
la simplification pour pouvoir avoir
accès effectivement aux soins et non pas
seulement un droit administratif mais
qui n'est pas un droit dans les faits
est une nécessité
j'ai cru entendre qu'on allait
simplifier et je bien compris qu'on
allait simplifier toutes ces procédures
pour que justement n'est pas autant de
temps vous avez bien compris et bien on
verra la suite
en tout cas merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre pour ce débat constructif ce
débat plutôt apaisé sur ce sujet de
l'immigration merci martin lévriers
merci henri leroy merci mais à tryba et
merci beaucoup
bernard jomier on va passer au deuxième
thème de cette émission la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
alors qui est débattue cet après midi la
proposition de loi du député aurélien
pradié un texte voté quasiment à
l'unanimité à l'assemblée mais qui a été
retouchée par le sénat lors ses
priorités sont elles les bonnes comment
lutter contre les violences conjugales
alors qu'une femme meurt tous les deux
jours en france le point sur les mesures
contenues dans le texte avec cécile 6 ou
une deux trois quatre cinq devant les
députés il avait énuméré un à un le
nombre de féminicide depuis le 1er
janvier 2019 217 mi-octobre le compteur
est passé à 129 aujourd'hui le texte
d'aurélien pradié sur les violences
faites aux femmes arrivent au sénat cet
après midi parmi les propositions le
député souhaite généraliser le bracelet
anti rapprochement qui permet d'alerter
dès qu'un homme violent approche de ses
victimes
au sénat on souhaite évaluer la mesure
avant de la pérenniser mais pour le
député ce n'est pas nécessaire contre
nous avons déjà beaucoup discuté de ce
sujet et que ça suffit je le dis comme
je le pense
d'abord il ya deux lois
d'expérimentation qui ont déjà été votés
par le passé dans notre pays
ces deux lois l'expérimentation n'ont
jamais des beauty sur une seule
tentative est donc allons-y désormais
autre mesure la généralisation du
téléphone grave danger
un système de touche unique sur le
portable pour les personnes menacées
le député compte également accélérer la
mise en place des ordonnances de
protection et réduire à 6 jours le temps
entre la saisine de la justice et la
mise en place de la protection de la
victime
enfin et c'est un point rejeté en
commission par les sénateurs
l'attribution en urgence de logements
qui appartiennent à l'état aux femmes
victimes de violences conjugales un
point que ne compte pas abandonner le
député c'est pas la solution miracle
ce n'est pas la solution exclusive mais
que c'était une solution complémentaire
qui était une bonne solution je pense
que la question des quotas réservés
des préfets étaient une question
intéressante comme complément et donc je
le défendrai notamment en commission
mixte paritaire
parallèlement à cette proposition de loi
le gouvernement annoncera une série de
mesures le 25 novembre prochain
résultats du grenelle des violences
conjugales lancé par marlène schiappa et
on va parler de cette proposition de loi
qui va être débattu cet après midi au
sénat avec deux invités agnès canayer
bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénatrice
theiler de la seine-maritime membre de
la commission des lois
également sur ce plateau jacques bigot
bienvenus vous êtes sénateur socialiste
du bas-rhin et vice président de la
commission des lois
première question pour vous jacques
bigot on a parlé un petit peu des
mesures essentielles contenues dans ce
texte
bracelet anti rapprochement
généralisation du téléphone grave danger
rendre les ordonnances de protection
plus efficace et que tout ça aille dans
l'ensemble plus vite
est ce que pour vous c'est un bon texte
devrait pas que c'est un bon texte mix
est un mauvais texte
le vrai sujet c'est que c'est un vrai
sujet il ya un sujet grave de société
face auquel il faut pouvoir agir ayant
la modestie de l'islate heures c'est pas
ce texte là qui va changer la situation
ne faisons pas croire ce que voilà c'est
mieux que rien mais c'est surtout le
travail sur le terrain qui est important
ce qui va manquer c'est les moyens
techniquement on peut toujours dire on
réduit le temps du délibéré du juge
on peut l'annoncer pas les moyens quel
est le rôle du procureur il est
fondamental quel rôle de la police dans
l'accueil de la victime sur le dépôt de
plainte
les choses ont pas néanmoins progressé
et puis en même temps je pense que il
faut peut-être aussi situés ces
violences dont les femmes sont victimes
jusqu'à perdre leur vie qu'il faut quand
même le rappeler de manière dramatique
on traite ces sujets comme des crimes
passionnels
ce ne sont pas que des crimes
passionnels c'est aussi un comportement
de l'homme à l'égard de la femme qu'il
faut essayer de juguler dans notre
société ait trouvé une fois de plus des
chemins vers l'égalité homme femme qui
fait que l'homme ne règle pas ses
problèmes à l'égard de la femme par la
violence est effectivement à 124 femmes
qui sont mortes de violences conjugales
depuis le début de l'année ça a déjà
dépassé les chiffres de 2018
qu'est ce que ça vous inspire au delà de
ce texte
évidemment ce sont des drames réguliers
que l'on croise malheureusement aussi
sur sur tous les territoires non il n'en
reste pas moins qu'aujourd'hui il ya une
prise de conscience et on ne peut que se
féliciter de cette prise de conscience
collective et cette volonté de faire
avancer les choses
c'est vrai qu'il ya déjà eu des textes
par le passé des expérimentations n'en
parlera qui n'ont pas vu le jour
aujourd'hui il ya une volonté unanime
puisque le texte a été voté il avait dit
unanimement à l'assemblée nationale je
pense que au sénat derrière l'ensemble
des groupes d'haïtiens de rochers mais
ça va certainement oui pour l'améliorer
le rendre comme le disait mon collègue
jacques bigot plus effectif plus
pragmatique plus réaliste parce qu'il
suffit pas de décréter des bonnes
procédures ou de décréter une envie de
faire avancer les choses si derrière il
n'y a pas de moyens et s'il n'y a pas de
procédure efficace on n'avancera pas sur
ce sujet dans justement que pensent les
victimes de ce texte
nous avons recueilli a recueilli un
témoignage vous propose de l'écouter
c'était au micro de sandra cerqueira
on le voit le bracelet anti
rapprochement et l'efficace en espagne
contre les féminicides donc ça veut dire
qu'on est arrivé
un niveau de telle violence que la femme
a peur de mourir qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avant combien de plaintes à la
déposer est-ce que ça m'aurait aidée non
car non ça c'est sûr et certain
parce que il aurait fallu que je porte
plainte qui est une procédure
il aurait fallu que je me rende compte
de ce que je vivais alors que nous et
beaucoup beaucoup de femmes sont dans ce
cas là maintenant faut des moyens
maintenant vous savoir comment le met en
place sachant que l'agresseur doit
donner son consentement
s'il n'est pas d'accord pour le porter
ne portera pas aussi donc ça veut dire
qu'il faudrait qu'ils se reconnaissent à
gré de sa rossi n'est pas l'agresseur
c'est sont nous les folles vous entendez
un ce témoignage jacques bigot beaucoup
de choses dans ce témoignage
certes le bracelet anti rapprochement
peut être efficace mais ce qu'elles
expliquent aussi cette femme c'est que
le problème est beaucoup plus large
encore et il fallu qu elle se considère
comme victime et qu'ensuite on reçoive
sa plainte
il y avait beaucoup beaucoup de choses
qui devaient être remplis de conditions
à être remplies
ça prouve bien que on est très loin de
la loi on en est dans le ce que vivent
au quotidien ces femmes et ce n'est pas
la dudh les criminologues et sociologues
et psychologues nous parlerons de cette
relation de la victime et de son bureau
et de la manière dont petit à petit
malade qui comprit y compris par les
violences dans les propos frasques est
très important aussi là le mépris
affiché un moment donné par des hommes à
l'égard de leurs femmes
la manière dont ils leur parlent peut
effectivement aussi entraîner une
déstabilisation complète qui se termine
par presque l'acceptation de la violence
et c'est ça qui est terrible
depuis des années que ces questions sont
suivies on sait très bien par des
associations comme sos femmes battues
etc
il ya un vrai travail à faire d'avoir
pour que les femmes osent porter plainte
je proche de ce point de vue là il ya un
progrès dans le texte c'est de dire que
le juge aux affaires familiales
pourraient être saisis sans même qu'ils
aient un dépôt de plainte
tous les obstacles que l'on met entre la
victime et son auteur seront extrêmement
important je crois dans l'avenir mais il
faut voir dans quel cadre juridique
c'est un vrai problème
en la matière on parle beaucoup
d'ailleurs 2
l'exemple espagnol agnès canayer le
bracelet anti rapprochement il est testé
enfin il existe déjà en espagne c'est
une cause qui a été reconnu comme cause
nationale depuis 2003 et par exemple ils
ont aussi mis en place une justice
spécialisée
est-ce que ça aussi ça peut être une
piste oui à partir du moment où pour
rejoindre ce que disaient aussi un jeu
vidéo
bigot c'est que on voit derrière qu' il
faut aussi former les acteurs à savoir
déceler accompagner les personnes qui
sont victimes et auteurs de ces
violences intrafamiliales et dès lors
qu'on aura des acteurs qui seront
spécialisés ils seront formés dont
qu'ils auront une meilleure appréhension
une meilleure connaissance du sujet
néanmoins le problème aujourd'hui reste
pas simplement la spécialisation mais la
capacité à traiter ces affaires là ça
demande du temps et on voit aujourd'hui
que les juges aient des moyens et on
voit aujourd'hui que des juges notamment
aux affaires familiales qui sont déjà
spécialisées sur le milieu de la famille
ont des cabinets dans lesquelles ils
doivent traiter un ensemble de dossiers
très importants et donc ça ne leur
laisse pas forcément le temps de
d'accompagner pleinement ces situations
complexes et puis derrière il ya un
sujet aussi de coordination des acteurs
puisqu'on voit aujourd'hui une des
grosses difficultés
reste que chacun intervient dans son
domaine la justice dans l'ancien les
associations dans leur et les
institutions dans leur domaine de
compétence vous êtes d'accord un jacques
bigot ce problème de coordination des
acteurs et puis ce problème de moyens
que vous pensiez déjà du mental je
prends l'exemple que j'ai vécu à
l'époque où j'ai deux prises dans la
communauté urbaine de strasbourg je
présidais le conseil de prévention de
sécurité de prévention de la délinquance
est le progrès vers la paix les pales à
l'époque avait décidé de se saisir de
ces questions de travailler avec la
police sur l'accueil des victimes
former les personnels à accueillir les
victimes ce qui n'est pas sans blâmer un
homme qui entend une femme se plaint de
violences est ce qu'il sera sera à
l'écouté de la même manière s'il n'est
pas formé ou que qu'une femme qui est
capable de comprendre peut-être mieux
ensuite nous avait suggéré absolument
elles peuvent parfois ne pas comprendre
qu'une femme accepte d'être victime
c'était évident le procureur avait
suggéré lui le fameux téléphone grand
danger qui a été mis en place avec le
financement à l'époque du conseil
général et de la communauté urbaine à
titre expérimental et c'est une fête que
pendant quelques années ces marchés
qu'on est doublé les moyens donnés qui
fait que la chancellerie la généraliser
ce qui n'a pas empêché d'ailleurs un
drame absolu puisque sur le territoire
de haguenau une femme alors qu'elle
avait un téléphone grand danger a été
finalement assassiné
donc on sentait bien que les choses sont
extrêmement mais que par contre le fait
que des acteurs sur le terrain se
mobilisent est essentielle alors faut-il
décrété une spécialisation il faut en
avoir les moyens
ce n'est pas aussi simple par contre je
pense que dans le débat que nous aurons
tout à l'heure nous interrogerons la
garde des sceaux sur les moyens réels
c'est à dire que on peut faire un
grenelle on peut faire des propositions
de loi on rajoute des ppl à des ppl la
réalité c'est quels sont les moyens dont
dispose la justice
effectivement il ya la question des
moyens et puis delà de la volonté du
gouvernement sur ce dossier
aurélien pradié ce matin était l'invité
de notre matinale sur public sénat il a
justement tacler le gouvernement
l'écoutant c'est pour pallier l'inaction
de marlène schiappa je le dis comme je
le pense nous avons beaucoup travaillé
avec la garde des sceaux sur ce texte là
avec qui je ne partage pas beaucoup de
chose politique pas du tout je le dis
très clairement depuis le début de
l'examen de ce texte jusqu'à l'issue je
n'ai pas eu le moindre contact ni avec
la secrétaire d'état ni avait levé tant
au développement de son cabinet agnès
canayer bien au moins vous aurez la
garde des sceaux 1 cet après midi mais
c'est sévère à l'égard de marlène
schiappa qui avait pourtant énormément
et bien communiquer sur les violences
faites aux femmes qui organise ce
grenelle
violent ça doit remettre des
propositions le 25 novembre alors qu'est
ce qu'est ce que vous pensez vous de ces
critiques à l'égard de son action
moi je pense que effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup de
communication mais on voit aussi que il
ya une nécessité de faire prendre
conscience globalement ces difficultés
là aujourd'hui
moi ce que je constate c'est que le
grenelle est lancé qu'on a fait des
propositions avant même la fin du
grenelle
donc on pense je pense quand même qu'il
ya un problème de méthode dans la prise
en charge de ce dossier fondamental
parce qu'on fait des propositions avant
d'écouter on sort des propositions de
loi pour aller plus vite parce qu'il ya
une vraie nécessité aujourd'hui d'avoir
une réactivité de compléter les
dispositifs on travaille dans l'urgence
au parlement parce que la proposition de
loi est frappé de l'urgence donc on
travaille dans des délais très contraint
or c'est un sujet qui demande vraiment
une appréhension globale et parce qu'on
voit bien que c'est vrai besoin de
coordonner de prendre en charge
l'ensemble des facettes d'amener vers
une meilleure prise en charge de ces de
ses victimes et des auteurs
vous êtes d'accord jacques bigot le
grenelle sur les violences à ce que
c'est plus de l'affichage est un
problème d'organisation de tout cela et
c est ce que c'est à la hauteur de
l'enjeu
depuis que nous avons ce gouvernement de
marcheurs on a l'impression que rien n'a
jamais été fait avant et que tout va
être réglé dans ce cas canard tout ça
est illusoire
ce n'est pas une bonne façon d'approcher
la politique on est sur un problème de
société complexe qui remonte même à
l'information on a interpellé le
ministre de l'éducation nationale sur le
travail qui doit être fait sur l'égalité
hommes femmes dans les écoles ça fait
longtemps on a su prix qu'on a accepté
la mixité scolaire est ce qu'on a réussi
dans la mixité scolaire à faire en sorte
qu'il y est une respect des femmes qui
est indispensable dans la société par
lequel ça passera donc tout cela il faut
que l'on reconnaisse et nous l'avons
fait nous à la commission des lois dont
qu'on reconnaisse nous sommes tous
d'accord dur sur la nécessité de traiter
le sujet il faut le faire de manière
objective et il ne faut pas que les uns
et les autres disent moi je vais plus
vite que le
que qu'elle les politiciens je sais doit
pas être un sujet politiciens on en a
fait un sujet politiciens l'air de dire
madame schiappa maintenant elle va tout
réformer va s'occuper elles de cette
situation ça ne se fait pas du jour au
lendemain
c'est très long c'est le fait dans la
durée il ya eu un texte en 2010 on en a
vu les conséquences il ya eu des
expérimentations qui ont été faites de
ci de là dans différents départements ou
dans différents territoires
il faut en tirer les conséquences on
constate une expérimentation quelque
chose qui a l'air de fonctionner en
espagne allons voir quel est le sujet
espagnol et puis vous voyez comme on
peut le pratiquer mais le bracelet anti
rapprochement ne paraît effectivement
une chose possible mais très compliqué
parce que on est sur du pénal et pas
survenu à faire simplement familiale le
juge aux affaires familiales c'est celui
qui va essayer de régler les problèmes
de la famille accepter le divorce
traiter la question de l'autorité
parentale est ce qu'il est le mieux
placé pour prendre des sanctions
d'interdiction alors qu' un juge des
libertés qui dont la mission n'est pas
complètement abouti
y compris dans la dernière réforme sur
la justice donc c'est tous ces sujets
qu'il faut mettre à table
mais quand on discute avec des
magistrats ou des procureurs ils sont
bien conscients que il ya toujours à
améliorer la loi que le législateur doit
modestement se dire écoutez long les uns
des autres et améliorons la loi pour
leur permettre d'aller mieux
je veux bien qu'on dise une ordonnance
en six jours la réalité c'est que si les
magistrats n'ont pas le temps ils n'y
arriveront pas et moi je pense que les
magistrats ont la volonté d'y arriver
et bien c'est sur cet appel à la
modestie pour le législateur qui va se
terminer ce débat un débat qui reprendra
d'ailleurs dans l'hémicycle à partir de
16h30 un c'est l'heure à laquelle
commencent les discussions sur la
proposition de loi d'aurélien pradié
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce débat tout autre chose à
présent retour au rapport parlementaire
sur la fraude sociale remise hier à la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
quentin qu'elle mais vous êtes celle des
compagnons conférence vous êtes avec
l'une des auteurs de ce rapport nathalie
goulet sénatrice us et de l'homme
alors il ya quelques semaines elle
parlait d'un fléau à plusieurs milliards
est ce qu'on en sait un petit peu plus à
l'issue de
ces travaux est ce qu on a un peu plus
de précisions la tabbee gaulle et vous
étiez effectivement depuis le 28 mai
dernier
chargé d'une mission par le premier
ministre sur la fraude aux prestations
sociales
première question très simple est ce que
vous avez pu chiffrer cette fraude aux
prestations sociales
nous on a essayé dans notre pré rapport
notamment en septembre il ya eu
tellement tellement de polémique à
propos des chiffres qu'on a préféré que
ma collègue carole grandjean s'attacher
au fond du dossier donc on n'a pas
chiffré pour éviter la polémique et puis
aussi pour une raison très simple c'est
que techniquement on n'avait pas les
moyens de chiffrer les administrations
nous ont clairement fermé les portes
c'est à dire vous avez eu des bâtons
dans les roues de la part des
administrations sur ce chiffrage du
défaut de réponse et les mêmes
d'administration ne répondent pas non
plus à notre collègue sébastien meurant
de la commission des finances qui est en
charge du rapport sur les migrations qui
a demandé lui aussi des chiffres et
qu'il ne les a pas eu donc même motif
même punition on n'a pas les chiffres
est ce que votre rapport revient sur les
principales causes de cette de cette
fraude aux prestations sociales
on a utilisé évidemment les données de
l'adn et f et puis les dossiers aussi de
trac fin qui est maintenant très
vigilant sur la fraude sociale il faut
le savoir
donc les fraudeurs sont très créatifs
mais il ya un point qui est quand même
extrêmement important on a eu finalement
grâce à notre conférence de presse du 3
septembre le nom exact de cartes vitale
en circulation 59,4 millions de cartes
vitale en circulation ce qui fait un
excédent d'environ 5 millions de cartes
qui a 5 millions de cartes en vrac dans
d'autres systèmes 5 millions en trop qui
sont ces cinq millions de le kart qui
sont en trop qui sont ces personnes
alors j'hésite entre clouzot et colombo
j'ai pas trouvé
et comme on ne l'a pas dit donc ça va
être l'objet de multiples amendement au
plfss
parce que voyez-vous 5 millions de
cartes actives c'est ce qui ressort de
ce que nous aident ils à la cnab la cnav
la dss tout le monde dans un communiqué
flamboyant du 5 septembre
et bien maintenant il va falloir qu'ils
s'expliquent sur 5 millions de cartes en
trop et combien ça nous coûte
et alors vous parler du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale vous
allez apporter une douzaine une
quinzaine d'amendements à ce plfss
quels sont ils présents nous en dire
quelques chaleurs en partie sont issus
du rapport en partie d'autres choses y
en a qui est très intéressant vous savez
ces restaurateurs et qui ont été taxés à
propos de des avantages en nature dans
l'eau
dans leur restaurant donc j'ai une série
d'amendements là-dessus qui va essayer
de limiter la casse et d'éviter cette
bêtise
et puis il ya aussi une série
d'amendements lié directement à la
fraude notamment liés à la carte vitale
parce qu'il faut absolument que la carte
qui est délivré à vie selon le code de
la sécurité sociale soit délivrée en
fonction des droits du titulaire c'est à
dire vous avez le droit de rester six
mois sur le territoire votre carte est
valable six mois et pas un jour de plus
et ça c'est un enjeu de fraude très
important merci beaucoup aux nathalie
goulet en sera bien sûr un l'examen de
ces amendements lors du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale mais
j'espère bien oui effectivement à ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale qui était d'ailleurs
examiné en commission ce matin tandis
que nous sommes à un quart d'heure des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement et
que l'on voit et bien les couloirs qui
commence à se remplir la salle des
conférences et qui est juste à côté qui
jouxte l hémicycle
j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sur ce
plateau à l'extérieur mou bonjour vous
êtes présidente fondatrice du think tank
france audacieuse et du mouvement
politique nous citoyens france on va
parler ensemble et bien des temps forts
que l'on attend pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement il
ya notamment plusieurs questions qui
vont être consacrés à l'assurance
chômage
cette réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
est entré en vigueur au début du mois
est ce que pour vous cette réforme elle
est équilibrée
c'est encore une fois l'exercice du
maquereau nisme du en même temps je note
quand même avant de parler d' équilibre
que c'est une réforme qui s'est faite
sans accord des partenaires sociaux a
critiqué par les partis par les
partenaires sociaux normalement ils
avaient entre janvier et février pour
trouver un terrain d'entente puisque il
n'y a pas eu de terrain d'entente
le l'exécutif a repris la main ce qui
fait qu'on a eu ces deux décrets de
juillet 2019 qui ont permis de faire ce
panorama d'exercice de cette nouvelle
réforme qui globalement
va dans le bon sens mais avec quand même
sur sur les cadres notamment
c'est ce sont ceux qui perdent qui
perdent le plus les curés les cadres et
aussi les plus précaires et les plus
pressés ce que notamment le front
syndical qui estime que ce couvert de
rigueur budgétaire d'incitation à
travailler finalement on sabre dans
aussi ses revenus les plus précaires et
ça c'est un vrai problème pour le
gouvernement alors qu'il a par exemple
ce budget du pouvoir d'achat c'est un
petit peu contradictoire et c'est pour
ça que c'est lui en même temps c'est à
dire qu'on à certains moments des
mesures qui vont toucher une population
on se dit bon ça va vers les plus
précaires puis à d'autres moments on va
retaper sur ce même sur cette même
population
donc aujourd'hui on est quand même sur
une mise en oeuvre qui est gradué
puisqu'il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui ont démarré au 1er novembre
d'autres qui vont se mettre en oeuvre au
1er avril il ya un pôle que je trouve
assez intéressant sur la formation et
tout ce qui va être fait au niveau de
pôle emploi qui a quand même besoin
d'être bien restructurer et renforcer
l'accompagnement mais voilà des
demandeurs d'emploi parce que même s'il
y a la volonté de le faire encore
faut-il qu'il y ait l'efficacité est
donc en termes d'efficacité c'est
l'offre et la demande
entre ce que propose pôle emploi est ce
que c'est adapté finalement à ce dont
ont besoin
ceux qui sont en recherche très active
d'emploi
est ce que l'objectif russie pour le
gouvernement c'est de faire des
économies c'est l'objectif souvent de
nombreuses réformes on attend à 1,3
milliard d'économies par an d'ici 2022
c'est quand même pas mal oui et il n'y a
pas de miracle de toute façon vu le taux
élevé de dépenses publiques que nous
avons évidemment que ces réformes sont
faites à la fois pour plus d'efficacité
et aussi pour réduire le montant du coût
à la collectivité
parce qu'il faut toujours penser quand
même qu'en bout de course la
collectivité c'est nous à travers les
impôts
en tout cas c'est un sujet qui devrait
être débattu à tout à l'heure dans la
mystique ligne a notamment une question
communiste sur ce sujet autre sujet sur
lequel il va y avoir des questions qui
va d'ailleurs ouvrir la séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
qui sera certainement adressé à
christophe castaner que l'on voit
d'ailleurs arrivé
actuellement dans la salle des
conférences du sénat
eh bien il va certainement y avoir cette
question consacré aux violences à
chanteloup les vignes
un mot d'abord sur les maux qui ont été
employés il y avait toute une polémique
en début de semaine edouard philippe qui
avait parlé concernant eh bien les
événements de chanteloup-les-vignes
d'une bande d'imbéciles et
d'irresponsables c'est une litote un set
qui l'a reconnu hier lors des questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée
et ce n'étaient pas les bons mots non ce
n'était pas les bons mots pour qualifier
la réalité du phénomène que l'on voit
exploser ces derniers temps parce qu'il
n'ya pas que chanteloup-les-vignes bien
sûr je crois que ça pose le problème en
fait de du verbe et de l'action du verbe
politique et de l'action qui est un
regard pendant qu'on voit également
gérard larcher un qui est en train
d'arriver dans les couloirs et qui va
vers le cabinet de départ je voulais
interrompue voilà donc donc en fait
c'est toujours surtout en matière de
plan banlieues on sait bien qu'il ya un
passif quand même assez lourd pour ce
gouvernement où lorsque jean louis
borloo avait proposé un plan un nouveau
plan banlieues il avait tout de suite
été mis la mêlée fermée la porte c'était
une fin de non recevoir
en fait la difficulté dans ce type de
réforme c'est qu'il faut à la fois
travailler sur la rénovation de
l'habitat et puis favoriser la mixité
sociale
et quand on parle de ses deux ponts on
voit bien que c'est ça qui dérange en
fait la rénovation de l'habitat
même si c'est très lourd à mettre en
place ce sont en fait des procédures qui
sont relativement au long cours et qu'on
arrive à faire mais la mixité sociale
pour permettre le désenclavement avoir
accès à l'ensemble des services publics
et de combien y aller dit aux gars
philippe également est en train d'y
arriver
oui donc on se retrouve vraiment là à
avoir des difficultés et on voit bien
que une des hypothèses qui a été émise
d'ailleurs par la maire de chanteloup
les vignes qui pour le coup a aussi été
très virulente 1 dans sa façon de
caractériser
les éléments semblent les événements
l'instant dit oui c'est parce que en
fait elle dit qu'ils auraient des
projets de rénovation urbaine qui
gênerait les trafics drogue
et quand l'économie j'ai nommé
souterraines voilà de façon plus plus
dit que ce que je m'essaye de drogue est
la même c'est quand même la même chose
donc c'est là où on voit que les mots
d'edouard philippe qui s'est d'ailleurs
rattrapé après mais parler de litotes
qui est un bon mot en termes littéraires
n'est pas forcément adaptée en matière
politique
alors la difficulté à trouver la ligne
rouge à trouver pour l'exécutif sur ce
sujet c'est qu'il ne faut pas que les
actes paraissent bien pauvre
au regard du verbe employés mais à
linverse il ne faut pas que le verbe
soit en dessous de la réalité
mais un autre sujet sur lequel il ya
peut-être eu un décalage entre le verbe
est finalement le plan qui est présenté
c'est l'immigration on avait noté des
grands grands signaux de fermeté sur ce
sujet et finalement le plan présenté ce
matin comment est ce que vous vous le
considérez tout à l'heure en plateau
certains m'ont très bien qu'il y avait
aussi du en même temps dans ces mesures
ans on est toujours sur dix en même
temps et ça c'est une réflexion plus
générale on commence à être un certain
nombre à se faire il y à un certain
nombre de sujets sur lesquels le en même
temps ne fonctionne pas c'est à dire que
vouloir avoir une approche novatrice et
trans partisane c'est pas forcément
sujet par sujet de vouloir contenter les
uns et les autres parce que parfois ça
ne fonctionne on risque de ne contenter
personne aura exactement alors qu'une
véritable approche transpartisane qu'est
ce que ça pourrait être ça pourrait être
d'être très structurant est très ferme
sur les sujets comme l'immigration sur
lesquels il faut monter au créneau parce
que c'est attendu par les français
c'est un vrai sujet que nous avons et il
n'y a pas de raison de laisser ce
terrain là au rassemblement national ça
c'est une défaite de la démocratie que
de faire cela et sur d'autres sujets
avoir une démarche qui est beaucoup plus
social et qui soit assumée et à ce
moment-là ça une ligne beaucoup plus
clair bien merci beaucoup à alexia
germes ont tout de suite on va prendre
la direction de la salle des conférences
alors que les questions d'actualité vont
commencer dans trois minutes maintenant
car quand un vous êtes avec david
assouline sénateur socialiste de paris
vice président du sénat justement ya
pour l'interroger sur toutes ces mesures
qui ont été dévoilé ce midi en matière
d'immigration pour le gouvernement
oui david assouline quelle est votre
réaction à ces annonces en matière
d'immigration est ce qu'il y a selon
vous un tournant un virage dans la
politique migratoire de notre pays
écoutez oui de la part d' emmanuel
macron de la part de ce gouvernement
c'est un nouveau ton c'est un ton qui
avait été plus ou moins déjà annoncé ces
dernières semaines
ça s'est transformé ensuite par un acte
très très douteux qui a été accordé un
interview à un journal d'extrême droite
valeurs actuelles pour parler en plus
d'immigration bien donc là maintenant ce
sont des mesures alors les mesures
d'abord sur l'immigration économique
cottin oui c'est juste encore donner un
gage parce que derrière on sait très
bien que ce n'est pas le sujet il y a
trente mille par an délits économiques
ça n'a jamais posé aucun problème tout
le monde sait bien que c'est pas là qui
est un sujet puisque ce sont des emplois
des emplois pourvus et que maintenant
venir parler de quotas c'est juste
essayer de surfer sur sur un état
d'esprit qui est pas bon qui est
deuxième bon que que les autorités de
l'état devrait plutôt combattre devrait
apaiser et puis et puis
touché aux 7 avec ses trois mois de
carence à voilà à la santé on va en
parler parce qu'effectivement il ya
l'instauration de ce délai de carence de
trois mois
mis en place sur la protection
universelle maladie accordés notamment
réfugiées là vous dites il y a un
problème avec cette carence mais bien
entendu d'abord il ya un problème
humanitaire quand on est malade on doit
pouvoir être soigné
mais derrière cela c'est aussi une
mesure qui met en danger la société elle
même si quelqu'un est malade est
contagieux et qu'on ne le soigne pas
parce qu'on doit attendre trois mois il
y aura les cas d'urgence qu'ils aient
les cas d'urgence ne seront pas
concernés mais vous voyez bien concret
des complications là où il doit y avoir
beaucoup de réactivité
là où il faut agir vite et pour agir
avec humanité
donc c'est tout cela ce sont encore des
gages qui ne règle aucun des problèmes
ou des angoisses que peuvent avoir des
français sur le sujet il faut apaiser
de toute façon les problèmes liés aux
migrations internationales sont devant
nous et sont pas derrière nous et il
faut pas les aborder de façon frileuses
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement
fils un très mauvais coup là on est en
voie d'être très mauvais signe qu'elle
pour se présenter demain comme un
rempart au front national si on fait ce
que le front national veut on n'est pas
un rempart on est à un point vous le dit
david assouline le gouvernement essaie
de réinstaller un match avec le
rassemblement national en vue de 2022
c'est ça que vous dites aujourd'hui on
oui en même temps c'est la meilleure
façon de le perdre ce match c'est à dire
non seulement on installe le front
national on valide ses conceptions ses
idées et ses propositions les quotas
c'était aussi ce et puis on n'est pas un
rempart et c'est grave pour demain merci
beaucoup david assouline un
vice-président socialiste du sénat on va
retrouver alice bardot maintenant dans
l'hémicycle en tribune de presse
alice et quel est le programme de ces
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
aujourd'hui à l'or lors des ces
questions d'actualité vous le rencontrez
quentin il sera notamment question des
mesures sur l'immigration annoncé tout à
l'heure par le premier ministre alors
des sénateurs de droite comme de gauche
vont interpeller le gouvernement
le sénateur socialiste gilbert luc
devinaz zh posera une question sur la
limitation donc des des droits de
l'accès aux soins pardon de santé pour
les migrants donc l'exécutif veut mettre
en place un délai de carence de trois
mois avant que les demandeurs d'asile
puissent accéder à la puma la puma donc
il ya la sécurité sociale de base
autre mesure souhaitée par le
gouvernement l'accord préalable de la
sécurité sociale pour que les sans
papiers puissent bénéficier de soins qui
ne sont pas urgents dans le cadre de
l'aide médicale d'état
voilà la cloche a sonné tout de suite
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
[Musique]
si l'observation il y en a t'il en
séance je n'en vois point il est donc
adopté ce procès verbal sous les
réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres
chers collègues l'envoi du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement à l'issue de ces questions
la séance sera suspendue jusqu'à 17h15
afin de permettre à la conférence des
présidentes se réunir notre séance et
retransmissions public sénat et sur
notre site internet
chaque âge sera attentif au temps et au
respect des uns et des autres la parole
est à notre collègue alain fouché pour
le groupe les indépendants sont chers
collègues vous avez la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur mes chers
collègues certains individus font des
concours de guet-apens contre les
services de secours les forces de
l'ordre ces concours de l'âge se propage
depuis plusieurs jours relayé par les
réseaux sociaux
la réponse à apporter doit être la
fermeté la nouvelle mode de ces
criminels et de se filmer pendant leurs
attaques contre les forces de l'ordre
désoeuvrés ou protégeant des trafics
ils oublient bien vite la chance qu'ils
ont de vivre dans un pays qui respecte
l'état de droit et qu'eux-mêmes ont
intérêt à respecter
rien ne saurait justifier ces atteintes
à l'ordre public à la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de ceux qui les protègent
au quotidien les gendarmes les policiers
des pompiers auxquels je veux rendre
hommage
les tensions dans les quartiers
défavorisés sont en recrudescence
voilà plus de trente ans que des
gouvernements successifs tente d'en
venir à bout
sans y parvenir vraiment il semble
qu'une trentaine d'individus étaient
impliqués dans le guet-apens de
chanteloup les vignes
seuls deux interpellations ont eu lieu à
ce jour d'obscène ville comme ailleurs
cette situation n'est pas acceptable
la réponse judiciaire doit être à la
hauteur des infractions commises
monsieur le ministre je sais que vous
vous êtes rendus sur les lieux hier
matin
ma question est la suivante que comptez
vous faire pour que les forces de
l'ordre disposent de moyens plus
importants nécessaires à
l'accomplissement de leur mission
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur
christophe castaner monsieur wings merci
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
fouché
vous avez évoqué 30 ans d'action avec
des succès des réussites en matière de
politique de la ville mais aussi avec
des échecs et une situation qui dans de
nombreux quartiers ne s'est pas
améliorée tant en matière sociale
d'espérance dont en matière de lutte
contre une sorte de déterminisme social
et d'assises à sion à résidence dans ces
quartiers qu'en matière d'insécurité et
de violence face à nos forces
c'est la raison pour laquelle hier matin
quand je me suis rendu à
chanteloup-les-vignes j'ai proposé à la
garde des sceaux j'ai proposé au
ministre en charge du logement de la
politique de la ville de m'accompagner
tout simplement parce que c'est trop
conquête républicaine que nous devons
conduire dans ces quartiers ne relève
pas que de la seule police elles
relèvent évidemment de la police mais
elle relève de l'ensemble de l'action
qui est porté sur ces territoires et
notre première volonté a été d'être à
côté de madame la maire de chanteloup
les vignes qui porte un projet ambitieux
pour sa commune et qui se bat chaque
jour avec les associations et dans le
cas présent ce sont les activités de ces
associations qui ont été mises en cause
quand nous avons rencontré les parents
les mamans de ce quartier c'est ce
qu'elle nous ont dit monsieur le
sénateur ce qui s'est passé est
inacceptable le comportement de ces
voyous est inacceptable et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il faut
effectivement des sanctions exemplaires
d'ores et déjà deux personnes ont été
interpellées ont été mis à disposition
de la justice et la qualification
criminelle a été retenue pour
l'instruction de cette affaire
l'enquêté se poursuit et je suis
convaincu qu'il y aura d'autres
personnes interpellées mais au-delà de
cela je voudrais redire comme vous
l'avez dit tout mon soutient cet
engagement puissant fort manifeste
courageux de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure la police mais aussi de nos
sapeurs pompiers qui étaient protégés
par la police au moment de ces incendies
deuxième élément je vais vous dire ma
détermination à renforcer plus encore
les moyens de nos forces de sécurité
intérieure je présentais cette nuit le
budget de la sécurité qui a augmenté de
1 milliard d'euros depuis 2010 est pour
justement donner des moyens aux forces
de sécurité intérieure et nous aurons
l'occasion dans cet hémicycle d'en
débattre
pour donner plus encore de moyens à nos
forces et les soutenir je vous remercie
merci monsieur lui monsieur boucher la
parole est à notre collègue martin de
sidrac pour le groupe l'est républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre qui est
présent parmi nous et je voudrais
commencer très simplement par vous poser
une première petite question
connaissez-vous chanteloup-les-vignes
monsieur le premier ministre c'est une
ville de 10000 habitants à l'ouest de
paris dans les yvelines qui est
aujourd'hui meurtrie par les
affrontements de samedi entre des
criminels et des policiers ces
affrontements ente entraîne l incendie
d'un équipement collectif chanteloup est
une ville française comme menthe béziers
où brest et qui aujourd'hui pansent
leurs plaies et se bat au quotidien
reconquérir mètre carré par mètre carré
chaque morceau de son leur territoire
républicain que des criminels souhaite
voir disloqué car lorsqu'on brûle nos
villes qu'on attaque nos policiers ou
qu'on menace nos élus c'est la
république on brûle qu'on attaque et
qu'on menace monsieur le premier
ministre et pour bien combattre ce mal
il faut bien le nommer et il faut le
comprendre relativiser ce qui s'est
passé en qualifiant les agresseurs
d'imbéciles fut en effet une erreur
monsieur le premier ministre
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que ses
agresseurs très inorganisés défendent
l'extraterritorialité de leur espace il
rejette les lois de la république
il refuse toute autorité venue de l'état
est il interdit ça la république de
s'occuper de leurs affaires ils font
session monsieur le premier ministre
c'est cela que vous devez nommé et
combattre avec la plus grande fermeté
monsieur le premier ministre comment
envisagez-vous de rétablir l'autorité de
l'état autorité que vous devez à nos
concitoyens qu'ils soient dans les
yvelines où ailleurs dans la en france
merci pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur le premier
ministre
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice la première partie
de votre question m'est adressée
personnellement il s'agit de savoir si
je connais chanteloup les vignes
la réponse est oui j'ai la chance de
connaître cette commune des yvelines se
connaît la maire de chanteloup les
vignes je me suis rendu en tant que
premier ministre j'ai visité un certain
nombre de quartiers le commissariat j'ai
pu rencontrer ce qui pour le compte des
services de l'état et en tant qu'élus
locaux gèrent cette commune et essaie
d'apporter les réponses les plus
adaptées à une situation dont nous
savons qu'elle est dans cette ville
difficile donc la réponse est oui
vous évoquez ensuite les événements qui
sont survenus samedi dernier en début de
soirée l'attak le guet-apens contre les
forces de police l'incendié criminel sur
l'équipement culturel de chanteloup les
vignes vins sur à des équipements
culturels de chanteloup les vignes et
vous me dites que pour bien traiter les
questions il faut savoir les nommer vous
faites se faisant référence
la qualification que j'ai pu avoir de
petite bande d'imbéciles comme je suis
comme vous attacher à la parole publique
et aussi aux positions qui sont prises
par les élus locaux je me permets de
vous faire remarquer madame la sénatrice
que le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines que vous
connaissez comme moi que vous respectez
comme moi a pour sa part utilisé le
terme crétin je ne sais pas s'il est
plus léger plus infamant plus
responsable plus dur que petite bande
d'imbéciles je ne sais pas si le terme
racaille ou sauvageons qui a été
utilisée qui ont été utilisés la vérité
la vérité mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs la vérité mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs c'est que je
crois que nous pourrions tous nous
entendre sur le fait que ceux qui
comptent plus que le choix dans le champ
lexical que nous faisons c'est la
réalité des faits et la réalité des
réponses la réalité des réponses madame
la sénatrice est la suivante nous
souhaitons mettre tout en oeuvre pour
que l'ordre soit rétabli
lorsqu'il est dérangé et pour ce faire
nous essayons d'attaquer le problème de
toutes les façons possibles lorsque nous
doublons madame la sénatrice le budget
de l'anru nous ne le faisons pas pour le
plaisir simplement de doubler un budget
nous le faisons parce que à l'ecoute des
élus locaux nous savons que les
opérations de rénovation urbaine sont
des éléments puissants de réponse à ce
problème et je le sais parce que
j'écoute madame la maire de chanteloup
les vignes
parce que j'écoute le cas échéant le
président du conseil départemental des
yvelines et parce que madame la
sénatrice
j'ai été maire du havre et je sais ce
que c'est clos rue et je sais ce que
c'est que les opérations de rénovation
urbaine et je sais ce que c'est que les
violences urbaines
par expérience voilà je préfère le dire
clairement et simplement je ne parle pas
de façon théorique je parle parce que je
sais que les opérations de rénovation
urbaine permettent d'apporter n'ont pas
toutes les réponses mais une partie des
réponses que ces quartiers existe c'est
la même exactement la même logique que
je poursuis lorsque avec l'ensemble du
gouvernement
nous essayons d'augmenter les effectifs
de la police nationale
dix mille effectifs supplémentaires dans
la police nationale
dans l'ensemble du quinquennat qui a
commencé en 2007 pourquoi pas pour le
plaisir d'augmenter les effectifs parce
que malheureusement ces effectifs font
défaut et que nous savons que pour
apporter une réponse crédible
nous devons améliorer le niveau de
présence des forces de l'ordre
c'est ce que le ministre de l'intérieur
le secrétaire d'état et c'est de faire
lorsque nous des doublons les classes de
cp
lorsque nous essayons de faire en sorte
que l'éducation fonctionne mieux y
compris dans les zones et surtout dans
les zones dites sensibles
c'est exactement la même logique nous
essayons d'aborder cette question par
tous les bouts si vous me permettez
cette expression
nous sommes parfaitement conscients de
la difficulté nous avons évoqué avec
madame la maire de chanteloup les vignes
ses difficultés
j'observe et c'est intéressant et je
sais que vous y serez sensible puisque
vous êtes attachés comme moi à ce que
disent les élus locaux
j'observe qu'elle a parfaitement pointé
le fait que nous venons perturber des
trafics de stupéfiants à chanteloup les
vignes comme dans d'autres villes et que
lorsque
on perturbe ses trafics lorsque l'on
vient briser des habitudes et des
habitudes néfastes et criminel eh bien
ça se voit ça crée forcément des
turbulences et nous devons les affronter
ne pas nous horrifier de ces turbulences
elles sont la conséquence d'une action
résolue et nous allons poursuivre cette
action car la lutte contre le trafic de
stupéfiants la préparation du futur dans
ses quartiers dans ces villes est un des
objectifs du gouvernement et je suis sûr
que vous le partagez madame 2 sidrac que
nous partagions les objectifs j'en suis
tout à fait consciente monsieur le
premier ministre et je vous en remercie
bien évidemment en revanche vous me
parlez de sémantique et moi je vous
parle de l'autorité de l'état et je ne
pense pas que vous m'ayez répondu le
constat nous le partageons nous sommes
d'accord avec vous bien évidemment j'y
étais fière aussi à chanteloup les
vignes avec vos ministres
simplement aujourd'hui l'autorité de
l'état est absente dans ces quartiers et
c'est cela que nous vous demandons merci
[Applaudissements]
à notre collègue olivier cadic pour le
groupe de l'union centriste
bien sûr président va question s'adresse
à madame la secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes au sujet de la
visite du président emmanuel macron en
chine le président de la république a
raison
seule l'union européenne dans une
approche coordonnée ou devenir je le
cite un partenaire crédible et efficace
de la chine
en effet la france ne peut pas s'engager
seul en chine
elle n'a pas la taille critique pour
contrebalancer l'émergence de cette
puissance aux aspirations dominatrice
s'il est légitime que la chine veille
s'affirmer comme une grande puissance
mondiale
elle trace son chemin largement à
l'écart des règles du jeu hors
occidentale fondée sur la réciprocité
des échanges la transparence commerciale
et la probité juridique ne parlons même
pas de valeurs démocratiques ou de
libertés publiques
le régime chinois construit un monde
orwellien pour assurer l'unité de son
peuple dans un espace clos par une cyber
muraille de chine
c'est au sein de ce monde hermétique que
se développent leurs champions nationaux
comme huawei ou alibaba
il serait suicidaire pour l'union
européenne de continuer à laisser la
chine
investir sur nos marchés sans bénéficier
d'un principe de réciprocité
ce qui est interdit à nos entreprises en
chine doit être interdit aux entreprises
chinoises dans l'union européenne
comment pensez vous imposer la
réciprocité des échanges entre la chine
et l'union européenne
chômage et pour vous répondre la parole
est là madame la secrétaire d'état
chargé des affaires européennes madame
de montchanin
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs effectivement ce que vous
dites est totalement vrai en mars
d'ailleurs l'union européenne a reconnu
à son niveau pour la première fois que
la chine est à la fois un partenaire
mais aussi un concurrent est un rival
et à ce moment là nous avons arrêté un
certain nombre d'actions concrètes pour
obtenir davantage de réciprocité dans
notre relation avec la chine et nous
assurer du maintien de conditions de
concurrence qui soit équitable et qui
soit fondé sur un respect mutuel de nos
règles
la visite d'état du président de la
république en chine qui s'achève
aujourd'hui à est permis de poursuivre
et d'amplifier sa dynamique impulsée
également lors de la visite du président
chinois en mars avec jean claude juncker
et angela merkel qui était présent pour
justement incarner sa dimension
européenne est arrivé à construire un
partenariat euro chinois ambitieux à la
hauteur des différents enjeux notamment
et vous l'avez rappelé dans le cadre de
la protection des données personnelles
c'est la priorité
effectivement celle du commerce et des
investissements et la participation du
président à la foire des importations de
shanghai avec le président chinois était
un moment important pour rééquilibrer
nos relations économiques par le haut
alors aujourd'hui un acte important a
été posée il concerne les accords sur
les indications géographiques et ce sont
sans indication géographique chinoise
sans européenne dont 26 françaises qui
vont bénéficier d'un haut degré de
protection dès l'entrée en vigueur de
l'accord en france cela veut dire
concrètement que nos producteurs de
côtes de provence de roquefort de
pruneaux d'agen seront mieux protégés
pourront plus exporter et pourront plus
se développer
ce sont là des exemples et vous imaginez
bien qu'ils sont indicatifs ensuite nous
avons cherché à avancer dans un accord
yoshi sur les investissements la
protection d'un investissement
stratégique et nos actifs stratégiques
le point clé pour moi c'est le volet
multilatéral c'est inciter la chine à
réformer
l'om c'est pour qu'elles puissent
traiter de pratiques commerciales
déloyales et c'est la continuité de la
déclaration franco-chinoise sur le
multilatéralisme
nous pensons que plutôt que de se mettre
des tarifs réciproque comme celle qui
avec les états unis
dialoguer avec fermeté et l'avenir tout
cas des amis
la chine n'est pas un état de droit
c'est un état de loi elle ne
s'embarrasse pas de principes de
transparence de loyauté pour décrocher
des marchés publics à l'international
pour vendre en chine
toute l'industrie cosmétique doit passer
par le site alibaba et on peut donc se
demander quel sera l'avenir des brevets
des molécules cosmétiques les
entreprises européennes ont besoin de
protection commerciale comme nous
l'avons porté pendant la campagne des
européennes notre groupe union centriste
insiste face à la chine
nous devons avoir une stratégie pour
défendre l'union européenne qui est lui
un espace de droit merci
la parole est à notre collègue françoise
cartron pour le groupe de la république
en marche
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président la question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale à la rentrée 2010
hui d évaluation au cp ce1 ont été mises
en place afin d'identifier les
compétences acquises par les élèves
ainsi que leurs difficultés
en comparaison les mêmes évaluation
nationale réalisée cette année font
apparaître
vous l'avez déclaré dimanche et je vous
cite des progrès significatifs chez les
enfants ainsi évalué progrès sur la
fluidité de lecture et de la capacité de
calcul progrès notés dans les
territoires les plus défavorisés
soyons clairs dix des treize critères
évalués en ce1 montre d'une amélioration
par rapport à l'année dernière mais en
même temps une faible majorité des
colliers a acquis le niveau attendu
en ce qui concerne la maîtrise des
opérations additions soustractions
bien sûr nous ne pouvons qu'espérer que
ces progrès se confirmeront et
s'amplifieront et ce dans l'intérêt des
enfants
nous le souhaitons bien entendu toutes
et tous dans cet hémicycle
aussi afin que ces résultats
s'inscrivent dans une dynamique positive
sur le long terme
pourriez vous monsieur le ministre nous
éclairer sur ce qui selon vous explique
cette amélioration
elles sont parties liées au dédoublement
des classes ou à 10 et où et des
évolutions de pratiques pédagogiques
avez vous une analyse territoriale de
cette évolution positive zones rurales
très près plus afin que cette
progression deviennent une tendance
lourde
horrible
les dispositifs qui seront ainsi
pérenniser les initiatives nouvelles qui
de mai pourrait être mise en place
merci pour vos réponses la parole et
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse féminine
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
même la sénatrice françoise cartron
c'est évidemment une question
essentielle si s'il y en avait s'il y en
avait et je me réjouis de l'unanimité
nationale sur une telle question là
s'il n'y en avait qu'une en matière
d'éducation ce rsa serait celle ci nous
le savons tous énormément de choses se
jouent entre 0 et 7 ans le bon départ
scolaire de tous les enfants de france
détermine beaucoup de choses pour la
suite
en matière de justice sociale est tout
simplement de bon niveau général de
notre pays
c'est pourquoi ces résultats doivent
nous encourager il nous encourage à
plusieurs titres d'abord il faut noter
que les résultats sont stagnants pour le
début de cp et mon temps pour le début
de c1 ce qui nous montrent donc des
résultats pour l'année de cp de l'an
dernier autrement dit le résultat
d'efforts qui ont été fait l'an dernier
en matière notamment de dédoublement des
classes et aussi en matière de pratiques
pédagogiques mais cela nous montre aussi
qu'il ya tout un travail qui reste à
faire notamment à l'école maternelle
puisque nous savons que en particulier
sur la question de la maîtrise du
vocabulaire
si un enfant arrive en cp avec un
vocabulaire trop faible il aura des
difficultés à rentrer dans la lecture et
l'écriture
cela justifie pleinement une politique
prioritaire de l'école maternelle et
renvoie la question que vous posez sur
le futur comme vous le savez nous allons
dédoubler les grandes sections de
maternelle en rep et aurait plus de
façon à ce qu'ils aient des classes de
12 et améliorer le taux des cadres
d'encadrement partout puisque nous
allons garantir qu'il n'y ait pas plus
de 24 élèves par classe dans toute la
france en grande section de maternelle
au cp et on s'est eu à et on se bat tous
ces éléments vont évidemment contribué
aux améliorations nécessaires
il en est à noter que d'ores et déjà
nous constatons deux améliorations que
chacun peut voir sur le site du
ministère
une en début de c1 qui donc montre ce
qui s'est fait en cp et une autre qui
est la réduction de l'écart entre réseau
d'éducation prioritaire et reste du pays
là où il y avait 12 points d'écart
canton résultats en lecture
il ya désormais dix points d'écart il
nous reste donc encore du chemin à faire
bien entendu mais c'est encourageant
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue jean yves roux pour le groupe
du rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
merci monsieur le président à ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'action et des comptes
publics
il ya quelques jours nous étions sur ces
bains pour soutenir les élus faciliter
l'exercice quotidien de leur mandat et
encourager leur vocation au service de
leurs concitoyens
que s'était-il monsieur le ministre vous
permettez le site et votre collègue en
charge des collectivités territoriales
est il indiqué si les élus souhaitent
que nous corrigions les défauts des
référents passé ils veulent aussi de la
stabilité
je ne dirais pas mieux mais monsieur le
ministre ce qui vaut en matière
institutionnelle vocia matière de
finances locales
car pour assurer efficacement l'ensemble
des services à la population
les communes pc doivent disposer de
réelles capacités d'action en la matière
l'inquiétude est grande en effet élus et
candidats qui préparent leur programme
municipal sur des bases crédible
viennent de prendre connaissance des
simulations des conséquences de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation sur
le potentiel fiscal
le mécanisme est pourtant bien connu
malgré une compensation à l'euro près la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation jour
en nécessairement sur le potentiel
fiscal et dont sur le niveau des
dotations d'état et des péréquations
correspondantes sont ainsi appelés à
vera palais a varié dès 2023 et donc un
cours de mandat près de 11 des 18
critères de répartition pour les
communes
nous sommes loin de la stabilité de la
visibilité fiscales nécessaires à
l'exercice serein du mandat d'élu sur la
base de ces simulations les communes les
plus pauvres deviendrait subitement plus
riches grâce à une hausse mécanique de
leur potentiel fiscal est donc moins
aidées par l'état tandis que les
communes et plus riche est
connaîtrez la transition et la
trajectoire inverse
où est la logique fiscale où est la
solidarité nationale où est l'esprit de
la décentralisation
monsieur le ministre
mes interrogations sont donc simples
comment et quand comptez-vous
concrètement corriger les effets
néfastes des variations du potentiel
fiscal et allez vous accueillir les
propositions des sénateurs qui souhaite
rectifier dès maintenant les
conséquences majeures induite par la fin
de la taxe d'habitation pour vous
répondre la parole et à monsieur le
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'action des comptes publics monsieur du
choc doivent et la parole merci à
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jean yves roux vous relayer les
interrogations des élus locaux en
particulier votre département sur les
finances locales et la réforme de la
fiscalité locale
j'entends deux interrogations majeures
une interrogation sur la stabilité et la
visibilité et interrogations techniques
sur le potentiel fiscal qui sert de
référence au calcul des critères d'accès
à telle ou telle dotation sur la
stabilité nous pouvons rassurer les élus
depuis le début de ce quinquennat nous
avons fait le choix de stabiliser les
dotations à un niveau global et le
budget pour 2020 prévoit la stabilité
détonations stabilité la dgf stabilité
des dotations d'investissement et légère
augmentation des concours de l'état aux
collectivités qui passe de 48,3 à 49,1
milliards d'euros la lisibilité nous la
trouvons aussi dans la volonté de
trouver un modèle de compensation la
taxe d'habitation pour les collectivités
soit un modèle simple et qui répondent
aux engagements du président de la
république simple par le transfert et
l'attribution de la quasi totalité la
taxe foncière aux communes avec un
pouvoir de taux dès 2021 dynamique parce
que c'est la recette fiscale simple et
dynamique pour les départements et les
intercommunalités avec l'affectation
d'une fraction tva pour compenser la
perte des recettes fiscales afférentes
ces dynamiques à hauteur de 3% par an
dans votre question il ya une partie
plus technique et c'est une litote
technique parce que ça concerne le
potentiel fiscal qui je disais détermine
l'accès au nom des communes des
collectivités locales à telle ou telle
dotation de péréquation avec jacqueline
gourault nous l'avons dit lors de notre
audition par le comité des finances
locales le 26 septembre
j'ai eu l'occasion de le redire il ya
quelques jours devant la délégation
collectivités territoriales de votre
assemblée
nous proposons de mettre à profit les
premiers mois de l'année 2020 et toutes
les contributions sont les bienvenues
pour voir si le potentiel fiscal peut
être redéfinie si nous pouvons améliorer
cet indicateur de la mesure de richesse
théorique
des communes et des territoires c'est
une entreprise difficile extrêmement
compliquée techniquement et si nous
n'arrivions pas ce qui peut arriver si
nous n'arrivions pas à le modifier dans
un sens qui soit correct nous mettrons à
profit le plf 2021 pour neutraliser les
effets de la réforme de la taxe
d'habitation
hiller question pour le gouvernement que
la réforme de la taxe d'habitation la
suppression la suppression d'un tel
d'habitation et la réforme de la
fiscalité locale se traduisent par une
évolution artificielle d'un indicateur
qui conditionne l'accès à telle ou telle
notation
merci la parole est à notre collègue
laurence cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes avaient
la parole merci monsieur le président la
réforme de l'assurance-chômage instauré
par décret et qui est entré en vigueur
le 1er novembre est un véritable
cataclysme 850 mille chômeurs et
chômeuses on voir leurs indemnités
baissé de 20% et 200000 vont être privés
de toute indemnité
ce sont plus d'un million de personnes
qui vont être frappés de plein fouet
croyez-vous sérieusement adam la
ministre que cette demandeuse d'emploi
qui a interpellé le président macron à
la réunion en lui disant il n'y a pas de
travail comment fait-on avec 790 euros
par mois va voir sa situation améliorée
c'est tout le contraire qui va se
produire et vous le savez et ce sont des
secteurs aux contrats discontinue qui
vont être davantage impacté
l'hôtellerie-restauration spectacle et
pas de nettoyage pour ne prendre que
quelques exemples
votre réforme va enfoncer la tête dans
l'eau des plus précaires c'est une
réforme sexistes et anti jeunes les
syndicats et les associations de priver
d'emploi sont vent debout debout contre
une telle réforme et appelle très
justement à manifester le 30 novembre et
le 5 décembre les agents de pôle emploi
se disait aussi choqué par ces nouvelles
règles ma question est simple madame la
ministre
avec cette réforme inique vous comptez
faire une économie de 4,5 milliards
d'euros en trois ans pourquoi ne pas
vous attaquer aux allègements de
cotisations patronales qui de 2013 à
2019 ont atteint les 26 milliards
d'euros
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre à baye dame pénicaud
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice laurence
cohen je ne reconnais pas du tout la
réforme de l'assurance chômage lorsque
vous dites
d'abord je voudrais dire que il faut pas
nier les faits d'abord notre politique
en matière de marché du travail commence
à porter des fruits et nous sommes
modestes s'il en reste beaucoup à faire
dans le département du val de marne par
exemple c'est le chômage est passé de
8,3 à 7,4 pour cent
ça c'est le fruit de travail
systématique sur la formation sur
l'apprentissage les ordonnances et
l'assurance chômage va venir
l'assurance chômage vous ne l'avez pas
du tout parlé si un triptyque pourquoi
nous modifions les règles de l'assurance
chômage
parce que le contexte a changé
aujourd'hui nous avons créé un demi
million d'emplois en france du secteur
économique avec les aides du
gouvernement et de et deuxièmement il y
a beaucoup d'emplois vacants j'étais à
la réunion avec le président de la
république je peux vous dire qu'il ya
énormément d'emplois avait quand même à
la réunion où évidemment il ya un taux
de chômage qui est inacceptable qui est
très difficile c'est pour ça que cette
réforme c'est un triptyque 1 sur les
employeurs nous visons moins de
précarité pour ça nous pénalisons les
employeurs qui abusent des contrats
courts car le premier sujet de la
pauvreté c'est le chômage
la vraie trappe à la provôté c'est le
chômage et la précarité qui instaurait
par des contrats beaucoup trop court ne
font mouche sur 10 son contrat très
court nous nous battons contre eux ce ça
avec le bonus malus avec le ctd eu vous
ne l'avez pas fait avant personne ne l'a
fait avant nous nous y attaquer le
deuxième sujet c'est l'accompagnement
des demandeurs d'emploi de façon inédite
un million de demandeurs d'emploi va
avoir un accompagnement beaucoup plus
important beaucoup plus pro actif comme
le font très bien les pays scandinaves
comme nous l'avons testé avec des
demandeurs d'emploi à nice et dans
d'autres agences pour l'emploi car je
vais beaucoup dans les agences pôle
emploi
je peux vous dire que c'est très fort
mal vient des problèmes du terrain et
des solutions qu'on amène au problème du
terrain et l'accompagnement il va avoir
des effets le troisième sujet sur le
sujet de l'indemnisation le sujet de
l'indemnisation
il faut revenir à la normale la normale
c'est ce que les partenaires sociaux
avaient négocié avant crise quand il ya
de l'emploi
quand il ya une dynamique en même temps
que du chômage il faut à la fois
protéger et inciter au retour à l'emploi
c'est ce que
faisons et c'est ce que nous faisons
pour l'emploi et contre la précarité
adam cohen madame la ministre mon propos
de convainc que vous même parce que la
réalité quand vous nous parler des
chiffres du val de marne ce sont les
radiations c'est ça la réalité et votre
réforme madame la ministre qu'est ce que
c'est c'est une machine à faire exploser
la précarité et la pauvreté plus de 9
millions de pauvres dans notre pays
aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est suffisant et inacceptable alors
pourquoi vous allez encore grossir le
rang
vous avez décidé de supprimer
l'observatoire national de la pauvreté
mais madame la ministre casser le
thermomètre ne fait pas baisser la
fièvre
votre politique signé un dépôt plus
généreuse quand il s'agit de servir les
plus aisés qui voient leurs revenus
augmenter de 1% et il faut que vous
arrêtiez avec cette politique et il faut
que vous arrêtiez de faire de la com
les gens attendent autre chose de
mesures ils seront dans la rue
nombreuses et nombreux on sera avec eux
parlaient pas notre collègue claude
bérit-debat pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues punition catastrophe
sociale trappe à pauvreté
autant de mots entendus pour qualifier
votre réforme de l'assurance chômage et
je le fais mien sans réserve pour votre
gouvernement le cap est clair à droite
toute cette réforme imposée par décret
et pour reprendre les mots de laurent
berger c'est une réforme les plus durs
socialement qui s'est opérée ces 25
dernières années avec les nouvelles
conditions draconiennes d'accès au droit
on estime qu'en 2020 sur les 2,6
millions de personnes qui auraient
bénéficié des aménités avec un système
près de 10%
ne pouvant ouvrir aucun droit et 23 %
des bénéficiaires verront leurs droits
rognés pour une question purement
comptable pire au 1er avril 2020 avec
votre nouveau mode de calcul 1,4 million
de demandeurs d'emploi verront leurs
indemnités baisser drastiquement les
personnes ayant un rythme de travail
fractionné déjà précaires seront les
premiers impactés madame la ministre
vous faites des économies sur le dos des
plus fragiles vous culpabiliser les
chômeurs vous en fait des boucs
émissaires sans leur donner les moyens
de retrouver un véritable emploi alors
arrêter cette politique de régression et
de ségrégation sociale
mettez en place des mesures ambitieuses
pour résorber le chômage
lutter contre la précarité et
accompagner réellement les chômeurs vers
l'emploi pour vous répondre
nico
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur claude bérit débat
vous parlez avec des grands mots moi je
vais vous parler avec des faits nos
politiques
elles ont de l'effet est ce que vous
savez que c'est en dordogne car + 76 %
d'apprentis au premier semestre
et ça c'est notre politique et ça va
continuer car nous allons sortir plus
encore de chômeurs qu'ils puissent
retrouver un emploi depuis deux ans nous
avons permis à trois cent mille
demandeurs d'emploi de retrouver un
travail
ça ça plus pourquoi parce que nous
faisons un investissement sans précédent
et aucun gouvernement l'a fait avant
dans tout ce qui aide les demandeurs
d'emploi l'année prochaine il y aura
neuf cent soixante mille demandeurs
d'emploi en formation est jeune il
demandant le point information nous
aurons nous investissons plus d'un
milliard d'euros dans la zee d'insertion
par l'économique dans le budget qui vous
sera présenté dans quelques semaines et
j'espère bien vous le vôtre et puisque
vous connais vous vous souhaitez
l'insertion des plus vénérables lui
n'est inemployable mais il faut des
marchepieds pour les aider en ce qui
concerne les indemnisations du chômage
moi je m'étonne que sur ses bancs
certains pensent que le travail c'est
moins bien que le chômage
nous sommes inscrits en faux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis factuel un demandeur
sur plan un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq
un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq gagne
plus au chômage qu'au travail
c'est cela dont l'indemnité baisse au
début il car le même capital de droit
ils pourront être divisé plus longtemps
s'ils trouvent pas d'emploi n'ai eu
aucune déviation de leur capital de
droit mais un cinquième et tous les
experts l'ont confirmé
ce n'est pas la faute de gens c'est les
règles qu'on fait les partenaires
sociaux ils n'ont pas vu l'angle mort
que sacré ils n'ont pas fait exprès mais
maintenant il faut le corriger
le travail doit les payer plus que le
chômage nous croyons à l'insertion à la
formation au travail c'est la société
qu'on veut faire et donc il est injuste
que quelqu'un aujourd'hui et 150 % de
son salaire au chômage alors que les
autres et ça reste très protecteur tout
le monde rentre 65 96 % de son salaire
oui pour le travail non compris
et vous pour l'insertion monsieur bérit
débat
si je parle avec de grands mots madame
la ministre vous vous parlez de façon
technocratique et manque et vous manqué
singulièrement d'humanité parce que
derrière les beaux chiffres juste à city
qu'il ya des hommes et des femmes qui
sont dans la misère sociale et ce n'est
pas en essayant de les monter les uns
contre les autres à des seyante de dire
l'assistanat et il faut le dénoncer
essayez madame la ministre de passer de
l'autre côté de la rue d'aller
rencontrer ces hommes et et france de
les écouter et arrêter de stigmatiser
mais plutôt désormais lutter ne luttait
pas contre les chômeurs faut conclure
véritablement contre le chômage
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
céline vous voulez espérons y est pour
le groupe l'est républicain
mais ce monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le ministre à paris la sécurité
se dégrade de manière forte et rapide
depuis début 2010 9
les vols ont augmenté de 12% les
cambriolages de 8% et les violences
sexuelles de 5% pendant que la mairie de
paris et la préfecture de police se
renvoient la balle
ce sont les parisiens qui trinquent
aucun territoire parisien n'est
désormais épargné puisque 51% de vols
avec violence dans le 20e arrondissement
dans mon arrondissement le 16e
les cambriolages ont explosé avec 18 %
d'augmentation et 62%
oui bon c'est pat way 60 2 % de vols de
véhicules 100% de dégradations de
mobilier urbain dans le 10ème et ce sont
les parisiens qui payent la facture
ça vous fait rire pas moi votre métier
ce n'est pas d'interpeller la société
c'est d'interpeller les délinquants et
je ne parle même pas de la crise des
gilet jaune et des désagréments causés
au parisien il y a une spécificité
historique dans la capitale qui est que
les pouvoirs de police sont confiés non
pas aux mères nées au préfet de police
et vous ne devez pas que constater mais
agir
alors monsieur le ministre où en est on
de la réforme tant attendue de la
préfecture de police
la lutte contre la délinquance n'est pas
un sujet secondaire en termes de
doctrine sécuritaire je ne connaît que
deux mots la fermeté et le résultat
pour vous répondre je vais la parole aux
traders et auprès du ministre intérieur
horaire après mes chers collègues m'ont
préambule n'est pas simplement un ex
voto on se respectent les uns les autres
et on s'écoute
voilà
ce ministre
monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
je ne peux effectivement que vous
confirmer qu'au cours des neuf premiers
mois de l'année 2019 la délinquance a
augmenté à paris vous l'avez cité
matière de cambriolages de vols
violences d' atteinte à l'intégrité
physique des personnes comme vous l'avez
souligné en fonction des arrondissements
et des catégories de délinquance
la situation est plus contrastée nous
avons demandé avec christophe castaner
au préfet de police de mettre en place
un plan de lutte contre la délinquance
efficace qu'il a mis en place depuis le
mois d'avril qui porte ce sur deux
piliers d'abord une présence renforcée
des effectifs sur la voie publique
notamment dans le cadre des quartiers de
reconquête républicaine où les effectifs
ont augmenté notamment dans le 10ème et
dans le 18e et puis nous avons aussi au
sein même de la préfecture de police
demandé à certains effectifs qui
d'habitude sont affectés à des tâches
tendre public de patrouiller comme des
effectifs de sécurité publique quand ils
n'ont pas de missions d'ordre public à
accomplir et ça c'est une réforme
importante qui se traduit par des
effectifs supplémentaires sur la voie
publique et puis vous l'avez citer
également nous souhaitons qu'il y à un
meilleur équilibre dans la répartition
des tâches entre ce qui relève de la
préfecture de police dans l'encadrement
de manifestations récréatives sportives
culturelles et ce qui doit relever de la
ville de paris et ce travail il est en
cours il est mené par le préfet de
police
et puis il ya le deuxième pilier sur les
investigations judiciaires
nous démentons énormément de réseaux
notamment de trafics divers et variés
cambriolage subi au mois de septembre un
réseau a été démantelé qui avait commis
plus de 136 fait les faits élucidés
augmente également à paris donc il faut
saluer l'activité des fonctionnaires de
police
cette réorientation que nous avons
souhaité avec le ministre de l'intérieur
que nous avons demandé au préfet de
police
elle commence à porter ses fruits madame
la sénatrice nous avons plus d'effectifs
sur la voie publique et puis surtout
nous avons une hausse qui est beaucoup
moins forte sur les derniers mois de
l'année en matière d'atteintes aux biens
et puis en matière d'atteintes aux
personnes j'enregistre ont même sur
juillet août et pour la première fois
une baisse donc nous allons poursuivre
la réorientation de cette action et pour
ce qui est de la réforme de la
préfecture de police
elle est examinée actuellement dans le
cadre du livre blanc sur lequel nous
vas y merci voilà bull espère gagner on
est en effet je confirme que en matière
de sécurité il ya deux choses qui sont
importantes qui sont les moyens et la
réponse pénale
je note qu'elle approche des élections
municipales chacun fait des volte face
qui sont assez spectaculaires donc on ne
peut que se réjouir
la maire de paris qui est
idéologiquement et pour des raisons
espérer et si historique pardon était
contrait hystérique aussi way était
contre été contre était contre le
développement de la vidéoprotection
il lui a fallu trois mandatures pour s'y
résoudre et même dans votre parti
présidentiel conclure notre griveaux ce
matin dit qu'il était pour la police
municipale armée on ne peut que saluer
il faut pour plus face est en tout cas
ça souligne que les chiffres sont
mauvais et que nous vous attendons sur
un plan pour la réforme de la préfecture
de police je vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue à la
victoire jasmin pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre de la transition écologique
et solidaire qui n'est pas mais qui
remplaçait et par dessus les transports
afin d'évoquer un sujet un des sujets de
la vie quotidienne dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer les différentes visites du
chef de l'état à mayotte et à l'île de
la réunion mais aussi du premier
ministre et des membres du gouvernement
ont quelque peu déçu
chacun a pu constater les manifestations
à l'île de la réunion
compte tenu que ces différentes visites
donnent aux ir ne permettent pas
toujours d'aborder les véritables
problèmes
madame la ministre j'ai eu l'occasion de
vous alerter sur les difficultés
rencontrées par les transporteurs de
passagers et de marchandises sur nos
routes
ils le peuvent exercer pleinement leur
métier l'unostra ne sait plus quoi faire
face aux menaces et aux risques de
crises de risque de chômage de leurs
mandants en effet les pratiques
tarifaires en matière d'assurance du
véhicule sont désormais un vrai problème
dans nos territoires et plus
singulièrement en guadeloupe le métier
de transporteur de passagers est menacée
compte tenu des tarifs exorbitants
proposés par les compagnies en absence
de concurrence face à des monopoles et
des oligopoles organisée c'est
inacceptable
de plus les flottes doivent respecter
désormais toutes les normes de
conformité notamment les normes
environnementales les polices
d'assurances sont en outre mer 50 % plus
cher plus élevé que dans l'hexagone pour
un vécu présentant les mêmes
caractéristiques
de plus les conditions générales de
souscription elle aussi présente de
profondes inégalités des disparités
inqualifiable madame la ministre et a
représenté ici votre gouvernement met
souvent en avant l'égalité pour
justifier la suppression de tout ce que
vous considérez comme étant des
avantages pour nos territoires
ultramarins vous envisagez d'été revenir
alors je souhaite et je vous demande
comment envisagez-vous de mettre en
place des moyens de lutte contre les
inégalités
et l'illégalité compte tenu également
des conséquences prévisibles à la fois
soliste d'emplois directs et indirects
et sur la mobilité dans nos territoires
pour répondre à la parole du secrétaire
d'état en charge des transports monsieur
du baril vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je prie d'abord excusé la l'absence de
lisbeth bornes qui est et en déplaçant
avec le président de la république dire
que j'ai pu m'imprégner très
concrètement des sujets de transport à
l'occasion notamment de la visite du
président à mayotte et à la réunion où
nous avons été en mesure d'apporter des
réponses très concrètes sont les sujets
routier et aérien
vous avez parlé un peu d'écologie et de
la transition qui s'opèrent je veux
rappeler toutefois les dispositions qui
sont mises en oeuvre par le gouvernement
notamment la prime à la conversion qui
permet d'accompagner tous les français
de l'hexagone et d'outre-mer c'est un
milliard d'euros qui auraient été versés
pour les 600 mille demandeurs depuis le
à la date du 1er octobre 2019 et cela
permet d'économiser des centaines
d'euros par an et nous avons recentré
ses années la prime sur les 20 % des
français les plus modestes ceux qui sont
les actifs qui se déplacent le plus loin
et enfin nous avons recentré les
critères environnementaux pour être dans
une logique de justice fiscale sociale
et environnementale
nous mettons les moyens notamment en
outre-mer vous savez que le contrat de
plan devenait contrat de convergence
bénéficient de crédits supplémentaires
24 millions en plus des 200 millions
qu'il était qui était budgété soit 227
millions pour la génération de contrats
qui termine en 2022 et nous lançons un
quatrième appel à projets autour des
pôles d'échangés multimodaux et du
transport collectif et j'invite dès à
présent vos territoires a candidaté pour
cet appel à projet de 450 millions
d'euros qui sera disponible dès l'année
prochaine sur la question des assurances
je termine par là que vous avez bien
voulu soulever
cette question est bien identifié par le
gouvernement vous savez que monsieur le
maire madame girardin et même bourreau
pardon ici présentes ont diligenté une
mission igf cgedd pour tirer pleinement
les conséquences de ce sujet d'assurance
qui concerne les transporteurs routiers
mais au delà et que la mission recevra
notamment l'unostra à compter de la fin
du mois de novembre
voilà madame la sénatrice les éléments
que je souhaitais apporter à votre
connaissance merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue christine la
barre pour le groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président voilà 21
jours que le liban connaît une situation
de crise situation qui a été déclenchée
par le souhait du gouvernement de taxer
les appels numérique de type whatsapp 7
ce projet de taxe à est une goutte d'eau
en fait qui a fait déborder un vase déjà
plein peut bien plein à savoir une
corruption importante
une situation économique dégradée des
investissements qui s'échappe des
services publics qui sont défaillants
pas d'accès à l'eau courante ni à
l'électricité
par ailleurs ce pays est fortement
fragilisé par la guerre en syrie
lundi l'agencé moody's a dégradé pour la
deuxième fois de l'année la note du pays
qui désormais fait l'objet est qualifiée
de pays spéculatifs le 29 octobre
dernier interrogé à l'assemblée
nationale le ministre des affaires
étrangères a déclaré que la démission du
premier ministre ne fait qu'aggraver la
crise il a par ailleurs présenté les
deux convictions du gouvernement à
savoir appeler les responsables libanais
à garantir la stabilité d'institutions
et écouter la population
cette déclaration a été mal interprétée
par la population locale qui dénonce
dans la rue
l'ingérence des politiques d payer des
pays étrangers dans la politique
nationale du pays
dans une lettre ouverte un plaidoyer
citoyens appellent les nations unies et
la communauté européenne à répondre et à
écouter les véritables attentes des
citoyens à savoir une véritable
indépendance du liban et l'établissement
d'un état laïc
la france est depuis longtemps un ami un
pays
me du liban donc ma question est simple
comment content comptez vous répondre
aux attentes du peuple libanais à savoir
un système politique moins corrompus et
une amélioration de la situation
économique
pour vous répondre la parole et à la
secrétaire d'état en charge des affaires
européennes madame mouche à la merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs balle à la
sénatrice nous ne sommes pas dans
l'ingérence mais nous suivons avec la
plus grande attention la situation est
effectivement ces importantes
manifestations qui réclament
quotidiennement depuis plusieurs
semaines des réformes sur le plan
économique social et politique
le défi vous l'avez dit c'est pour les
autorités libanaises de pouvoir répondre
à ces fortes attentes exprimées par les
libanais dans une situation très fragile
parce que c'est aussi le contrecoup des
crises régionales et d'une économie qui
comme vous le dites ne va pas bien
le besoin de réformes d'ampleur est
reconnu par tous et les manifestations
qui ont conduit à la démission du
ministre premier ministre saad hariri le
29 octobre montre que la suite est
incertaine et que c'est d'abord aux
libanais de l'écrire dans ce contexte au
fond la france dit deux choses
effectivement l'importance de la
stabilité du pays dans un contexte
régional très tendu et d'autre part
l'importance d'écouter la voix des
manifestants et pouvoir leur répondre
parce que leurs demandes de réformes
sont nous semble légitime --donc à la
suite de la démission du premier
ministre
il nous semble essentiel qu'un
gouvernement puisse rapidement être
formé pour conduire des réformes dont le
pays a besoin et dans le contexte de
crise économique sociale politique que
traverse le liban
il revient désormais aux responsables
politiques libanais de faire prévaloir
un esprit d'unité nationale de
responsabilités pour garantir cette
stabilité la sécurité et l'intérêt
général alors dans cet esprit tout doit
être fait pour éviter les provocations
pour éviter les violences
pour préserver le droit des citoyens à
manifester pacifiquement
il est donc essentiel que l'ensemble des
forces politiques facilite dès à présent
la formation d'un nouveau gouvernement
qui puisse répondre aux aspirations
légitimes exprimées par les libanaises
et libanais et puissent aussi prendre
les décisions qui s'imposent
indispensable au rétablissement
économique du pays la france dans le
cadre fixé par la conférence cèdres se
tient prête à soutenir le liban sur
cette voie et dans ce moment crucial la
france comme toujours se tient aux côtés
du peuple libanais
merci madame laborde
oui merci vous n'avez répondu vraiment
qu'un parfaitement à ma question puisque
les manifestations qui se font toujours
jours montre bien que la démission du
premier ministre était certes une
revendication de la population mais
n'était pas la réponse aux problèmes qui
se font jour
aujourd'hui le peuple libanais demande
une nouvelle nouveau système beaucoup
moins corrompus peut-être que dans sur
ce sujet là nous pouvons les accompagner
les aider
je remarque juste qu'aujourd'hui la
seule chose qui se fait jour et
l'annulation du salon du livre
francophone qui devait se tenir à
beyrouth dans les tout prochains jours
mais assez la parole et l autre collègue
line perreault pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à madame agnès buzyn
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame la ministre nous ce tout nous
soutenons l'objectif de libérer du temps
médical visant à faciliter l'accès aux
soins
cette politique publique implique d'une
certaine manière un partage des
compétences entre professionnels les
infirmiers peuvent être formés aux
pratiques avancées
les pharmaciens peuvent désormais
contribuer aux campagnes de vaccination
antigrippale mais ce nouveau partage de
compétences que nous appelons de nos
voeux et source d'incompréhension et
parfois d'un sentiment d'inégalité le
journal de mon département relatait
dernièrement les préoccupations des
infirmiers libéraux suite à l'extension
de la vaccination aux pharmaciens ils ne
comprennent pas ce qu'ils appellent un
glissement des actes infirmiers
ce sentiment est renforcé par une
incompréhension relative à la
tarification de leur a formellement
l'acte de vaccination anti grippale est
facturé de la même manière qu'il soit
opéré par un pharmacien ou par un
infirmier
force est de constater que la
rémunération de 6 euros 39 effectué que
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un acte unique pour
l'infirmier lorsqu'au cours d'une même
séance plusieurs actes inscrit à la
nomenclature sont effectués sur un même
malade
l'acte du coefficient le plus important
est seul inscrit avec son coefficient
propres
le deuxième acte est ensuite noté à 50%
de son coefficient le vaccin ne déroge
pas à la règle
je ne veux pas ici remettre en cause la
facilité de venir se faire vacciner dans
les officines mais dans les communes
rurales infirmiers reste la seule
personne mobile pour pratiquer cet acte
ces deux professions complémentaires
sont donc des maillons essentiels de
notre territoire
pendant cette période d'appropriation du
nouveau dispositif
madame la ministre rendez vous
entendez-vous pardon prendre des mesures
pour que l'acte vaccinal antigrippal
effectué par les infirmiers soient
facturés au même niveau que celui
effectué par les pharmaciens
qu'ils soient associés ou non un autre
acte pour vous répondre la parole et à
madame la ministre des solidarités de la
santé va la musa vous avez la parole
madame la sénatrice evelyne perruchoud
massy pour votre question parce que vous
connaissez mon engagement en faveur de
la vaccination et notamment de
vaccination antigrippale la france
possède une stratégie globale en matière
de lutte contre la grippe pour protéger
par tous les moyens les publics
vulnérables
évitez d hospitalisation des décès et
protéger nos services d'urgence après
avis de la haute autorité de santé j'ai
souhaité harmoniser les compétences des
professionnels de santé impliqués dans
la vaccination contre la grippe que ce
soit les sages femmes les infirmiers les
pharmaciens en 2017 nous avons autorisé
la vaccination par les pharmaciens dans
deux régions puis dans quatre régions en
regardez évaluation des bénéfices pour
la santé publique j'ai décidé de
généraliser le dispositif pour cette
campagne vaccinale à toute la france
s'agissant des infirmiers alors qu'il ne
pouvait pas réaliser la primovaccination
g supprimer cette limitation depuis la
dernière campagne hivernale 2010 de 18
j'attire votre attention sur les
informations parfois erronées qui
circulent notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
les pharmaciens ne sont pas rémunérés
100 euros pour les actes il y à bien une
somme forfaitaire unique de 100 euros
pour les pharmaciens au titre des débats
dédommagement c'est-à-dire espace de
confiance confidentialité et formations
nécessaires
mais les rémunérations pour ces actes
sont équivalentes à savoir 6h30 en
métropole 6 euros 60 dans les autres
mers dans le même temps les infirmiers
libéraux peuvent également facturé les
indemnités de déplacement si les actes
ont lieu au domicile
la politique de prévention et de santé
le jeu mais n'en globe tous les
professionnels de santé sans distinction
et je ne crois pas qu'il faille faire le
jeu de l'opposition des uns aux autres
surtout sur de tels enjeux l'ensemble
des ordres professionnels se sont
d'ailleurs engagés en signant ensemble
une charte de la vaccination notamment
qui vise à augmenter la couverture
vaccinale chez les professionnels de
santé
car il s'agit d'un enjeu déontologique
pour notre pays je vous remercie
merci la parole dès maintenant à notre
collègue anne marie bertrand pour le
groupe l'est républicain
j'avais la parole monsieur président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'intérieur monsieur le
ministre
le public présent dans cet hémicycle ne
peut ni applaudir ni conspué des
orateurs la raison est simple les élus
ne légifère pas sous la menace
c'est un principe essentiel dans une
démocratie
depuis le vote par cette assemblée d'une
loi interdisant le port de signes
religieux lors des sorties scolaires
nombreux sont les sénateurs qui comme
moi ont reçu des mails menaçants allant
jusqu'à espérer notre mort la liste des
cent soixante trois sénateurs ayant voté
cette loi qualifiée par certains et je
cite de scélérate et jeté en pâture
le groupe facebook par le même de
sénateurs nazis et il invite ses membres
à communiquer les lieux de résidence et
les photos de parlementaires qui ont
voté ce texte les intimidations sont
explicites
d'autres collègues jacqueline eustache
brinio auteurs de la ppl qui mène un
combat primordial pour la laïcité a été
contrainte face à la violence des
attaques reçu de se constituer partie
civile
je tiens à lui apporter tout mon soutien
un texte démocratiquement votée par une
assemblée des parlementaires traque est
menacée et monsieur le ministre on ne
vous a pas entendu on ne vous a pas
entendu dénoncer ce qui constitue une
atteinte grave à l'exercice d'une
démocratie sereine pourquoi ce silence
pourquoi vous être question le ministre
de l'intérieur à ce titre quelles
mesures comptez vous prendre pour mettre
fin à ses tentatives d'intimidation est
devant nous nous en inquiéter je vous
remercie pour vous répondre mais
l'interventionnisme l'intérieur merci
merci monsieur le président mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice
je crois que sur ce sujet nous devons
tous nous dresser c'est celui de la
liberté du débat public qui est
particulièrement cher dans un hémicycle
comme celui du sénat et qui est
consubstantiel même à l'engagement
politique de chacune de chacun d'entre
vous et de chacune et chacun d'entre
nous et donc je crois qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire de polémiquer et j'entends
votre interpellation qu'est ce que j'ai
fait qu'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai fait immédiatement la saisine de la
plateforme pharos parce que j'ai été
saisi par votre collègue jacqueline
eustache brinio et j'ai fait ce que je
fais à chaque fois un signalement au
procureur est une expression politique
la plus forte possible pour dénoncer ces
actes d'intimidation totalement
inacceptable et je le fais devant vous
comme je lé fais madame la sénatrice de
façon quasi systématique quand je suis
alerté directement auprès des
parlementaires concernés au 1er
septembre nous avions enregistré 240 4
actes de violence ou de malveillance à
l'égard d'élus ou de parlementaires 212
dans le cadre du mouvement des jeunes 32
dans le cadre du ceta est
systématiquement nous les avons tous
ensemble condamné quels que soient les
désaccords que nous pouvons avoir et que
nous pouvons exprimer dans cet hémicycle
mais c'est la liberté même du débat dans
cet hémicycle qui fait que vous êtes
protégé dans votre prise de parole et
nous vous devons madame la sénatrice
ainsi qu'à chacune et chacun ici la
protection de la police ou d'un gendarme
et chaque fois que nécessaire et des
poursuites sur la protection j'ai donné
instruction précise à chaque préfet que
pour que chaque parlementaire qui
sollicite l'appui le contrôle
l'assistance sur la mise en sécurité de
sa permanence parlementaire par exemple
puissent être accompagnés et je le redis
ici au sénat et puis il ya les
poursuites judiciaires et madame la
garde des sceaux a signé ce matin même
une circulaire à l'ensemble des
procureurs pour que sur ce sujet là
comme sur toutes les menaces qui sont
faites aux élus parlementaires ou élus
locaux
il y est systématiquement une volonté de
recherche de responsabilité et de
sanction pour qu' aucun de ces
comportements totalement scandaleux ne
puisse menacer la liberté d'expression
et la liberté de vote de chacun de nos
élus de la république
merci
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
nathalie de là pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique et social
européen vous avez la parole merci
monsieur présidence monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues au nom du groupe rds
je souhaite saluer l'excellent travail
de nos collègues laurent lafon et
jean-yves rooks dans le cadre de la
mission d'information sénatoriale sur
les nouveaux territoires de l'éducation
sur les quinze préconisations du rapport
je tiens aujourd'hui à mettre en lumière
la problématique de la définition des
zones prioritaires d'éducation ces zones
dites rep pourrais plus répondre à deux
critères cumulatifs les critères sociaux
qui comprennent par exemple pourcentage
d'élèves issus des csp les plus
défavorisés où le taux des boursiers et
un critère géographique unique
le pourcentage d'élèves issus des zones
urbaines sensibles
ainsi les territoires ruraux au sens il
sait sont exclues de ces zones
prioritaires alors qu'ils sont également
fortement impacté par des fractures tant
sociales que géographiques comme
l'éloignement aux pratiques culturelles
ou sportives
je vous parle ici de 36 % de nos écoles
et 20 % de nos élèves
la réalité d'aujourd'hui et les
projections démographiques de demain
démontre que l'offre scolaire de
proximité dans ces territoires ruraux
est un sujet à traiter prioritairement
je vous propose donc de ne pas attendre
monsieur le ministre pour faire évaluer
les propositions de nos collègues aux
fins de les appliquer évaluer 'l'indice
d'éloignement géographique permettrait
de mieux valoriser le travail des
enseignants dans ces territoires et
rendre plus attractifs les postes il
situe aujourd'hui délaissé en gironde le
dialogue de confiance qui s'est instauré
entre les collectivités locales et
l'éducation nationale déconcentré s'est
révélé décisif pour construire une offre
scolaire adapté aux réalités du terrain
aux yeux de notre pertinent dazzan
françois coux toute commune rurale est
traitée à part entière avec des
recrutements à profil et des mesures de
sauvegarde avant toute fermeture un
travail collaboratif qui va bien au delà
des contrats de ruralité un exemple qui
a été révélée par la mission
d'information alors monsieur le ministre
à quand cette redéfinition des zones
prioritaires à quand une généralisée
de l'exemple girondins sur merci pour
vos réponses
la parole est au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice nathalie delattre
je vais avoir le plaisir de répondre
positivement à l'essentiel de vos
questions d'abord je me joins évidemment
à vos compliments sur le rapport des
sénateurs la faune et roux parce que
c'est en effet un point d'appui très
intéressant qui vient en plus s'ajouter
aux rapports qui m'a été remis hier par
madame azéma et monsieur mathiot
intitulé territoire rééducation qui va
justement nous permettre de réfléchir à
l'éducation prioritaire dans une vision
complète n'opposant certainement pas
l'urbain et le rural mais au contraire
permettant d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
vous avez raison jusqu'à présent
l'éducation prioritaire repose peut-être
sur des critères qui ne permettent pas
d'avoir de toucher l'ensemble des élèves
défavorisés de france et nous devons
donc la faire évoluer pour que ce soit
plus dynamique plus efficaces et plus
justes en fait vous avez parlé de
l'indicent d'éloignement comme étant un
indice intéressant est effectivement
comme le demande le rapport j'ai demandé
à la direction de l'évaluation du
ministère de calculer cet indice
d'éloignement essayèrent même que les
premiers résultats sont arrivés donc
nous avons techniquement les moyens
d'intégrer cet enjeu qui en effet est
très important nous prenons déjà un peu
en compte par exemple pour les villages
de montagne où cette question de
l'éloignement et déjà administrativement
prises en compte pour regarder ce qu'on
fait en matière de création ou de
suppressions de postes mais nous allons
le faire de manière plus systématique
certainement dans les temps futurs avec
la remise de ces rapports commence une
nouvelle période qui nous période de
concertation avec bien entendu des
organisations représentatives et bien
entendu la représentation nationale de
sorte que en effet nous allons pouvoir
prendre en compte les éléments du
rapport de messieurs les sénateurs la
faune et roux et que nous allons pouvoir
travailler tous ensemble sur cette
vision complète
d'ores et déjà je tiens à dire que nous
faisons très attention à la ruralité
notamment notamment à travers les
conventions ruralité et du travail puis
sénateur durant est en effet le cas de
la gironde
où j'étais vous le savez bien il ya très
longtemps pour regarder justement ce
travail en finesse qui est fait peut
être emblématique de ce que nous devons
faire pour toute la france je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
maintenant de notre collègue gilbert luc
devinaz ce pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre le 31 août
dernier à villeurbanne
un jeune homme a été tué par un migrant
afghan aux motivations mais là en délire
religieux et troubles psychiatriques
graves
ce drame atroce illustre la nécessité de
soins psychiatriques adaptés pour tous y
compris les migrants
aujourd'hui vous annoncer les mesures
visant à durcir nos conditions d'accueil
parmi celles ci il y à l'instauration du
délai de carence pour les demandeurs
d'asile pour bénéficier de la protection
universelle maladie
avec cette mesure ne prenez vous pas un
double risque d'abord un risque
sanitaire
nous parlons de personne qui souffre
parfois de maladies infectueuses faut-il
attendre que leur pop taji s'aggrave
pour qu'elle soit prise en charge en
durcissant l'accès aux soins
ne faites-vous pas peser un risque
sanitaire pour tous ensuite un risque
juridique
la france a ratifié la directive a que
de l'union européenne son article 19
précise que les états membres doivent
assurer les soins médicaux urgents et
les traitements des maladies
psychiatriques des demandeurs d'asile
monsieur le premier ministre
cette mesure est elle conforme aux
engagements européens de la france pour
me répondre la parole est à madame la
ministre des solidarités de la santé
madame agnès buzyn vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
sénateur de vinasse la ligne que nous
avons choisie est unie de responsabilité
d'humanité nous avons tenu bon sur le
panier de soins nécessaires
grâce à aux rapports effectués par
l'igas et 10 g f qui a eu comme mission
de réfléchir à l'efficience de nos
politiques publiques en matière d'accès
aux soins et ce rapport dit clairement
qu'il ne faut pas restreindre le panier
de soins c'est ce que nous faisons
par contre ce rapport met en évidence un
certain nombre d'abus ou de dévoiement
du système et nous avons pris deux
mesures
l'une qui permet aux demandeurs d'asile
d'accéder à la pum ans avec le même
délai de carence de trois mois que ceux
qui s'appliquent aux ressortissants
français qui arrivent sur le territoire
après avoir vécu à l'étranger ou aux
étrangers arrivés en situation régulière
et qui n'ont pas d'emploi qui accèdent à
la puma uniquement au bout de trois mois
donc c'est simplement une harmonisation
de l'accès à la pum ans et dans le délai
de trois mois
ces étrangers malades ont évidemment
accès aux soins urgents qui comprennent
les soins évidemment urgents vitaux mais
également tous les soins anti contre les
infections
en ce qui concerne les maladies
psychiatriques nous sommes absolument
persuadés que le psycho trauma des
migrants est un vrai sujet donc nous
mettons en place en parallèle de ces
mesures de lutte contre la fraude
nous mettons en place des mesures qui
vous verse et publiques de façon à avoir
un impact cours du primo arrivants un
parcours de santé qui fait un bilan qui
permet de bien orienter des patients
notamment de prendre en charge les
pathologies liées à la migration que ce
soit des pathologies infectieuses ou des
pathologies psychiatriques et donc il y
aura un renforcement du budget dépasse
des permanences d'accès aux soins de
santé
il devra également une expérimentation
qui menait à rennes qui va être déployé
pour voir si ces migrants peuvent être
soignées en médecine de ville et donc
nous avons une mesure à la fois de
rationalisation de l'accès à l'a pu m'en
met en parallèle une action qui vint
vers ces populations pour les prendre en
charge efficacement dès le premier jour
sur les pathologies pour lequel il ya un
réel besoin je vous remets ce
merci monsieur de dinars merci monsieur
le président oui même la ministre lutter
contre les abus je dirais lutter contre
tous les abus qui peut être content mais
là en l'occurrence vous prenez des
mesures envers les plus démunis en
pénalisant l'ensemble des migrants et en
nous faisant prendre un risque sanitaire
en manière de santé faut rester simple
la prévention il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir et c'est encore là la meilleure
des économies merci la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean raymond
hugonnet pour le groupe l'est
républicain vous avez la parole
merci merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des armées
à la veille des cérémonies mémorielle du
11 novembre les représentants du monde
combattant sont en émoi en effet le
devenir de l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre est
plus qu'incertain alors même que le
champ d'intervention de l'onacvg s'est
considérablement étendue avec notamment
la prise en compte des victimes du
terrorisme
le projet de budget 2020 se traduit par
de lourds transferts de charges
reportées sur sa trésorerie
en l'état actuel de la réorganisation de
l'onacvg la débudgétisation ainsi opérer
n'est pas soutenable au moment où la
restauration de l'unité nationale
devrait être une urgence au moment où le
souvenir de nos glorieux aînés devrait
être un exemple vous laissez à bercy le
soin d'étouffer leur mémoire
que comptez-vous faire madame la
ministre pour enrayer cette dangereuse
accusation pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès du premier ministre porte
parole du gouvernement madame da merci
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais d'abord
d'excusés madame florence parly ministre
des armées qui préside actuellement
l'hommage national en
la mémoire du brigadier-chef pointeau à
valence comme vous évidemment le
gouvernement est extrêmement attaché à
l'office national des anciens
combattants et des victimes de guerre
qui constitue vous le savez un
interlocuteur de proximité et de
solidarité pour le monde combattant
ainsi que notre opérateur principal en
matière d'action mémorielle sur les
territoires vous avez évoqué les mesures
inscrites dans le plf 2020 et les
craintes qu'elles peuvent susciter je
veux aujourd'hui vous rassurer
pleinement et entièrement parce que
d'abord les mesures d'économies prévues
qui se monte à 2 millions d'euros et qui
comporte effectivement des réductions
d'effectifs sont liées à la mise en
place d'une dématérialisation à la
baisse du nombre de bénéficiaires et à
la réorganisation des fonctions de
l'administration centrale
cette évolution je vous le rappelle a
été votée par le conseil
d'administration de l'onac vg en
présence des organisations syndicales et
il n'y a pas eu d'opposition parce
qu'elle n'impacte pas le réseau
départemental de l'office qui lui sera
maintenu dans son intégralité les
fonctions d'accueil étant évidemment
préserver nous avons effectué par
ailleurs un prélèvement de 17,5 millions
d'euros sur la trésorerie de l'onac est
un prélèvement exceptionnel qui se
justifie parce que la trésorerie de
l'onac avait été excédentaire dans des
proportions anormales quand on compare
avec d'autres opérateurs publics
ça n'est pas évidemment un prélèvement
qui portera atteinte à la réalisation
des missions de l'onac nous nous
emportons évidemment garant vous l'aurez
donc compris le gouvernement est
particulièrement attentif à la
préservation de l'onac dont les missions
sont indispensables tant dans
l'accompagnement des anciens combattants
que des victimes d'attentats dans notre
pays que de préservation de la mémoire
combattante je vous remercie
tu connais
je convoque la mémoire et vous invoquez
la comptabilité
sauf votre respect cette responsable
répond ce n'est pas au niveau
à l'heure où le brigadier ronan pointeau
vient de trouver la mort en opération au
mali à l'âge de 24 ans samedi dernier
les coups de rabot budgétaire portées à
l'office national des anciens
combattants et victimes de guerre sont
insupportables alors je laisse bien
volontiers au plus célèbre de nos
collègues sénateurs le soin de vous
apporter la réplique ce qui pieusement
sont morts pour la patrie ont droit qu à
leurs cercueils la foule vienne est pris
entre les plus beaux noms leur nom est
le plus beau toute gloire près 2 passes
et tombe éphémère et comme ferait une
mère la voix d'un peuple entier les
bears en leur tombeau entendez madame la
ministre la voix de victor hugo et
donner réellement à l'office national
des anciens combattants et victimes de
guerre les moyens d'accomplir son devoir
et sa noble mission
merci merci
nos prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 13
novembre à 15 heures merci monsieur le
projet bis mesdames et messieurs les
ministres
la séance est suspendue elle sera
reprise à 17h15 à l'issue de la
conférence des présidents pour l'examen
de la proposition de loi visant à agir
contre les violences au sein de la
famille
la séance est suspendue
alors la séance des questions
d'actualité au gouvernement vient de se
terminer et l'une des dernières
questions a concerné les mesures de sur
l'immigration donc annoncé ce matin par
edouard philippe
alors le sénateur socialiste gilbert luc
devinaz s'est inquiété notamment de la
limitation de l'accès aux soins de santé
pour les migrants alors pour lui cela
pose un problème en termes de risque
sanitaire mais également en matière
juridique pourquoi parce que cela
pourrait être contraire à nos
engagements au niveau européen alors
pour la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn
qui lui a répondu non au contraire cela
ne pose pas de problème
elle a dit nous avons tenu bon sur le
panier de soins nécessaires et cela
était utile notamment pour qu'il n'y ait
pas d'abus et de dévoiement alors note
ya également été question cet après midi
d'un tout autre sujet puisque edouard
philippe est revenu sur les propos qu'il
avait tenus lundi pour qualifier les
auteurs de violences de samedi à
chanteloup les vignes alors il les avait
qualifiées rappelez-vous d'imbéciles
tout à l'heure il a comparé ce mot avec
celui employé par le président du
conseil départemental des yvelines qui
lui avait parlé de crétins alors tout
cela pour dire que c'était des réponses
qui comptait et que c'était les réponses
apportées par don qui comptait plus que
le champ lexical
la sénatrice a l'air martha 2,6 drac a
pourtant eu l'impression du contraire on
écoute vous me parlez de sémantique et
moi je vous parle de l'autorité de
l'état et je ne pense pas que vous
m'ayez répondu le constat nous le
partageons nous sommes d'accord avec
vous bien évidemment j'y étais fière
aussi à chanteloup les vignes avec vos
ministres simplement aujourd'hui
l'autorité de l'état est absente dans
ces quartiers et c'est cela que nous
vous demandons merci
alors voilà pour ces questions au
gouvernement tout de suite un débriefing
plus complet avec vous et vous inviter à
tam merci beaucoup à l'iss pour toutes
ces explications et pour ceux des bribes
de la séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement je suis toujours avec alexa
germond bonjour vous êtes chez la
présidente fondatrice du think tank
france audacieuse et du mouvement
politique nous citoyens france ont
débriefé ensemble cette séance qui a été
notamment marquée par la question de
l'immigration un sujet sur lequel est
intervenu
nicole belloubet ce matin sur un an chez
nos confrères de france inter elle est
en train de répondre justement il fait
un point presse à ce sujet on l'écouté
d'un quota le plan qui a été présenté ce
matin par le premier ministre est un
plan en vingt mesures qui sont vingt
mesures cohérentes qui forme un tout qui
est équilibré puisque c'est à la fois
assurer un meilleur contrôle en matière
d'immigration mais aussi un meilleur
accueil pour les personnes qui viendront
chez nous donc je trouve que c'est un
plan qui est parfaitement cohérent et
équilibré
est ce que j'ai dit ce matin correspond
exactement à ce qu'a présenté le premier
ministre c'est à dire que la question
des quotas n'est pas la seule réponse à
ces problèmes d'immigration il y à
d'autres éléments de réponse qui figure
dans le plan on sent que vous avez des
sacs vous avez des réserves sur la
question des quotas dans cette interview
vous pouvez le dire c'est être aussi
intéressant d'avoir un débat dont je
pense que vous sûr interpréter des
propos je pense qu'il y à un commentaire
du commentaire qui n'a pas lieu d'être
ici je leur dis ici très clairement je
n'ai pas d'états d'âme et le tout est un
plan très cohérent
je viens de vous dire je viens de vous
dire ce que j'avais à dire madame
bélouve et on a vu ce nombre 49 loi sur
l'immigration en 45 ans est ce qu a pas
un sur un film en de ces mesures est ce
que là ya pas aussi quelque chose et qui
est incohérent dont les mesures qui ont
été présentés ce matin il n'y a pas que
des mesures de nouveaux législatif il y
aura quelques amendements qui vont être
présentés dans les textes qui sont
actuellement en cours de discussion
mais le reste ne relève pas
nécessairement de mesures législatives
49 langues allant de 5 ans et un énorme
chiffre vous répond
voilà pour cette réaction de nicole
belloubet et qui venait et bien répondre
à la polémique qu'elle avait commencé à
soulever autour de ces possibles états
d'âme concernant la politique de quotas
elle a dit ne faut pas sûr interpréter
mes propos mais on avait senti quand
même qu'elles n'étaient pas tout à fait
d'accord sur ce point de la politique du
gouvernement en matière d'immigration à
l'excellent germond oui là on a eu un
excellent exemple je trouve d'un
dialogue à fleuret moucheté avec une
réponse très politiquement correct avec
certainement un recadrage devais faire
ma le débat fermer les portes c'est pas
une c'est pas une réponse ouverte c'est
le moins que l'on puisse dire cela dit
dans ces cas là ce qu'il s'agit de faire
c'est effectivement de remettre en
perspective la mesure des quotas par
rapport à tout ce qui a été annoncé
également parmi les 19 autres mesures
mais on a bien senti ce matin qu'il y
avait une gêne très certaine du ministre
sur la question sur la question des
quotas
priorité au direct ont continué les
réactions salle des conférences puisque
quentin vous êtes a à présent avec le
secrétaire d'état aux transports jean
baptiste djebbari qui lui a été un petit
peu bousculé hier au sénat le sénat qui
a rejeté directement en nouvelle lecture
la loi à l'homme
la loi d'orientation sur les mobilités
et âme bonjour la bâtisse jebbari vous
avez été un peu bousculés hier en séance
avec effectivement se renvoient
directement de votre projet de loi
mobilité en nouvelle lecture on le sait
les sénateurs ils sont favorables au
texte mais il vient il manque des moyens
pour le transfert de compétences aux
intercommunalités
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui ne
fonctionne pas dans voilà votre message
aux sénateurs ils voient ils ne sont pas
convaincus par cette absence de moyens
financiers ont d'abord dire que j'avais
bien travaillé avec les sénateurs en
2018 sur le pacte ferroviaire et là
effectivement nous avons eu des
discussions très nourris entre
l'assemblée et le sénat et nous avons
achoppé en commission mixte paritaire
mixte paritaire sur le sujet du
financement notamment des petites
collectivités sur des services non
réguliers et j'ai tenté hier d'apporter
quelques précisions et dire que le
gouvernement était prêt aussi à
clarifier
sus de la compensation d'une
décompensation fiscal qui était qui
était discuté mais ils ont décidé de
rejeter ce projet de loi qui est sera
donc le 19 novembre à l'assemblée
nationale pour sa lecture définitive
puisque ce texte est évidemment utile
aux territoires oui les sénateurs et il
avait et bien entendu cette promesse de
la part du gouvernement que dans le
projet de loi de finances il y aurait
bien l'explication de ce transfert de
compétences et de son financement
ils ne le voient pas ce financement dans
le plf dans le vin je veux dire deux
choses ce texte il est financé et c'est
une loi mobilité importante la première
depuis 1982 intégralement financé certes
pas par les ressources que préconisait
la majorité ici au sénat mais
intégralement financée et comme je viens
de vous le dire j'avais proposé au nom
du gouvernement notamment de clarifier
et de sécuriser le financement des
collectivités notamment du versement
transport
mais ils ont décidé autrement je
respecte évidemment le choix sous le
choix souverain de la haute chambre jean
baptiste djebbari dans quelques instants
vous allez défendre votre budget
transport devant les sénateurs en vue
d'une proche de finances 2020 on est à
quelques jours de l'anniversaire du
mouvement des gilet jaune c'était il ya
un an c'était partir d'une fronde sur
les prix du carburant est ce que dans
votre budget il ya les garanties pour
apaiser la fronde sociale en france
en tout cas je crois que ce budget il
prend pleinement la leaf est en tout cas
elle il a dans sa construction l'épisode
qu'il sait qui s'est déroulé il ya douze
mois et il répond très concrètement aux
territoires au travers du plan de
désenclavement des territoires ruraux
par exemple au travers du plan de
régénération du réseau ferroviaire au
travers de doughty qui sont donnés aux
collectivités pour lutter contre la
pollution de l'air outils extraire une
prise de conscience de la part du
gouvernement
en tout cas ce texte il a été vous savez
décidé et porté par le gouvernement
avant la crise' gilet jaune mais pour
autant je crois qu'il contient en son
sein des réponses qui intéresse mais il
ya une prise de conscience dans votre
budget notre budget est ambitieux il est
en hausse de 6% par rapport à l'année
dernière et évidemment il s'adresse
directement aux territoires aux élus et
donc je crois qu'il répond évidemment
tout à fait aux préoccupations des
français et notamment des juges
merci beaucoup jean baptiste djebbari et
donc effectivement à la loi l'homme elle
retourne à l'assemblée nationale an pour
une ultime lecture le 19 novembre merci
quentin pour cette nouvelle réaction et
j'accueille sur ce plateau eric
kerrouche bonjour vous êtes sénateur
socialiste des landes membre de la
commission des lois également sur ce
plateau dany wattebled vous êtes
sénateur les indépendants du nord
également membre de la commission des
lois
on va revenir avec vous et bien avec sur
l'un des évènements et qui a marqué ce
débrief tout à l'heure et bien il y a eu
le point presse de nicole belloubet la
garde des sceaux qui est revenu sur les
propos qu'elle a eu ce matin d des
propos qui ont eu des échos jusqu'en
chine puisque emmanuel macron avait été
interrogé sur les états d'âme de
certains de ses ministres nicole
belloubet avait dit que les quotas
n'était pas la seule solution en matière
de politique migratoire qu'en pensez
vous danny watts oublie moi je pense que
le présent un puck a légèrement recadrer
sa ministre en disant bon il faut pas
d'état d'âme quand on a une proposition
des choses à mettre en place puisque les
armes
c'est ce que j'aime en ricanant du
gouvernement doit suivre l'action jeu
général du prêt à leur public ça minimum
éric kerrouche votre réaction
c'est peut-être un retour de flamme
peut-être que nicole belloubet se
souvient de ses origines politiques et
que peut-être manifestement elle comme
une femme de gauche nicole belloubet
dans ce gouvernement
ça doit être très difficile je vois pas
comment on peut être de gauche et dans
ce gouvernement mais ça peut être sept
cette légère situation d'inconfort on va
dire avec le avec le choix qu'elle a
fait et au vu des choix surtout qu'ils
sont faits par ce gouvernement en
immigration et en matière économique
justement on en vient au fond de ces
annonces de ses dents mesure annoncée ce
midi éric kerrouche est-ce que vous
jugez qu'il y à un juste équilibre des
droits et des devoirs c'est ce qu'a dit
edouard philippe
à midi tout à l'heure ça c'est la
présentation du gouvernement j'imagine
qu'il avait pas de me dire le contraire
à un moment où la politique en matière
de quotas montre ses limites dans
d'autres états je pense particulièrement
par exemple au au canada et au canada et
singulièrement au québec c'est compliqué
de penser que en mettant en place des
dispositifs ça va fonctionner dans notre
pays et que ça et valait évacuer
d'autres possibilités d'immigration
pour ma part je pense que ça ne suffira
pas alexia germond votre regard sur les
annonces tout à l'heure et notamment
cette question des quotas ses quotas
pour l'immigration économique
ça représente que 30 mille personnes par
an sur 260 milles parce que vous dites
bien hériter rouge c'est aussi un signal
politique
oui c'est un signal politique mais c'est
surtout une part infime du travail qui
est à réaliser et là où il ya peut-être
un peu maldonne vis-à-vis des français
c'est que quand le premier ministre
attaques en dix ans on veut reprendre en
main notre politique migratoire
c'est clair qu'en ne parlant que de
quotas économique
ah oui là ça parlait que de ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on retient beaucoup la
question dès qu'on parle des quotas mais
ce que je veux dire c'est
essentiellement il ya quand même un
focus qui est fait sur l'essentiel du
travail en tout cas se porte sur toute
la partie économique de cette migration
et que ça ne puisse pas le sujet si on
veut aller au bout du sujet et une fois
encore il n'y a pas de raison que ça
soit un territoire qui soit uniquement
présentés par le rassemblement national
il faut pouvoir parler calmement de ces
sujets là mais il ya deux sujets qui me
paraissent évidemment prioritaire c'est
la question du droit d'asile et
notamment du retour lorsqu'ils ne sont
pas acceptés on pourra peut-être en
rediscuter mais ça c'est vraiment très
important parce que il y à un flot
important de gens qui ne sont pas
reconduits à la frontière et puis le
deuxième
le deuxième sujet à côté de ce droit
d'asile c'est toute la politique
migratoires au sens large avec l'accès
aux soins et le regroupement familial
bien entendu qui est un sujet qui n'est
pas attaqué là du tout alors une belle
réaction peut-être justement sur la
question de des quotas puis aussi de la
m e et puis on va montrer clair moi ce
qui m'a plu c'est les droits et devoirs
c'est une chose que je considère
essentiel qu'est l'immigration
effectivement elle doit être là qu'elle
soit choisie c'est autre chose
mais surtout ce qui m'interroge c'est
des moyens qu'ont bien être en phase sur
les gens qu'il a reconduits aux
frontières
5 % seulement des 80000 personnes
donc voilà qu'est ce que l'on fait les
paroles c'est bien mais les accès plus
forte et plus fort et tout de suite on
va rejoindre salle des conférences alain
joyandet qui est au micro de quentin
calme et alain joyandet qui a notamment
travaillé sur la hem le relais de
médicale d'état quentin tout à fait il
est rapporteur du budget santé au sein
de la commission des finances
mais avant de parler de la m e tout
d'abord un mot sur ce juste équilibre
entre droits et devoirs que revendique
le premier ministre quelle est votre
analyse sur ces annonces qui ont été
faites en matière d'immigration
aujourd'hui d'abord je salue
l'initiative parce que même si on n'est
pas d'accord sur tout je pense que le
fait que le gouvernement se saisisse du
sujet parce qu'il ya quand même un vrai
sujet après il faut trouver
effectivement l' équilibre entre les
droits et les devoirs entre la rigueur
et l'humanisme cette question des quotas
ça vous parle
c'était vous étiez ministre de nicolas
sarkozy vous aussi vous dites qu'il faut
maîtriser davantage les l'immigration
notamment professionnelle alors je
précise que quand on parle des quotas on
parle de l'immigration professionnelle
c'est grosso modo 10 % en 2000 sur les
placer en 1306 séjour new hâlas melons
dès qu'on dénombre 300 mille
bénéficiaires
donc bien sûr qu'il faut adapter le
recrutement entre guillemets des
immigrés pour les entreprises que ce
soit sous des quotas ou des objectifs
peu importe faut aussi traiter lacaune
la question de l'immigration clandestine
il ya aussi cette question de la santé
on l'a dit vous êtes rapporteur de ce
volet santé au sein de la commission des
finances vous parlez donc des sujets
comme de la m
d'ailleurs le sénat lorsque eh bien il
va examiner le projet de loi de finances
il compte imposer sa marque une fois
encore sur ce sujet vous nous
l'annonçait hier la commission des
finances
adopté les amendements que j'ai proposé
trois amendements l'un pour changer la
nature de cet am et en faire une am eu
une aide médicale d'urgence donc changer
le contour de l'intervention ce qui nous
permet de faire en sorte ça coûte moins
cher donc un deuxième amendement pour
réduire le budget de 300 millions quand
nous avons quitté le gouvernement
leymen coûtait pas un milliard et coûter
moins de 600 millions donc c'est
possible
et puis un troisième amendement pour
restaurer un droit d'entrée de 30 euros
pour que chacun participe un peu où
coulent que représente cette année mais
où c'est a ému le gouvernement n'entend
pas toucher à la haye mais aussi
fortement que vous vous le faites vous
qu'est ce que vous allez leur dire pour
les convaincre vous leur dites qu'il
faut vraiment réformer la m je pense
qu'entre la position du gouvernement
celle que sera la position du sénat en
séance publique sur le budget puisque
maintenant qu'on a des amendements
adoptés par la commission des finances
on va aller discuter avec le
gouvernement en séance publique
on verra la position du gouvernement
nous ne sommes pas des jusqu'au
boutistes
moi je salue les avancées ce qui est
positif essayons de rapprocher les
points de vue si nous rapprochons les
points de vue alors ce sera peut-être la
première fois que sur ce sujet là et
avec ce gouvernement là on arrive à se
mettre d'accord je le souhaite parce que
c'est l'intérêt général merci beaucoup
alain joyandet un loyer à tam le débat
ne fait que commencer sur cette question
de la m
merci beaucoup quentin pour cette
nouvelle réaction et j'accueille sur ce
plateau gérard longuet bienvenus vous
êtes sénateur et l'air de la meuse
membre de la commission des finances
justement dans votre réaction à ce que
prévoit finalement le gouvernement sur
la m1 donc parmi tous ces points dans sa
politique migratoire qui l'a développé à
midi finalement est bien là et murs on
avait beaucoup parlé mais il touche très
peu et toucherait peu c'est la raison
pour laquelle la commission des finances
et alain joyandet vient de le rappeler a
adopté ces amendements que nous
débattrons avec le gouvernement en
séance pour essayer d'en obtenir plus
d'en savoir plus et de mettre en face de
responsabilité qui qui qui doivent être
prises vous déplorez cette position du
gouvernement qui a un discours
la stévia c'est ce qu'a dit alain
joyandet le débat est ouvert une somme
au parlement celles pour essayer
d'avancer pour trouver des solutions
parce que de toute façon on ne peut pas
rester sans réponse on ne peut pas
laisser à la fois des gens sans solution
médicale et on ne peut pas non plus
laisser cela émeut dérivés pour devenir
une sorte d'appel d'air permanent car le
fond du problème c'est cela c'est
l'impact de ce dispositif qui suscite
des courants minoritaires certes mais
médée courant de l'immigration eric
héraud jeu votre réaction
la france est trop généreuse ce que vous
dit gérard longuet cela peut et bien
entraîné des courants à migratoires je
pense que systématiquement le
gouvernement par les temps qui courent a
tendance à se déporter de plus en plus
sur le thème migratoires et sur le thème
de l'immigration en général ce qui est
un certain changement de pied par
rapport à par rapport à 2010 est oui on
se rappelle qu emmanuel macron à
l'époque avait dit toute son admiration
notamment pour angela merkel et la
politique d'ouverture qu'elle avait eu à
l'égard des migrants
manifestement je le disais donc à un
vrai j'ai agi non un vrai changement
d'orienter ce plus qu'un changement
d'avis et un changement d'orientation
politique qui le rapproche je pense de
de sa base de initiale sur le sur le
fond des droites ça exactement oui sur
le fond évidemment qu'il faut combattre
qu'il faut combattre certains excès
encore faudrait-il qu'il soit exactement
quantifier ce qui n'est pas le cas
actuellement
ce qui n'est pas le cas actuellement les
données les données sont parcellaires
c'est étonnant qui c'est vrai de
plusieurs centaines de millions 11 ans
céline pour des dépenses sont en recul
c'est pourtant là c'est pourtant c'est
pour les objectifs fixés pour ses fins
et même ses courtes on a constaté
le problème c'est que tant qu on
objectif pas on peut avoir des on peut
avoir des fantasmes atik deux dates à
côté d'un côté comme de l'autre et je
pense que d'un côté il faudrait il nous
faudrait des éléments objectifs qui
épuise ce sujet dre rage d'appeler un
chat un chat est un chat siamois un chat
siamois et ses chants de joie
c'est un sujet sur lequel il ya beaucoup
de fantasmes et de contrevérités c'est
ce qu'ils avaient dit le gouvernement
il avait demandé ce rapport à l'igas qui
a été remis hier et finalement ben on
n'en sort pas tellement avec les idées
plus claires danny watts entend beaucoup
de choses un mot ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup
c'est l'état des lieux je vais pas si
hâtif et précisément non quand on parle
de migrants quel migrants combien sur
les toits de quelle origine quel pays
est tous des balles viennent là comment
voulez vous reconduire quelqu'un dans
son pays si on ne sait pas d'où il vient
et si on peut pas contrôler son arrivée
donc on est dans un flou absolu on
entend beaucoup de fantasmes et moi dans
cette affaire-là
ce qui m'énerve c'est les débordements
c'est les excès parce que bon de d'un
mot on leur fait une fabulation
il ya eu des excès c'est ça qu'il faut
combattre parce que c'est vrai qu'un
migrants qui arrivent chez nous aucune
en situation délicate en termes de santé
doit être soigné mais c'est dès que dès
qu'on attend que les actes médicaux qui
sont un peu plus de confort ce d'autres
choses et ça fait un flou absolu
on n'est pas capable de cadrer les
choses et je rejoigne notre collègue qui
c'est vrai l'état lieu devrait être fait
ou l'apa c'est le rôle du parlement
c'est de parler d'échanger sa choix ce
jeudi rationalité l'immigration parce
que finalement on n'a pas assez de
données
oui sachant que c'est pour ça que c'est
de notre responsabilité de l'objective
et autant que possible et j'ai
d'ailleurs trouvé que l'intervention du
sénateur joyandet était était dans une
logique d'ouverture est très
intéressante de ce point de vue là je
crois que la difficulté c'est que la
politique de santé publique finalement
elle nous protège tous d'une part et que
celle ci ne doit pas être
instrumentalisée pour des fins
migratoires et c'est ça là où l'on voit
la frontière qui est assez ténue où il
faut faire attention parce que dès lors
que l'on basculerait d'un autre côté
toutes mesures qui seraient prises ou
toute réforme qui serait prise serait à
ce moment-là susceptibles d'être d'être
critiqué bon sachant que sur le droit
d'asile
peut-être quelques chiffres c'était un
sujet qu'on avait particulièrement
travaillé au sein du think tank france
audacieuse donc avec l'ancien directeur
de l'oft prague qui nous avait fait tout
un dossier là dessus il y à environ 115
mille demandes par an il faut savoir
puisque on veut aller contre les feux
grillés politique de demandes de neuf
demandes qui sont devant qui passe
devant l'ofpra
le taux de réponses positives de l'oft
rang en 2017 c'était 27 % si on complète
avec la cour d'appel dédié on passe à
36%
donc on voit bien qu'on est dans les
quarante cinq mille à peu près qui ont
un statut autorités déjà considérables
tant des gangs
compte tenu de cette un certain nombre
de pays et c'était bien là la conclusion
de la note c'est que nous étions un des
pays les plus les plus généreux en la
matière mais ce qui pose un vrai
problème et c'est d'ailleurs écrit noir
sur blanc ce qui est assez courageux de
sa part
c'est vraiment le la difficulté de la
reconduite à la frontière alors quand
vous dites on sait pas d'où ils viennent
on a quand même des statistiques qui
sont disponibles chaque année en
fonction des pays qui sont les plus
demandeurs en 2017 vous aviez l'albanie
vous aviez la syrie bien sûr ça
s'expliquer avec un certain nombre de
leurs expressions national aux relations
géopolitiques la syrie rumeurs mais pas
l'albanie mais c'est pour ça que je
lalbenque c'est les deux
il semble poser vos questions aux est
question donc temps que l'on n'appelle
pas un chat un chat avec la difficulté
des reconduites à la frontière mais qui
sont extrêmement compliqué parce que
voilà c'est à dire qu'il faut demander
aussi l'apport du pays du pays d'accueil
tout ça se fait en bonne intelligence
donc on voit bien que de ce point de vue
là il faut travailler vraiment main dans
la main avec avec ces pays eric héraud
chasse que vous êtes d'accord à ce que
le problème finalement c'est surtout et
bien l'immigration illégale et la
question de la reconduite à la frontière
finalement c'est pas tellement là et me
c'est pas tellement fins et oui c'est la
m e mais c'est pas tellement certain
nombre de sujets qui ont été largement
évoqués alors du point ce matin
non mais problème depuis ses preuves
depuis 40 ans je pense que l'on a
multiplié les lois sur sur l'immigration
qu'on continue à le faire avec
manifestement des effets des effets qui
sont limitées moi je constate simplement
quelque chose c'est que le solde
migratoire en france est relativement
faible
quand on regarde les entrées et les
départs c'est relativement faible et
donc il ya une immigration qui de toute
façon est nécessaire quoi qu'il arrive
après pourquoi il y à une immigration
qui est nécessaire dans notre pays en
terme de population active d'apport de
population active car c'est une
nécessité
et l'idée de dire l'idée de dire l'idée
de l'idée de dire mais là je pense qu'on
aura un désaccord fondamental sur ce
poids est d'ailleurs j'avais 10 ans tant
mieux tant mieux aujourd'hui
salou et ça ça nous rassure ce qui est
certain ce qui est certain en tout cas
c'est que il ya une tradition d'asile en
france oui je pense qu'elle je pense
qu'elle est importante
ça ne doit pas comme d'habitude justifié
pour autant les accès mais je ne
voudrais pas que les accès servent à
invalider la position la position
française en général et c'est surtout ça
qui c'est surtout ça qui m'importe
alors que répondez-vous gérard longuet
justement sur la question de la
population active
parce que d'ailleurs certains
représentants des arm disparaît comme
par exemple quand on parle de politique
de quotas économique
on pourrait tout à fait le plus ouvrir
dire justement ça peut être aussi une
politique positive parce qu'on a besoin
d'eux d'immigrés dans un certain nombre
de secteurs économiques
on peut en effet souhaité un bon en fait
revenir tous les cerveaux étrangers vers
les universités françaises moi
personnellement comme français j'y serai
très favorable est aussi sauf williams
est un autre problème
sauf qu'ils vont plutôt aux états unis
qu'en france donc là il ya une véritable
interrogation sur notre capacité à
rayonner sur place 24 hâtives sur les
métiers d'exécution ce que vous citez
l'instant là je suis pas d'accord du
tout parce que nous avons encore huit et
demi pour cent ne forçant de demandeurs
d'emploi cela veut dire que nous sommes
nous n'avons pas su jusqu'à présent
mobilisé toute notre population de
demandeurs d'emploi alors ce sont des
problèmes objectif c'est que des
questions de formation c'est les
questions de localisation la france un
grand pays avec une faible densité de
population les bassins d'emploi sont
sont fracturées et par conséquent des
gens peuvent être demandeur d'emploi
dans la haute loire alors qu'il serait
très demandé dans le département d'à
côté mais ils n'y vont pas donc je
considère que pour l'instant tant que
nous n'avons pas réduit à 1
incompressibles qui est peut-être de 5%
mais qui n'est sûrement pas de 8%
le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi il ne
faut pas faire d' immigration de
production qu'on fasse on de l'accueil
le cerveau oui tout à fait parce qu'ils
retournent dans leur pays
encore que il faut savoir je crois qu'il
ya plus de médecins africains
francophones en france il y en a un en
afrique pose un petit problème de
développement et c'est pour ça que je ne
suis pas favorable à l'immigration parce
que
on prend les meilleurs il faut bien voir
que tous les jeunes qui viennent
premièrement ce sont des hommes n'y a
pas de femmes
ils sont tous jeunes ils sont en pleine
forme et ils viennent en payant leur
voyage pour ensuite faire vivre une
partie de la population
moi je préfère largement aider ces pays
à se développer c'est tout ce qu'ils
avaient je pense pas que les deux je
pense pas que les deux s'opposent et je
parlais de soldes migratoires et de
proportion et de proportion de la
population étrangère dans la population
française qui coupent comme vous le
savez varie très peu même sur
pratiquement 80 ans en volume sur 80 ans
savary relativement avril était possible
on prendra les chiffres un autre moment
mais la france est devenue un pays
d'immigration à partir des trente
glorieuses et à la fin des trente
glorieuses avec la décolonisation
avant on ya de l'italien à l'oral et
pour 110 kg 1 j'ai lu aussi l'interview
de michèle tribalat dans wall dans le
figaro intéressant ce que je pense que
c'est à ça que vous engagez et j'en ai
plaisir à ça que vous vous référez et en
l'espèce je vous dis que depuis les
années depuis les années 30 en effet le
taux de population étrangère est
relativement stable
je dis pas qu'on n'a pas de pot 2 je dis
pas qu'on a pas de problème par ailleurs
je dis juste qu'il ya une certaine
stabilité et qu'il faut faire et qu'il
faut faire attention portée à faire
porter sur les migrations tous les
problèmes du monde parle français
leurs problèmes par eux mêmes on aura du
mal à vous mettre tous les deux d'accord
en mode
dany wattebled juste aller pour changer
un peu de débats ces intégrations
intégration qui doit être mieux réussi
surtout dans en cas d'acceptation chez
nous donc l'apprentissage du français
que soit oral ou écrit est un point
d'entrée important c'est un concept très
difficile
et si on revivre le projet de réforme en
lui même il ya une piste qui me semblent
intéressantes
c'est le fait de remettre à niveau la
liste des métiers sous tension qui était
une carie est ce qu'il ya d'intéressant
c'est que c'est pas uniquement sur les
emplois mais c'est également pour
rebondir sur ce que vous disiez
sénateurs
faites un travail qui est fait avec les
régions pour bien cerner les difficultés
région par région territoire par
territoire
et là ça nous permettra peut-être de
mettre en phase les formations les
dispositifs année vous avez les métiers
sous tension c'est l'occasion d'ouvrir
un vrai débat sur la société française
je prends l'exemple des personnes âgées
c'est vrai que nous manquons
d'accompagnement pour les personnes
âgées et je vois en région parisienne on
voit dans la rue ce sont en général nos
compatriotes antillais qui s'occupe de
nos grands mères
il ya peut-être un moment le souhaitait
française devrait s'intéresser à la
solidarité des générations et c est ce
que les jeunes n'ont pas aussi
l'obligation de sauver les bus alors
vous le dire c'est normal je plaide pour
moi je deviens vieux mais il faut faire
des enfants aussi pour que des jeunes
s'occupent des bains donc l'idée de
famille l'idée de solidarité
intergénérationnelle moi je la défends
on peut dire que c'est pas grave y'a pas
dans les enfants sont égoïstes c'est pas
grave on va en chercher ailleurs
ça ne marche pas comme ça sur le long
terme allez on passe à un deuxième sujet
qui a marqué cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement et bien ce
sont les violences à chanteloup les
vignes
le premier ministre a été interpellé sur
le sujet il a répondu tout à l'heure on
l'écoutant et vous me dites que pour
bien traiter les questions il faut
savoir les nommer vous faites se faisant
référence
la qualification que j'ai pu avoir de
petite bande d'imbéciles je me permets
de vous faire remarquer madame la
sénatrice que le président du conseil
départemental des yvelines que vous
connaissez comme moi que vous respectez
comme moi a pour sa part utilisé le
terme crétin je ne sais pas s'il est
plus léger plus infamant plus
responsable plus dur que petite bande
d'imbéciles je ne sais pas si le terme
racaille ou sauvageons qui a été
utilisée qui ont été utilisés
la vérité la vérité mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs la vérité
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
c'est que je crois que nous pourrions
tous nous entendre sur le fait que ceux
qui comptent plus que le choix dans le
champ lexical que nous faisons c'est la
réalité des faits
et la réalité des réponses on va parler
du fond de la question de la sécurité
dans ces banlieues mais d'abord dany
wattebled on est obligé d'y revenir
edouard philippe il a parlé aussi
sémantique car il ya le fond et ya la
forme que qu'avez-vous pensez vous les
biens de la polémique soulevée par la
litote qu'il avait employé en parlant
d'une bande d'imbéciles et
d'irresponsables moi les mots ne
m'importe peu parce qu'en fait les mots
ça veut dire quoi
on est devant une des villes de 10000
habitants où on a une trentaine
d'individus jeunes qui se permet de
faire la loi où l'état alors on peut
donner le nom que l'on veut à ces gens
là moi je pense que la seule réponse
c'est que tu as le reprendre sa place
on n'est pas dans une mégalopole on est
dix mille habitants
donc je sais pas combien repenser le
quartier 3000 peut être plus on peut
parler devant aurions pas tout ce que
l'on veut mettre des moyens faut
recommencer à la base je pense qu'il ya
là dessus on a lâché beaucoup beaucoup
de trop alors peut-être ces jeunes à 13
en ont pâti repris à 14 ans pierre mans
les mêmes 15 à la salle y dépasse une
limite et qu'étaient les réponses de de
l'état on a quelques meneurs on peut les
cibler on a les moyens jouisseur qui
mène sanctionnons déjà ces choses là
après on pourra faire tout ce que l'on
veut mais moi elle pourrait devoir c'est
comme le respect des règles le respect
dom mes parents m'ont appris le respect
des choses la grille archi on vient on
en a plus continuer comme ça et on ira
loin on voit des films futuristes où il
ya des quartiers où on ne peut même plus
rentrer on n'est pas loin
eric et je vous êtes d'accord il faut
restaurer l'autorité de l'état
quand on voit que il y avait même des
dix concours sur les réseaux sociaux
pour je vais employer les mots pour
casser du flic c'était quand même ça qui
a été fait le week-end dernier
qu'est ce que vous en pensez il ya deux
niveaux de réponse
un premier qui va faire plaisir à
monsieur longuet il ya 1300 1300
quartier politique de la ville en france
ça fait à peu près 5 millions de
personnes
sur ces cinq millions de personnes il y
en a 2 millions qui sont en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
je dis simplement là qu'il y à un
terreau qui est fertile pour une
certaine partie de la population et
cette partie de la population se sont et
ça a été le cas à chanteloup-les-vignes
des délinquants qu'il faut sanctionner
mais qui agissent mais qui agissent
encore une fois dans des territoires qui
ont des situations sociales
particulières et
traiter l'un centre est et l'autre par
exemple en abandonnant le pont le plan
borloo
et bien c'est déjà ça c'est déjà ça
c'est déjà ça l'erreur
maintenant il est évident que au vu de
ce qui a été commis je pense à ce cirque
qui a été incendiée est ce que ça
représente en termes d'investissements
publics
bien entendu qu'il ne faut rien lâcher
vis-à-vis de cette délinquance qui est
dérangé notamment par la renoul le
renouvellement urbain qui se produit
justement sur cette commune c'est aussi
simple que ça gérard longuet vous allez
peut-être d'accord chantal lavigne est
une ville que je connais bien parce que
l'ancien maire pierre cardo qui était
député d'ailleurs tannen tout à fait
remarquable et a fait un travail
formidable et nous rappelait il ya peu
de jours encore que il ya vingt ans il y
avait 300 jeunes de sa commune qui
venait casser aujourd'hui il y en a 37
un commando organisé et c'est assez
largement minoritaires pourquoi parce
que on parle de l'état mais les villes
font un travail formidable et conseils
municipaux formidable les associations
locales pour un travail formidable et ce
qui est navrant c'est en effet l'absence
de l'état c'est à dire que voilà des
gens qui font leur boulot mais il ya un
moment où il faut attraper des jambes
par les oreilles et les rappeler à
l'ordre
et alors les taux n'avaient ton avis les
mots n'ont pas beaucoup d'importance
sauf que en droit pénal français
un incendie volontaire c'est un crime
c'est un acte crime pour cela n'est
sacré bout de temps maintenant sur la
pauvreté
je suis complètement d'accord avec vous
que la pauvreté évidemment n'arrange
rien mais il faut savoir d'où elle vient
cette pour voter elvire aux particuliers
dans certains quartiers je les connais
pas tous deux familles monoparentales
c'est à dire de deux familles qui sont
des structures et pourquoi sont elles
des structures il faut rentrer un petit
peu dans le détail et on s'aperçoit à ce
moment là que le refus des valeurs
traditionnelles le refus de l'engagement
le refus des parents qui sont
responsables des enfants des enfants qui
sont solidaires des parents tout ça ça
entraîne beaucoup beaucoup de
conséquences et une ce sens et la vie
d'aujourd'hui
non mais là c'est pas la vie c'est pas
la vie d'aujourd'hui c'est le
laisser-aller d'aujourd'hui et c'est
quand on dit maintenant vous faites
n'importe quoi non footeux fait si vous
faites n'importe quoi
vous avez comme résultat n'importe quoi
je pense qu'il faut rappeler à chacun et
depuis le plus jeune âge ses
responsabilités responsabilité respect
de l'autre respect de soi même
respect de ses parents et pour les
parents respect du couple qui a la
responsabilité des enfants permettez moi
de vous dire que les enfants l'après
vente les frais très lent pour ces
familles monoparentales et bien
justement donne ça serait intéressant
d'avoir le courage de dire pourquoi
pourquoi vous excusez moi mais là
lorsque il ya plein de rappel à l'ordre
de la société sur la valeur que
représente la famille on explique on
peut faire tout et n'importe quoi répond
c'est très bien ça de ma devise est
capable de rappeler lors de l'e3 site
baptisé les familles monoparentales est
donc essentiellement les deux mères
isolées
s'ils ne le font pas on va sortir du
débat sur la famille peut-être davantage
et à l'ail encourage aussi en banlieue
parisienne de parler de la polygamie de
gare les familles par monoparentales
sont la contrepartie et du courage ygk
ayons vues et galaxy 2 par les ennemis
et joue un succès si vous parlez ayons
le courage de parler des chiffres encore
une fois parce que là aussi mais là on
n'est pas sûr de l'objectivation ont des
perceptions
vous avez raison d'aller dans le
fantasme encore une fois non je ne vais
pas dans le fantasme et vous avez raison
sur un point c'est que j'aimerais avoir
des données statistiques courageuse qui
nous explique pourquoi les gens vivent
ainsi à l'excellent germond vous ben
justement votre shopping bien sûr qu'ils
se jettent sur la façon dont est bien
cette violence dans les banlieues est
traitée aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
est il à la hauteur
j'aimerais quand même souligner que ça
cette cette violence là qu'on a connu à
chanteloup-les-vignes n'est que le suit
la triste suite d'incidents criminel
qu'on a vu partout ailleurs donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas un incident qui
est isolé malheureusement les forces de
police et de sécurité sont
quotidiennement emprise dans des
guets-apens et on se rend compte avec
l'embrasement des banlieues on est on
est à oui je crois qu'il faut la poser
des mots sur la romanité oui on a connu
ça c'est tout à fait envisageable
il y à des appels à l'aide de la police
qui sont finalement relayé mais pas tant
que ça c'est relayé dans les milieux qui
s'intéresse aux forces de police et de
sécurité et donc on a l'impression que
là le gouvernement pour le coup a fait a
réagi à un point ponctuelles alors que
c'est quelque chose qui prend 1 en
pleurs une ampleur bien plus
considérables je note aussi que pour
tous les les efforts qui ont été faits
dans cette ville je crois que sur les 15
dernières années il ya à peu près 350
bâtiments qui ont été rénovés 1 / sur la
ville ce qui est énorme mais il ce qu'il
faut bien qu'on comprenne c'est que
quand même temps que l'on fait ça ça
dérange finalement l'économie
je suis vraiment l'accès et c'est vrai
que là nous lui a des poux lecouls des
moyens qu'ils ont été
bien augmenter de 5 à 10 milliards
bon mais on est là au point de
cristallisation finalement c'est un bras
de fer et je crois que c'est très
important que l'autorité de l'état ne
fléchissent pas il n'ya c'est vraiment
inenvisageable différemment que l'état
puisse d'une façon ou d'une autre
voir ce bras sous son bras se coucher or
là c'est l'impression que cela donne
surtout que c'est la condition c'est la
condition de simplement pour que la
majorité des gens de la population qui
vivent dans ces zones puissent puissent
mieux et bien vivre parce que c'est en
fait eux qui subissent la plupart du
temps les exactions de quelques reculs
de l'onta c'est la loi c'est la loi du
plus fort est la loi du plus fort n'est
pas la loi la plus juste nous sommes
bien d'accord
allez on va passer aux un troisième et
dernier thème de ce débrief eh bien
c'était la question de l'assurance
chômage il ya eu deux questions à ce
sujet on écoute une d'entre elle
laurence cohen a interpellé la ministre
du travail tout à l'heure et votre
réforme madame la vie ni ce qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une machine à faire
exploser la précarité et la pauvreté
plus de 9 millions de pauvres dans notre
pays aujourd'hui vous ne trouvez pas que
c'est suffisant et inacceptable alors
pourquoi vous allez encore grossir leurs
rangs
vous avez décidé de supprimer
l'observatoire national de la pauvreté
mais madame la ministre casser le
thermomètre ne fait pas baisser la
fièvre
votre politique c'est niet elle dépend
plus généreuse quand il s'agit de servir
les plus aisés qui voient leurs revenus
augmenter de 1% et il faut que vous
arrêtiez avec cette politique et il faut
que vous arrêtiez de faire de la com les
gens attendent autre chose des mesures
ils seront dans la rue nombreuses et
nombreux on sera avec eux et on va
écouter la réponse de muriel pénicaud
alors elle a été interpellé à deux
reprises
c'est l'une de ses réponses justement
lorsqu'elle a été interpellée sur
l'assurance chômage
moi je m'étonne que sur ses bancs
certains pensent que le travail c'est
moins bien que le chômage nous sommes
inscrits en faux aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je suis factuel un demandeur
sur plots un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq
un demandeur d'emploi sur cinq gagne
plus au chômage qu'au travail
ce n'est pas la faute de gens c'est les
règles qu'on fait les partenaires
sociaux ils n'ont pas vu l'angle mort
que sacré ils n'ont pas fait exprès mais
maintenant il faut le corriger
le travail doit y ait payé plus que le
chômage nous croyons à l'insertion à la
formation au travail c'est la société
qu'on veut faire et donc il est injuste
que quelqu'un aujourd'hui et 150 % de
son salaire au chômage alors que les
autres et ça reste très protecteur tout
le monde rentre 65 96 % de son salaire
oui pour le travail en angola précarité
et oui pour l'insertion tenir à table
est votre réaction à ce que dit nick
merial pénicaud halde il ya un angle
mort qui fait que l'on peut gagner plus
au chemin vaillant et cite un cinquième
des chômeurs la réaction d'abord sur
l'antique des mots chômeurs c'est un
gros mot demandeurs d'emploi sage ce mot
est alors j'ai entendu privés d'emploi
et sachent pas d'accord on prive pas
l'emploi donc là sur la sémantique moi
je dis que sur le chômage et on va
revenir tout à l'heure ce que j'en
disais il ya des postes non pourvus donc
le premier et lequel si on n'incite pas
demain matin
une association financière forte avec
une formation qui est doublé on porte
voix des gens dans l'emploi j'ai un
exemple très concret aujourd'hui j'ai en
dessous de moments de ma permanence un
transporteur il cherche un chauffeur
derniers kilomètres puisque le fait plus
les grandes distances et les pédales ce
qu'ils font pour nous 2000 euros net +
voiture prendre entré chez soi avec la
formation il ne trouve pas je pense
qu'il ya un gibier un gibier d'emplois
partout et on n'arrive pas connecté ça
alors oui c'est vrai que cette réforme
elle va obliger c'est vrai on perdra un
peu à peu d'assurance chômage aura
peut-être moins anisé et est ce qui
était normal qu'on soit me dire 4500
euros
un certain nombre de mois je pense qu'on
porte le travail et surtout ce qu'il
faut coupler c'est l'accompagnement mais
la formation qui doit être coupé
derrière et je suis d'accord avec une
partie des réformes
éric kerrouche je suppose que vous
n'êtes pas d'accord 7
réforme elle a aussi marqué un certain
nombre des plus précaires c'est aussi ce
que dénonce aujourd'hui bien les les
syndicats qui jugent que et bien les
plus précaires ont été fortement
impactés de faim moi ce genre de
déclarations ça me rend malade déchu
poli vraiment c'est on est dans là on
est dans la caricature du pire du
libéralisme à un moment où en allemagne
les lois hartz que les lois qui ont été
promus par gerhard schröder viennent
d'être condamnés je crois par la cour
constitutionnelle qui remet en cause la
pauvreté qu'engendre la précarisation un
moment où on a des témoignages en
angleterre sur les contrats les contrats
0 heure on se précipite vers des
solutions qui sont des solutions de
stigmatisation des chômeurs des
solutions d'une certaine façon de ce
qu'on parlait de justement de ces
quartiers précédemment on va continuer à
broyer les gens socialement à leur
donner moins de moyens et puis à leur
faire comprendre que s'ils n'acceptent
pas de toute façon à tout prix et bien
c'est de leur faute et il faut qu'il
fasse ce sacrifice parce que c'est le
seul à faire maintenant sur le la
question des postes à pourvoir
c'est toujours pareil il ya la question
de la photo et la question des flux
parce que à un moment donné la photo il
y à des postes non pourvus pour plein de
raisons des problèmes de déplacement des
problèmes de rémunération mais dans le
temps ces postes sont pourvus mais on
oublie on oublie une évidence évidente
c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez actuellement
de travail alors on peut le tourner dans
tous les sens on peut victimiser les
chômeurs on peut en faire des gens qui
vont passer au rsa et mettre à mal la
logique de solidarité dans le
département mais ça c'est du libéralisme
un petit bras c'est ce que fait ce
gouvernement votre réaction rapidement
gérard longuet ont rapidement je pense
que madame pénicaud va dans la bonne
direction
ça mérite d'être seul mérite d'être
clair je reconnais que ce n'est pas
agréable et qu'il aura certainement des
injustices des situations cent mille
chômeurs qui n'auront plus d'indemnités
disaient certains oui par exemple pour
des raisons dont les responsables de la
capitale s'agit non mais je comprends
très bien les gens râlent et ça ne me
choque pas qu'ils râlent et s'ils ne
râlez pas on comprendrait pas mais elle
va dans la bonne direction malgré tout
bien joué je veux dire je suis
frontalier de l'allemagne j'ai bu les
réformes mars
en gt président de région à une époque
où la feuille ou l'allemagne étaient en
chômage
elle est en plein emploi est ce qu'on
présente loi avec travailleurs cook est
trois fois plus important qu'en france
voilà des travailleurs que cela leur est
que ce sont les travailleurs pauvres
c'est pas la même chose sans des
travailleurs qui sont payés il me semble
que sur la forme madame pénicaud et
parfois inutilement clivante et on n'a
pas besoin de ça en ce moment
mais sur le fond ça va plutôt dans la
bonne direction il ya des choses qui
sont bonnes notamment sur la réduction
sur les cadres c'est quelque chose qui
est bien sûr audible après pour les plus
précaires bon on pourrait peut-être
revoir dans le détail un certain nombre
de mesures merci à tous les cadres
d'avoir participé à ce débat
on va tout de suite aller salle des
conférences rejoindre quentin qu'elle
mais vous êtes avec jacqueline eustache
brinio il a aussi été question de son
cas lors des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement à la reçu des menaces de
mort
à l'issue est peint de son vote sur une
proposition de loi qu'elle apporte est
d'ailleurs alors ce ne sont pas des
menaces de mort un tas mais elle a reçu
des menaces
elle est aussi était l'objet d'injures
sur facebook
madame eustache brinio vous étiez
l'auteur de cette proposition de loi sur
la neutralité religieuse pour les
accompagnateurs de sorties scolaires
après ces posts sur facebook vous nous
après vous nous apprenez que vous avez
sollicité le cabinet du ministère
de ce vote oui effectivement j'ai
découvert ce dont on a souvent parlé
tous ces postes qui concernaient des
menaces et des injures sur facebook et
donc j'ai envoyé un mail à la
conseillère parlementaire ne le ska
nerfs pour lui signaler que les
terralies niel estime que des des
parlementaires soient menacés soit la
cible de telles attaques
qu'est ce qu'on veut mais le lendemain
le lendemain matin le jeudi j'ai reçu un
petit mail très gentil qui musée bas
qu'il a bien pris note de ces menaces et
des propos que j'avais expliqué et
qu'ils allaient faire le ministère
allait faire un signalement sur la
plateforme pharos
c'est vrai que je ne m'attendais pas ce
genre de réponse et de signalement la
plateforme pharos je l'avais fait
moi-même la veille
voilà ses auteurs mais maintenant je
pense que c'est pas l'auteur d'ailleurs
je lui ai répondu que j'étais étonné par
cette réponse et je n'ai plus une
nouvelle du tout depuis du ministère et
de qui que ce soit d'ailleurs
une semaine plus tard il y eut cette
question aujourd'hui de votre collègue
lr on a vu la réponse de christophe
castaner qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé d'abord il a fallu quand même que
ma collègue anne marie bertrand pose
cette question aujourd'hui au
gouvernement pour pointer cette
difficulté pointé ce qui est
inadmissible en démocratie
pour découvrir effectivement que le
ministre était évidemment attaché à la
protection de cette démocratie et pour
éventuellement savoir qu'il avait bougé
dans son coin en interpellant madame
bello b mais je ne suis pas sûr que si
ma collègue n'avait pas poussé cette
question notoriété au courant de
démarche du ministre ce qui est quand
même assez étonnant
merci beaucoup à jacqueline eustache
brinio dame répondu à nos questions et
on verra la réponse du procureur suite à
la saisine notamment aussi par la
présidence du sénat suite à ces posts
sur facebook dame
merci beaucoup 1 comptant pour toutes
ces réactions c'est la fin de ce débrief
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement mais l'actualité
parlementaire elle continue tout de
suite on va prendre la direction de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
ou est auditionné jean baptiste djebbari
le secrétaire d'état aux transports qui
s'exprime sur le plf 2020 le budget de
l'année prochaine voilà tout de suite on
prend la direction plus à celle de
connexion sommes très heureux
aujourd'hui d'accueillir
jean baptiste djebbari qui comme vous le
savez tous et secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports nous l'auditionner
aujourd'hui qu'on ne cadrent bien sûr de
la préparation de la loi de finances et
des crédits relatifs aux aux transports
jeu insiste sur mon transport pour que
vos questions ce se limite à ce secteur
où il ya déjà beaucoup de questions à
poser je vous rappelle également même si
je les fais ce matin que nous
auditionneront elisabeth bornes le 19
novembre et ce sera donc l'occasion de
l'interroger sur d'autres sujets qui
relèvent de son ministère c'est à dire
que l'écologie
nous accueillons également lavables qui
est le rapporteur spécial de la
commission des finances en charge des
infrastructures
nous l'avons invité à notre audition et
qui est donc là aujourd'hui qui pourra
si elle le souhaite également interrogé
le ministre tunis nous avons souhaité
donc vous auditionné comme il se doit
dans le cadre de la préparation du
projet de loi de finances pour 2020 nous
aimerions que vous puissiez nous faire
le point sur les crédits de votre
ministère et nous aimerions également
que l'on puisse évoquer les aspects du
projet de loi de finances qui sont la
traduction d annonce d'ailleurs qu'elle
était faite par le gouvernement au début
de l'été et certainement par un hasard
de calendrier à la veille de la cmp
relative au projet d'orientation des
mobilités à savoir la diminution de 2
centimes d'euros par litre de
remboursement de des icpe sur le gazole
qui doit dégager 140 millions d'euros de
recettes par an l'augmentation de la
taxe de solidarité sur les billets
d'avion comprise entre 1,5 et 3 euros
pour les billets concernant les vols
intérieurs et et intra européens et
entre 9 et 18 euros pour les vols hors
union européenne ce qui devrait
représenter un produit supplémentaire de
180 millions d'euros
ces crédits sont destinés à être
affecté à la fit pour atteindre la
trajectoire qui est prévu par la lame
d'un financement de 3 milliards d'euros
l'année prochaine
alors cette hausse de la fiscalité pour
sur le transport aérien et le transport
routier pose bien évidemment la question
de l'accompagnement de ces secteurs pour
qu'elles puissent s'orienter vers des
technologies moins émettrices de gaz à
effet de serre à travers notamment le
soutien au développement d'une filière
de biocarburants pour l'aviation
question sur laquelle il n'y a pas de
d'éléments dans le projet de loi de
finances les acteurs de ces secteurs
nous indiquent qu'ils sont prêts à
supporter la hausse de fiscalité la
condition que ces recettes leur
permettent de réduire effectivement leur
émission c'est toujours la question de
la fiscalité écologique qui doit être
réellement affecté à la transition
écologique et que des perspectives leur
soit donnée sur l'évolution du cadre
fiscal et réglementaire et donc nous
souhaiterions monsieur mise que vous
puissiez nous donner quelques éléments
sur ce sujet autre autre question
concernant le projet de loi de finances
est une question qui concerne un grand
absent
la taxe carbone on tourne la taxe
carbone était omniprésente dans le
projet de loi de finances pour 2010 9 un
peu trop d'ailleurs l'expérience l'a
malheureusement prouvé autant le fait
que conformément aux engagements qui ont
été pris par le gouvernement il n'y ait
pas d'augmentation de la taxe carbone
cette année que la trajectoire
d'augmentation qui était prévu soit soit
interrompue se pose quand même une
question que l'on se pose tous c'est ce
que la taxe carbone est définitivement
enterrée est il question à terme de la
réintroduire et si oui comment certains
s'interrogeant même sur le fait comme
nous l'avons fait nous mêmes la semaine
dernière en auditionnant le conseil des
prélèvements
victoire sur le fait de savoir si la
convention citoyenne sur le climat n'est
pas destiné à remettre cette question au
coeur de l'actualité
et je rappelle que nous vaut 10 youn
rond dans les prochaines semaines les
responsables de l'animation de cette
convention citoyenne
enfin j'ajouterai que le projet de
budget n'est pas au rendez vous sur deux
sujets majeurs
le premier celui dont on parle et pas
plus tard qu'hier à monsieur le ministre
à savoir le financement de la compétence
mobilité dont les communautés de
communes vont pouvoir se saisir dès lors
que la loi d'orientation des mobilités
aura été définitivement adopté n'insiste
pas davantage là dessus on en a parlé
hier mais vous savez l'attachement du
sénat au fait qu'il y ait pour la prise
de cette compétence des recettes dédié
et pérenne et puis un autre sujet dont
nous avons déjà eu l'occasion de parler
ensemble et soit qu'elles ont trahi dans
cette commission
c'est la question du financement de
l'entretien des ouvrages d'art gérés par
les collectivités territoriales et plus
particulièrement par les communes et les
communautés de communes le rapport que
nous avons présentés à isabelle borne en
juillet et à vous-même au mois d'octobre
appelée à un plan marshall c'est à dire
à ce que des moyens importants soient
mis sur sur la table pour aider les
collectivités locales et pour les aider
déjà à faire ce qui nous paraît le
commencement de de toute politique
ambitieuse en la matière de faire un
diagnostic de l'état des ponts puisque
aujourd'hui que nous avons l'occasion de
l'indicé ce bilan
ce diagnostic n'existe pas et puis enfin
toute dernière question nous aimerions
que vous puissiez nous donner quelques
éléments sur le rapport que nous
attendons sur les petites lignes
ferroviaires
monsieur le préfet philizot s'apparente
de plus en plus en tout cas son rapport
à une arlésienne et donc peut-être que
vous pourrez nous donner quelques
éléments sur ce sujet voilà monsieur le
ministre ce que je voulais dire en
introduction de votre propos au terme
duquel vous aurez bien sûr un certain
nombre de questions qui vous seront
posées notamment par les rapporteur pour
avis des crédits qui vous concerne et
peut-être demain de la rapporteure
spéciale également merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
rapporteurs apporta spéciaux mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
peut-être nous faire un cours propos
pour vous présenter les principaux
éléments du budget puis répondre c'est
le président à vos questions avant de
les prendre la question des sénateurs
présents vous dire que ce budget j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire un peu mais hier
entre de lit entre les lignes et le
budget des ans des engagements tenus
tant sur les sujets des mobilités du
quotidien que sur les investissements
structurants de moyen et long terme que
ce budget s'inscrit dans le contexte
particulier que vous avez cité monsieur
le président des épisodes de l'automne
2010 8 qui évidemment ont mis en exergue
l'importance des problématiques de
transport de nos côtés de nos
concitoyens partout dans les territoires
et du rapport qu'ils ont chaque jour
très intime à la mobilité au sens large
que ce budget met donc au coeur les
investissements structurels et le
maintien de la qualité de service offert
au coeur de notre de notre politique et
qu'il met également la question
environnementale au centre de nos choix
de politiques publiques
ce budget qui aujourd'hui nous intéresse
représente canton mais on peut présenter
plein de façons différentes mais
représentent 9,8 milliards d'euros or
cdg express soit une hausse de 6 3% par
rapport à l'an passé et il met
évidemment en oeuvre les engagements
pris à l'occasion du débat de la loi des
mobilités qui porte notamment le budget
de la fita un peu moins de 3 milliards
d'euros 2009 182 millions pour l'année
prochaine et lafitte dans le détail aura
des moyens supplémentaires ses 80
millions en plus pour la régénération
des réseaux routiers et fluviaux
existants les engagements également sur
des trains d'équilibré du territoire
continuez vous savez que la sncf a dans
son conseil d'admistration valider la
commande des nouveaux trains corail
notamment sur les lignes paris orléans
limoges toulouse et paris clermont et
c'est donc 22 millions qui sont
consacrés dans ce budget pour
l'acquisition des 28 nouvelles rames et
qu'au delà ce budget consacre
l'engagement de l'état pour le
ferroviaire 2 milliards de de concours
au réseau ferré national reprise de la
dette nouveau programme qui vise à tenir
l'engagement de l'état au moment du
pacte ferroviaire de l'année dernière et
puis peut-être que nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler des différentes
règles qui sont qui sont inscrits de
manière à ce que les engagements de
l'état et la soutenabilité du groupe
public ferroviaire soit assurée la
mobilité durable
se pose également comme un autre sujet
de préoccupation fondamentale de ce
gouvernement
vous savez que pour y parvenir nous
avons souhaité les tripler la part des
déplacements à vélo d'ici à 2024 et
engageons 350 millions d'euros sur sept
ans à cet effet est également créé le
forfait mobilité durable pour que les
salariés puissent avoir recours plus
facilement à des modes alternatifs à la
voiture
et puis sur un sujet un autre sujet au
transport combiné est également
confirmée elle était importante voire
essentiels notamment dans le cadre des
sujets qui nous intéressent et nous
pourrons peut-être dire un mot du du
train des primeurs un petit peu plus
tard si vous le si vous souhaitez
peut-être dire aussi un mode une
politique qui est sont mal connues la
politique des transports maritimes
nous consacrons voilà nous nous
consacrons 292 millions d'euros chez
cette année à cette politique
j'ai eu l'occasion hier en séance de
saluer l'engagement des bénévoles et les
personnels de la snsm et je le réitère
ce salut qui le payent parfois au prix
de leur vie qu'on nous l'a tristement
observé pendant le naufrage au large des
sables d'olonne et qui pour autant
remporté un concours absolument
fondamental indispensable à l'état dans
la réalisation du secours en mer et je
vous confirme que mon ministère tiendra
au maintiendra plutôt son niveau de 2010
9 pour les moyens accordés à cette
association
l'été a confirmé également en 2020 son
engagement auprès des ports en
sécurisant les moyens nécessaires à leur
bon entretien notamment en matière de
dragage et en poursuivant les opérations
de développement inscrits dans les cpe r
vous savez que la france est à
l'initiative notamment dans les
enceintes internationales sur les sujets
de pollution maritime et de qualité de
l'air nous défendons notamment la mise
en place d'une zone spéciale de faibles
émissions en méditerranée comme et elle
existe déjà en manche mer du nord et
nous avons également porté une
proposition sur des émissions en tout
cas la baisse des émissions de co2 par
la réduction de la vie qu'il avait la
vitesse commerciale des navires et ces
discussions ont vocation à prospérer
dans une présentant relativement court
peut-être que pour terminer avant de
répondre à vos questions je vais évoquer
le volet aviation civile du budget 2020
dire qu'il se structure autour de deux
axes principaux
d'abord le maintien d'un haut niveau
d'investissement en matière de sécurité
sur les 200 m et 2,29 milliards d'euros
du budget déjà c'est un effort
particulier est accordé aux
investissements permettant de garantir
des services de navigation aérienne de
haut niveau qui sont conformes à la
période 2023 2024 et par ailleurs nous
visons la limitation des impacts
environnementaux du secteur aéronautique
je reviendrai dans quelques instants sur
le sujet déblocables ans vous avez
évoqué évidemment ceci est réalisé avec
le souci de préserver nos finances
publiques et nous continuons le
désendettement de la dg assez pour le
ramener à son niveau de l'année 2005
voilà peut-être les principaux éléments
à répondre très rapidement le président
à vos trois questions sur la taxe
carbone des raisons de dire que l'état
tient la parole présidentielle qui s'est
donc engagé à ne pas pratiquer
l'augmentation de cette taxe
vous avez raison aussi de dire qu'il ya
des discussions actuellement dans le
cadre de la convention citoyenne et que
très certainement ce sujet il sera
abordé
mais la convention vous avez dit est
destinée elle n'est pas destinée aux que
nous n'avons pas évidemment missionné la
coume la convention qui est tout à fait
autonome sur le sujet mais je crois que
c'est un sujet qui reste dans les
mémoires dans les psychologique
évidemment c'est un d un débat qui aura
lieu sur le financement de la compétence
mobilité sujet qui a été la pomme de
discorde de nos débats d'hier je les dis
où je vais répéter plutôt la philosophie
du gouvernement c'est bien de s'assurer
que dans le cadre de la réforme de la
fiscalité locale la part qui était sa de
la taxe d'habitation est substitué par
une par fractions dynamique de la tva et
que par ailleurs j'avais souhaité dans
le cadre de la compensation du versement
transport vous dire que le gouvernement
était ouvert à porter ou a proposé un
amendement de manière à sécuriser les
collectivités qui aujourd'hui et elles
sont minoritaires sur est dans une
situation défavorable vis-à-vis du
versement transport
le mans nous n'aurons pas ce débat mais
je crois que nous avons eu beaucoup
d'autres débats très positive sur ce
texte et vous avez nous l'avons saluer
je crois collectivement sur les sujets
de la loi didier nous avons eu un débat
au sénat peut-être maintenant un mois je
vous avait rappelé que les diagnostics
sont en cours en tout cas que le
recensement des ouvrages plus de quinze
mille ouvrages concernés est en cours
que cette liste est ouverte jusqu'à la
fin de l'année et que une fois que la
liste sera arrêtée par décret il sera
alors possible de passer à la phase
suivante qui est
la répartition financière entre les
différentes collectivités des états bien
sûr des opérations de régénération de
ces ponts qui sont tout à fait essentiel
à l'aménagement du territoire
je vous dis rapidement un mot du rapport
philizot et si vous voulez je regarde un
peu plus tard sur les biocarburants
je le dis également y lire le rapport
philizot il je l'avais demandé comme
rapporteur à l'époque du paped
ferroviaire il n'a été rendu dans son
avant-projet
quand je suis arrivé au ministère et il
fait effectivement l'état le diagnostic
des voix ligne par ligne
et il pose des éléments financiers sur
le coût de la régénération mais
souhaitait que le préfet philizot un
cran plus loin en lien avec les régions
de manière à ce que d'ici à la fin
novembre début décembre nous disposions
à la fois du rapport et d'un plan
d'action régionale concertée avec les
agents de manière à ce que nous
puissions engagé une phase très
concrètes de travail sur les petites
lignes oui c'est à neuf et que nous
testions des solutions adaptées je pense
notamment au train léger je pense au
travail et de rosel je pense à des
solutions qui ont émané des discussions
que j'ai pu y les collectivités et
notamment chez moi en limousin et je
crois que ce ce plan d'eau ce plan
d'action opérationnel sera à mon avis de
nature à satisfaire beaucoup mieux les
attentes des territoires et au delà des
citoyens et des élus que nous sommes
tous ici voilà monsieur le président en
introduction ce que je souhaitais porter
à votre connaissance
merci beaucoup monsieur ministre veut
donner la parole à monsieur mon délit
qui est rapporteur sur les crédits du
transport ferroviaire collectif et
fluviaux monsieur rapporte merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et fiction nous avons eu hier
l'occasion d'échanger sur certains
aspects liés à l'adoption de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités ce sera le
premier budget post l'homme et de fait
le travail que nous avons réalisé ici
qui a été repris d'ailleurs par
l'assemblée pour sanctuariser leur sueur
de la fillette a été je pense plutôt
bénéfique
donc ce moment est important puisque
plusieurs réformes d'ampleur doivent
être mises en oeuvre
ma première remarque vous avez évoqué le
rapport philizot j'ai eu l'occasion de
positionner préfet philizot dans le
cadre de du plf
avant cette réunion et et c'est vrai que
le besoin estimé en termes
d'investissements pour remettre en état
de l'ensemble de leurs petites lignes je
dirais que nous ne sommes pas 200
millions d'euros près ces 7 milliards
400 millions
en gros donc et même si dans le cadre de
la l'homme nous avons intégré la
possibilité pour les régions de prendre
en compte les petites lignes
ça reste un montant qui et quels que
soient les participations des uns et des
autres considérable le budget global des
régions sur le ferroviaire étant de
l'ordre de 7 milliards par an ce qui
donne une idée du volume
d'investissements qui serait nécessaire
le premier ministre donc avait annoncé
de 200 millions d'euros supplémentaires
par an pour la régénération des réseaux
à partir de 2022
donc si je fais le rapport entre 200
millions d'euros par an à partir de 2020
de 7 milliards 4 précisant des besoins
il ya un écart considérable
donc est ce que dans le cadre du contrat
pluriannuel entre l'état sncf réseau
c'est c'est cette dimension sera sera
prise en compte dans la négociation
je souhaiterais également savoir
toujours sur la question des lignes et
des ter
on dirait que les régions
la cour des comptes a adressé un rapport
assez assez sévère sur sur le service et
le coût de ces services
donc calé quel regard vous portez
aujourd'hui sur le partage des missions
des responsabilités entre les différents
interlocuteurs soient létale mais région
et gestionnaire des infrastructures
et puis pour terminer sa mission du
transport fluvial on l'a vu dans le
budget notamment de la fuite des fonds
sont en progression très nette très
forte pratique mans doublé en l'espace
de trois ans il faut saluer l'engagement
du gouvernement sur le sujet et de façon
paradoxale le nombre le plafond
d'emplois diminuent cela n'ait de 212
postes essais consécutifs depuis 2013
baisse des effectifs est aujourd'hui
quand je parle de paradoxes ce qui n'est
pas même si on considère qu'il ya une
automatisation un surnom de deux taxes
terrain est ce qu'on peut considérer que
ça n'est pas allé chronique que d'un
côté de doubler le budget de ce qui va
nécessiter la fois de l'ingéniérie
l'engagement d'investissement humain et
serra et diminuer les effectifs
donc l'ambition du fluvial qui est
essentielle dans notre pays ne
serait-elle pas freiné par cette plafond
d'emplois en diminution
est-ce qu'on n'a pas atteint un maximum
à ce niveau là donc voilà pour
l'essentiel des trois les trois sujets
que je souhaitais aborder avec vous à ce
stade merci monsieur mode de vie sur le
ministre merci monsieur président des
socios nateur sur le sujet du rapport
philizot que je vais liés aux contrats
de performance si vous le voulez bien
le contrat de performance der sar vu
aller directement le corollaire de la
reprise de 35 milliards d'euros de la
dette par l'état avec des objectifs
multiples vous savez qui sont à la fois
d'assurer la soutenabilité à long terme
de cncf réseau ça c'est l'objet des
multiples règles la double règle d'or
j'ai ramassé ou le si vous souhaitez le
sous jacent c'est quand même d'augmenter
de renforcer les investissements et les
investissements qui sont prévues qui
sont pour le coup bien connu sur la
signalisation sur donc l'augmentation de
la performance notamment des lignes à
grande vitesse
il y a des volumes de régénération des
lignes or who is us et 7,9 qui sont
également bien connu et puis à le sujet
des petites lignes vous avez fait et
puis elle est contrainte qu'on ne
connaissait pas avant la loi dit on a
parlé un petit peu avant les sujets du
glyphosate est aujourd'hui questionné en
tout cas induisent un certain nombre de
surcoût est donc le contrat de
performance entre l'état et sncf
résoudre évidemment faire la synthèse de
tout ça est resté dans l'ambition que
nous avons qui est d'augmenter de 200
millions d'euros par an le volume de
reja de régénération des lignes 1 et
ligne notamment sur réseau secondaire le
rapport philizot vous avez raison de
dire ce chiffre un peu plus de 7
milliards d'euros
ça c'est avant optimisation industrielle
côté réseau côté sncf réseau et
éventuellement en gestion déléguée aux
régions puisque vous savez que l'article
46 pistes de l'album permet à la fois de
déléguer la gestion du réseau
et puis le délégué également la maîtrise
d'ouvragé des travaux
et puis peut-être pour prendre un
j'ai évoqué juste avant les initiatives
qui peuvent être menées côté territoire
peut-être pour prendre un chiffre moi
j'ai eu l'occasion de d'abord c'est un
petit peu sur le sujet des trains légers
donc des trains qui correspondent à des
lignes peu fréquentées
quand on regarde en comparaison
internationale vous avez des trains qui
sont certes moins capacitaires pour le
dire simplement vous passer de 200
places à 100 places mais c'est des
trains qui coûte à peu près 40% de moins
à l'acquisition et donc moins cher en
exploitation et qui par ailleurs
sollicite beaucoup moins les voix et les
premières estimations industriels que
nous avons porterait l'économie réalisée
à 30 ou 40 % par rapport aux travaux
d'entretien et de régénération que nous
connaissons actuellement donc le
gisement d'économies en plus d'optimisme
l'optimisation industrielle est tout à
fait conséquents raison pour laquelle je
pense que le rapport philizot le plan
d'action issu du rapport fiso doit
apporter une réponse extrêmement
concrètes et nous faire converger sur un
chiffre qui ne sera évidemment pas celui
de 7 milliards 2,7 milliards d'euros qui
sera intégré dans la trajectoire de
réseau sur le sujet de du fluvial merci
de préciser effectivement que l'état
aide à mettre les moyens pour notamment
régénérer les ouvrages pour moderniser
mécanisée automatiser un certain nombre
d'ouvragés des cluses pour centraliser
les postes de commandement et que nous
sommes tout à fait vigilant que la
réduction des 112 et ep que vous avez
cités qui est correct ne se fasse pas au
détriment évidemment du service rendu
cette une un point de vigilance
absolument majeur du ministère et nous
sommes aussi très vigilants et vigilant
pardon au caractère saisonnier de
certaines activités notamment ses
activités autour des canaux automatique
et en temps d'y apporter des réponses
adéquates
enfin ce rapport du ter entrée de la
cour des comptes gestion du trafic ter
il ya évidemment beaucoup de choses qui
sont adressés quelque part aux régions
je ne commenterai pas au delà de dire
que nous avons inscrit dans l'album
certain nombre de dispositifs que j'ai
rappelé jusqu'à juste à présent que le
décret que nous avons pris nous permet
aussi de donner aux régions les moyens
notamment en termes de transparence et
la formation des données et je sais que
vous aviez été particulièrement attentif
à ce sujet là pendant nos premières
discussions
et puis et puis évidemment le sujet des
ter
vers du train en région du meilleur
générale s'inscrit évidemment dans ce
qu'on vient de débattre sur autour du
rapport physique d'une manière générale
de ces lignes fines de l'est certes du
territoire merci j'ai la parole à
monsieur jojo qui est le rapporteur pour
avis sur les crédits de la première
partie de la loi de finances merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre est notre commission est saisie
pour avis de plusieurs mesures fiscales
du projet de loi de finances relatives
aux transports
le président en a cité deux en
introduction la diminution de 2 centimes
d'euro du remboursement de la déité icp
sur le gazole est dont bénéficie le
secteur du transport routier de
marchandises et la hausse de la taxe sur
les billets d'avion
s'agissant du transport routier de
marchandises il est regrettable que la
mesure finalement retenu pour faire
contribuer ce secteur au financement des
infrastructures soit celle d'une
augmentation de la taille icp qui
portera majoritairement sur les
transporteurs nationaux alors que tout
l'enjeu était de faire contribuer les
transporteurs étrangers qui utilisent
nos infrastructures
d'ailleurs sans les payer puisqu'il se
ravitaillait en carburant un franc
dehors de france
pourquoi monsieur le ministre avoir
renoncé à mettre en place une vignette
qui aurait également concerné les poids
lourds étrangers
en ce qui concerne le transport aérien
et quelles réponses pouvez vous apporter
aux compagnies aériennes qui demandent
un soutien au développement d'une
filière de biocarburants pour pouvoir
réduire leurs émissions de gaz à effet
de serre le pellec 2020 prévoit
également de supprimer le tarif réduit
de thé icp sur le gnr d'ici 2022
une telle mesure était déjà prévu dans
le plf précédent mais elle avait été
supprimé à la suite du mouvement des
gilet jaune
toutefois contrairement à l'année
dernière il prévoyait une suppression
brutale
le plf 2020 prévoit une suppression
lisser dans le temps est assorti de
mesures d'accompagnement cela montre
bien le seul ministre matière de
transition énergétique lorsque l'on
prend le temps de concerter les acteurs
du secteur on peut aboutir à des
solutions compromis acceptable en
contrepartie de cette suppression d'un
amendement a été adopté à l'assemblée
nationale pour étendre le bénéfice du
fctva aux dépenses d'entretien des
réseaux de collectivités
pouvez vous nous éclairer nous confirmer
monsieur misc cela concernera tous les
réseaux gérés par les collectivités à
savoir bien entendu les réseaux secs
mais aussi les réseaux humides pour
teminer terminé je souhaiterais vous
interroger sur le malus automobile
le projet de loi de finances prévoit une
réforme de la fiscalité applicable aux
véhicules en raison notamment de
l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau cadre
réglementaire européen relatif à la
mesure des émissions de co2 mise en
place qui conduit à réévaluer là-haut à
la hausse de 25% le niveau des émissions
des véhicules
il est prévu qu'une nouvelle grille
tarifaire du malus soit instaurée au
cours du premier semestre de l'année
prochaine à une date encore incertaine
pourquoi ne pas procéder à une frêle
bascule au 1er janvier 2021 ce serait
beaucoup plus claire à la fois pour les
professionnels de dôme et lille mais
également pour les consommateurs merci
de votre réponse
merci monsieur le rapporteur aux seuls
ministres
si monsieur le président si vous m'aviez
replonger vos questions dans mes
premiers jours au ministère puisque j'ai
eu à la fois affronter et faillites de
compagnies aériennes et avoir cette
discussion exigeante avec les routiers
qui effectivement faisait état des
difficultés qu'ils avaient dans le cadre
du présent projet de loi de finances
ce que vous avez dit sur le général tout
à fait exact et nous avons essayé de
construire avec eux un dispositif global
qui permette de préserver la
compétitivité du secteur et qui apporte
des réponses un peu concrètes au sujet
de préoccupation fiscale dans l'est dans
le détail ce que nous avons fait sur la
réduction de 2 centimes de la tcp eux
c'est que nous avons posé un mécanisme
de transparence qui permettra pour les
secteurs du transport routier de
marchandises de répercuter s'il le
souhaite puisque cette nuit à la
transparence se fait en pied de facture
montera de répercuter à leurs clients
les deux centimes et donc d'assurer une
forme de neutralité financière pour eux
parlez en moi j'ai lu cette discussion
avec eux je comprends quand ils me
disent que chaque année en voisine ans
il se retrouve avec des os des baisses
et que cela évidemment compliqué pour
s'assurer de
une forme de stabilité fiscale dans le
secteur est donc gelé
je leur ai proposé de donner une mission
et gfc je vais d'aidé qui dirait
plusieurs choses à la fois qu'il
essaierait de poser les cadre d'un
contrat transition énergétique avec une
visibilité très clair et une stabilité
très clair sur les différents
dispositifs de sur amortissements d'
avantages fiscaux liés à la transition
énergétique et je leur ai dit également
que nous pouvions travailler sur deux
sujets qui était le délai de
remboursement de en trésorerie en
quelque sorte de matthijs vub parce que
vous savez que comme les agriculteurs ce
délai parfois porter à six et neuf mois
nous avons beaucoup en tout cas gérald
darmanin beaucoup de vrais aux côtés des
agriculteurs sur le sujet pour
raccourcir substantiellement ses durées
traitement et donc je propose que nous
fassions la même chose et par ailleurs
nous avons ouvert un champ sur
l'application du taux réduit de tennis
et peu à la pompe
ça c'est une vraie demande des syndicats
des transporteurs routiers d'avoir dès
lors que vous êtes avec un véhicule plus
sobre sur le plan énergétique d'avoir la
possibilité de bénéficier directement
terre d'une carte professionnelle par
exemple du taux de réduit à la pompe et
donc de ne pas avoir à faire ce débours
de trésorerie cette mission allait
lancer ou le bel val être allé dans
l'est dans les tuyaux côté bercy écouter
du côté de chez nous et elle a vocation
à porter un éclairage au tout début du
printemps 2020 et à s'intégrer dans la
loi de finances de l'année prochaine de
manière à apporter des réponses
extrêmement concrètes routier puis par
ailleurs nous avons posé des mesures
d'attractivité notamment sur la
formation encadrer des jeunes aux
métiers du transport poids lourds et moi
j'avais émis l'hypothèse que nous
utilisions le service national universel
comme un moment d'exposition à des
classes de jeunes 1 800 mille jeunes à
ces métiers qui sont des métiers dans
nos territoires par tous localisés et
qui évidemment s'inscrit dans une
logique plus plusieurs européenne de
trouver les bons moyens pour sauvegarder
en tout cas pour faire advenir l'europe
sociale et préserver ses emplois qui
sont évidemment attaqué personne ici ne
le nie sur le sujet du transport aérien
peut-être du nez en général il ya deux
choses d'abord le moment qu'on a vécu
depuis quelques mois à la fois
moment des élections européennes avec
une très forte montée des
stigmatisations ressentie par le secteur
mais en tout cas une forme de
questionnement sur le transport aérien
en tant que mode de transport
complémentaire ou pas au mode de
transport à réguler sur plan
environnemental
je pense que il faut être clair sur le
sujet il faut dire que le transport
aérien est tout à fait un mode
complémentaire à d'autres modes de
transport qu'il doit réaliser cette
transition énergétique mais que sur les
longues distances et sur le
désenclavement et il est une solution
adaptée aux besoins exprimés dans les
territoires c'est mon cas à limoges
aurillac ailleurs et que donc tout ça me
construire de façon un peu apaisées et
que les transports doivent se concevoir
en complémentarité et moi j'ai souhaité
qu'on réactive le conseil supérieur de
l'aviation civile qui n'a pas été très
actif depuis 2016 qu on le remonte au
niveau du ministère et qu'on traite de
deux choses de la compétitivité de la
filière et de l'acceptabilité sociale et
environnementale et des travaux très
conséquents qui ont été menées pendant
les assises de l'est rien je vois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut délivrer un
certain nombre de travaux sur la
simplification des mesures qui sont
simples pas très coûteuse et qui apporte
des réponses liées à la compétitivité en
dur du secteur des compagnies aériennes
qu'elles soient régionales ou ou plus ou
plus importante avec des réseaux plus
plus étendue peut-être qu'on pourra
revenir sujet de la fiscalité j'ai
quelques éléments éventuellement à
partager avec vous sur le sujet pour
répondre très rapidement sur
l'amendement mattei
vous m'avez posé la question de savoir
si l'amendement intégrer toutes les
dépenses d'entretien secs et humides sur
les réseaux secs les mines je vous
réponds oui
et enfin sur la question du malus et
l'hébergement des normes
environnementales
d'abord dire que l'ensemble du
dispositif c'est effectivement un malus
avec des seuils de déclenchement qui
sont revus de l'iss est à 110 grammes
que par ailleurs la hausse du bonus
permet de porter le bonus maximal du min
de 10500 pardon à 12500 euros et que
vous savez que nous avons enclenchée au
travers de la l'homme 7,30 transition un
peu d'ailleurs irréversible du
verdissement des flottes et j'ai pu
avoir l'occasion de discuter avec un
certain nombre de constructeurs
automobiles qui reconnaissent que le mur
mon investissement est important mais
qui reconnaissent aussi que cette
transition est nécessaire et que quelque
part aujourd'hui nous sommes déjà dans
une phase irréversible de la transition
vers l'électrique donc que le sujet de
maintenant c'est trouver les bons
leviers d'incitation et puis évidemment
trouver les les volumes très importants
de financement est évidemment le sujet
de construire un airbus de la batterie
entre la france et l'allemagne est tout
à fait au coeur de nos préoccupations
voilà monsieur le président merci
monsieur mise vous parliez de
verdissement des flottes ont tendu une
perche pour que j'exprime publiquement
le souhait que l'état respecte ses
engagements fixés par la loi de
transition écologique de 2015 qui
prévoit que 50 % du renouvellement de la
flotte doit être fait avec des véhicules
propres et aujourd'hui on en est très
loin comme en témoigne une réponse à une
question écrite apportée par le
ministère
monsieur corbisez qui est rapporteur sur
les crédits des trans motivé je pourrais
dans le ministre si effectivement le
vert commence à se remplir un peu plus
de la moitié puisque aujourd'hui le
budget de la fit se porte à près de 3
milliards c'est presque un chiffre digne
des grands des grands hypermarchés on
est à 2 milliards 982 millions alors que
tout le monde espère avoir les 3
milliards
si les crédits de voirie effectivement
deux dédiés à l'entretien du réseau
routier national va atteindre 800 sont
10 millions d'euros et qu'on espère
arriver à jouer au milieu a souhaité
je rappelle quand même que en matière d
ouvrages d'art cette commission avait
mis en place une mission concernant on a
essayé d'augmenter assez rapidement les
moyens qui sont consacrés à leur
entretien hors la loi didier 2014 a
recensé un peu plus de 15000 e ouvrage
d'art aujourd'hui à la seule charge des
collectivités territoriales et va
s'engager très prochainement avec vous
des négociations et les opérateurs
les collectifs des négociations
concernant la prise en charge de partage
des frais quand monsieur le ministre ces
négociations ont-elles se dérouler selon
quel calendrier
quel critère retenu la commission pourra
t-elle y participer ou donner son avis
pour en revenir ou pas la partie
développement durable vous mes chers
collègues que vous le savez durant cet
été
les conditions d'attribution de la prime
à la conversion été revu fortement à la
baisse
malheureusement pénalisant les revenus
les gens des plus faibles revenus les
plus faibles qui souhaitait acheter des
véhicules d'occasion électrique
rechargeable est ce que monsieur le
ministre les prochains du secteur de
l'automobile ont constaté un
effondrement
allez-vous revoir ce dispositif dans les
mois à venir pour corriger le tir
concernant le bonus malus c'est vrai
vous l'avez venez de le dire vous a
donné les chiffres du ministre
le malus le plafond de malus va
descendre 217 microgrammes à 110 c'est
pas gênant dans la mesure où si l'argent
va effectivement dans le bonus demande
peut être canton sauf que aujourd'hui le
bonus va être complètement restrictifs
puisqu'il n'y aura que pour les
véhicules et 100% électrique à batterie
c'est à dire que même l'hydrogène qui te
règlement est un véhicule électrique à
l'hydrogène pas de subvention pas non
plus pour les véhicules hybrides
rechargeables et on a entendu dire que
le gouvernement allait réduire son
montant pour les véhicules à faibles
émissions
acquis par les entreprises or comme l'a
dit mon collègue et le président hu man
délit et le président moret les
entreprises seront soumises à la loi
l'homme dans le cas des obligations de
verdissement de leur flotte
allez-vous revoir cette solution puis
avec mon collector on a tout ce qui
inquiète puisque le bonus malus n'a pas
encore été voté en commission nous
allons l'évoqué entre nous s'il
quinzaine de jours et je suis un peu
gêné de présenter un
gris de malus à mes collègues qu'il
n'aura qu'une durée de vie de 3 mois 4
mois puisqu'il va être appliquée à le
mot preuve janvier et semblerait que le
gouvernement à partir du mois d'avril se
dire après les municipales va appliquer
la réglementation européenne la wlt paix
qui est nettement plus sévère que la
grille française est donc avec des
écarts de 25%
pourquoi alors que cette grille ne
serait applicable qu'à partir du 1er
janvier 2021 pour que la france soit
plus écologiste écologique que les
autres pays d'europe pourquoi
l'appliquer tout de suite parce que
imaginer qu'à un citoyen lambda achète
un véhicule au mois de mars
on lui dit ben le malus il est de 150
euros
or le malus s'applique au moment où on
va immatriculé le véhicule metric ce
véhicule arrive au mois d'avril et la
nouvelle réglementation vous l'appliquez
le menu sera de 600 euros
mettez vous à la place de ces citoyens
qui d'un moment le le garagiste lui
radis à votre buzz malus les 200 euros
mais avec l'application de la règle
membres aux réglementations européennes
il multiplié par quatre pourquoi cette
précipitation de la part du gouvernement
d'appliquer la loi européenne alors
qu'elle pourrait s'appliquer au 1er
janvier 2021 la question élections se
pose parce que je suis très gêné demandé
à mes collègues de valider une grille du
malus qui n'aura qu'une durée de vie de
trois mois merci monsieur reporter aux
seuls ministres en question dans la
question
merci monsieur le président le sénateur
sur la première sur promet sujet de la
loi didier vous savez raison de rappeler
que sa porte sur plus de quinze mille
ouvrages quinze mille quatre cents pour
être précis de 1700 pour le réseau
routier national lui 1300 pour le réseau
ferré national et 4400 sur réseau vnf
pour reprendre un tout petit peu la
chronologie donc à compter du 2 août
dernier il est une publication
publication par dont on peut du
recensement provisoire qui est donc
valide jusqu'au 31 décembre prochain il
y aura un arrêté qui va être pris avec
la liste définitive a compté pendant les
premiers mois de 2000 20 et l'idée c'est
bien d'avoir une concertation entre les
collectivités et les différents
gestionnaires de réseaux l'état et aux
opérateurs pour à la fois parler
entretien la surveillance du
renouvellement et puis évidemment parler
de la répartition de la clé financière
de régénération sur le sujet de du bonus
et du malus d'abord dire que inde où
viennent les normes vous avez tp que
nous disent qu elles viennent du
tailgate où on traite aperçu que
finalement le malus en tout cas les
systèmes qui prenait en compte ou qui
évalue et le dommage à l'environnement
n'était pas adaptée et notamment n'était
pas représentatif des conditions réelles
de circulation
donc les normes en elles mêmes elles
sont plutôt une avancée même si je
comprends les enjeux de lisibilité que
vous décrivez les normes elles sont déjà
appliquées à pour les véhicules
utilitaires légers
depuis le 1er septembre est
effectivement elles vont être applicable
pour tous les véhicules dans le temps le
le clin d'oeil que vous dites mais je
crois qu'il faut j'entends un la
difficulté un peu l'ingénérie
parlementaire pour les porter mais je
crois quand même que sur le fond ce
principe
elle pose une avancée considérable sur
le laos du bonus je les 10 pour
l'électrique
effectivement le bonus max s'applique
aux véhicules électriques
mais le maire général les bonus
s'applique à différents types de
véhicules avec différents types de
motorisations avec des niveaux de valeur
de valeurs différentes est très complexe
mais nous ferons passer le vous avez
d'ailleurs tout à fait logiquement
qu'ils sont à disposition et sur l'enjeu
de verdissement des flottes qui est
d'une manière générale ce qui nous ce
qui nous amène à avoir cette discussion
moi je réitère que sur le plan la fois
écologiques sur le plan sociétal et sur
le plan du potentiel industriel de la
filière française c'est tout à fait
nécessaire de le mener et que nous
sommes déjà dans une dans le l'autre
côté de la courbe si je puis dire est
que nous devons absolument par la norme
par l'incitation fiscale et par une
politique industrielle tout à fait
ambitieuse accompagner cette transition
tout est nécessaire
merci juste peut-être une précision pour
qu'on sache bien de quoi on parle
quand on parle des ponts qui sont gérés
par les collectivités locales et
notamment les communes et les le pci
c'est pas seulement les ponts qui sont
des ponts de rétablissement aux visées
par par la loi didier parce que
plusieurs fois on a un petit peu semblez
confondre les deux les pondre
établissements ça concerne vous l'avez
dit effectivement un peu plus de 15
mille tombes mais les ponts gérées par
les communes ou les communautés de
communes
c'est au tour de 200000 donc c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose et même si on
apporter tant mieux notamment pour
éviter didier qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur ce sujet quand il était sénateur
mais bien sûr pas seulement pour elle si
on règle la question des pondre
établissements dans les mois qui
viennent c'est très bien mais notre
propos va au delà et bien sûr les
travaux de la mission d'information que
nous avions diligenter les rapporteurs
ace est présent peuvent en témoigner ont
bien établi qu'on était plutôt à 100000
pont sous maîtrise d'ouvragé communes ou
communautés de communes monsieur vaspart
à porter sur les crédits de transport
maritime oui merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre promis le
deuxième territoire maritime du monde
grâce notamment à l'outre-mer et on est
loin d'être la deuxième puissance
maritime du monde
ils seront on confond souvent les deux
donc il ya un travail important à faire
en matière de 2,2 à la fois de
protection et de valorisation de notre
territoire maritime
je voudrais simplement faire trois
observations qui peut être deux ou trois
questions
une observation c'est d'abord à
remerciements
pour notamment le financement du canot
de sauvetage keira hiva oa aux marquises
qui sera fabriquée normalement sur 2020
et et les bénévoles pourront avoir
là-bas un outil digne de ce nom alors
que lorsque j'ai vu les bateaux sur
lequel on envoyait des bénévoles pour
faire du transport sanitaire
j'ai eu un peu honte alors ce bateau va
être construit il ya eu 500 mille francs
cinq cent mille euros je crois sur deux
ou trois lignes différentes de deux
programmes et donc merci de l'avoir fait
notamment pour les bénévoles de
polynésie vous avez dit monsieur le
ministre tout à l'heure vous avez parlé
des financements de la snsm et vous avez
dit qu'ils étaient stables alors sauf à
avoir mal compris on avait on a on a
plutôt compris qu'ils avaient plus 4,5
millions d'euros pardon vous avait
fourché
donc tout va bien tout va bien non pas
parce que vous avez fourché mais parce
qu'il y aura bien les 4,5 millions
et puis je voudrais vous donner une
information aussi parce que c'est
quelque chose qui nous tient à qui nous
tient à coeur ici et à moi en
particulier c'est la performance de nos
grands ports maritimes et là dessus nous
allons nous avons mis une mission en
place dont je serai rapporteur et il
faut que nous regardions de prêt pour
quelles raisons nous sommes un peu en
décalage sur certains sujets pas sur
tous parce que sur les containers sais
et vu entreprises de marché mais par
rapport notamment au port du nord ou par
dp des pays du nord mais également par
rapport à la méditerranée et avec quand
même une inquiétude puisque le port de
gênes est repris par les chinois he avec
la route de la soie on peut aussi se
poser un certain nombre de questions il
va falloir que nous regardions ce
dossier de très près donc cette
mission-là va travailler sur le premier
semestre 2020
et je souhaite monsieur le ministre que
vous puissiez aussi nous aider dans
cette tâche parce que c'est un c'est un
intérêt collectif que nous avons là un
mot sur les ports
notamment manche atlantique par rapport
aux bauxite l'état c'est évidemment
préparé au no deal notamment et il y a
eu un certain nombre de dispositions de
prises notamment en matière de
recrutement de douaniers supplémentaires
dans le budget déjà 2019 ce avait été
actée et il y a eu notamment à saint
malo un essai à blanc si j'ose dire il
ya peu de temps et il a il est apparu de
trois difficultés au niveau des agents
douaniers il semblerait qu'il n'y ait
pas de difficultés particulières par
contre il semblerait qu'ils aient des
difficultés sur le contrôle sanitaire
donc là il faudra regarder ça de près
parce que il ya quand même un trafic
transmanche important à la fois de de
viande mais à la fois deux vivent donc
c'est c'est un petit sujet je ne sais
pas si vous avez des réponses à nous
apporter
le premier ministre avait également
annoncé est une stratégie la mise en
place d'une stratégie portuaire
à ma connaissance il ya pas c'est pas
encore annoncée est ce que vous avez des
éléments là dessus est-ce que ça
générera des moyens financiers
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas acté
dans le budget dès 2020 enfin en tout
cas un autre à la lecture du budget et
puis
[Musique]
et
aussi que le gouvernement compte-t-il
faire une mettre en oeuvre dans les
prochaines années pour soutenir la
compétitivité de la flotte de la flotte
de commerce française d'une part et
l'accompagner dans la transition
écologique
d'autre part merci monsieur le
rapporteur de ce ministre
ainsi monsieur le président peut-être
d'abord sur la snsm bien dire que les
crédits sont portés de 6 4 millions
d'euros à 19 soit une hausse de quelque
5 millions d'euros
corrigé mon erreur si effectivement j'ai
franchi dire que sur les grands ports du
nerf général et la stratégie portuaire
donc c'est une réflexion que nous menons
nous aurons l'occasion de nous exprimer
au tour du 3 décembre pour la
présentation la stratégie portuaire qui
vise effectivement à ne pas réitérer un
peu l'histoire française
l'occasion d'il ya deux ans l'histoire
de la mère de jacques attali qui disait
qu'à chaque fois qu'on avait essayé on
avait plutôt jamais réussi contrairement
aux anglais donc souhaitons que avec un
premier ministre très impliquée sur les
sujets pour tuer nous nous ayons plus de
plus de fortune cette fois ci sur la
stratégie portuaire peut-être quelques
éléments d'abord s'intéresser à la
réforme du modèle économique des grands
ports francs vous savez qu'à ropa est
aujourd'hui l'objet d'une préfiguration
comme adam rivaux allons donc nous avons
stabilisé pour le coup les moyens en
terme de dragage nous voulons stabiliser
évidemment la fiscalité
je vous dirai tout un mois tout à
l'heure un mode qui a été immergée tic
nous continuerons à accompagner la
compétitivité des opérateurs notamment
au moyen de l'aide à la pince et et 27
millions d'euros qui sont confirmées
cette année il ya évidemment tous les
sujets de la transition numérique dans
l'espace portuaire sur la filière
logistique et et sur les opérations de
manutention et puis nous avons posé dans
le projet de loi de finances des
éléments importants en matière de
transition énergétique thijs effet eu
des lycées elle fut réduite pour les
les branchements à quai et ça marche
plutôt bien je m'étais rendu avec
elisabeth bande à marseille gros volume
d'investissement du côté des opérateurs
et vraiment je crois que le brand le
branchement les branchements des navires
à quai sont des solutions tout à fait
adapté pour notre ambition écologique le
sur amortissements pour le gnl et on
voit la cma-cgm qui a une politique très
ambitieuse sur le sujet puis la baisse
de l'hiver pour les petits stockages
donc nous nous mettons en place et nous
renforcerons au fil de l'eau l'ensemble
de l'arsenal fiscal pour aider à la
compétitivité énergétique des ports il
ya un sujet peut-être de vigilance mais
qui est plus un sujet macro et votre
mission à mon avis ce sera très
intéressant de ce point de vue là c'est
regarder un peu aussi tu la chaîne de
valeur dans mr générale l'industrie
maritime et portuaire
bien que les grands opérateurs
aujourd'hui s'intéresse beaucoup à la
logistique qui nécessitent des
investissements énormes avec des acteurs
mondiaux et chinois pour ne pas les
nommer
je pense que là dessus en terme de
compétitivité il faudra regarder ce
sujet là de façon assez aiguë et moi je
me tape tout à fait avec votre
disposition pour partager mes premières
observations et puis sur le dernier
sujet de la préparation breakbeat ce qui
a été fait en collaboration avec gérald
darmanin c'est évidemment un travail sur
les aménagements des parkings notamment
pour les routiers et des aménagements
sur les sites de mon vétérinaire
sanitaire
alors je n'avais pas connaissance de
l'expérimentation que vous citez donc on
regardera évidemment mais je crois
pouvoir dire que sur l'aspect vraiment
préparation autant du côté douanes connu
tout est peut-être en sports nous sommes
arrivés à un niveau de préparation
satisfaisant pour nous prémunir d'abord
exit dur je ne veux pas qu effectivement
ici et là nous puissions faire bouger
comme ça de manière à être être plus
plus performant encore merci beaucoup
madame bonne foi des rapporteurs sur les
crédits
l'aviation merci monsieur président est
monsieur mini souvenez vous interroger
sur trois choses le premier seul aérien
a même si déjà ça donne de choses ont
été dites je vous rappellerai pas la
situation de nos compagnies aériennes
qui est particulièrement fragile
souligne nos compagnies à une
concurrence très féroce un parfois même
déloyale depuis trois quatre ans que je
suis rapporteur sur le sujet les crédits
aérien on dit toujours la même chose à
savoir qu'il ya nécessité à redonner de
la compétitivité de ce point de vue
votre gouvernement organiser les assises
de l'aérien ou tout ce qui touche à
l'aérien a participé fait un certain
nombre de propositions
résultat des courses et vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure de compagnies
aériennes françaises sur le carreau r
azur et xl airways 2000 emplois directs
et une taxe supplémentaire avec
l'augmentation de la taxe chirac
détournée de son objet c'est à dire de
la solidarité pour financer la fit est
donc pas pour financer l'aérien alors
que comme nous le disait la semaine
dernière le président suppléant du
conseil des prélèvements obligatoires
sur le rapport la fiscalité
environnementale au défi de l'urgence
climatique
la taxation de l'aérien ne doit être
plus de fiscalité internationale est
fléché pour soutenir la transformation
du secteur secteur d'ailleurs que j'ai
auditionné et qui bien évidemment
souhaite réaliser sa transition
énergétique d'ailleurs il y participe
déjà un renouvellement sans renouvelant
sa flotte et c est avec une
interrogation particulière mais vous
l'avez déjà évoquée mais vous n'avez pas
été plus loin à savoir la nécessité de
développer une vraie filière des
biocarburants donc ya pas de crédit là
dessus dans la loi de finances donc je
voudrais que vous répondiez le deuxième
sujet concerne le ferroviaire
vous l'avez évoqué aussi avec le rapport
philizot nous sommes de la même région
un nouvel aquitaine ce que je suis et le
élus de charente et je vous parle de la
ligne angoulême limoges qui est une
vraie
in d'aménagement du territoire abandonné
depuis des années aucun train qui
circule le
les lignes de désenclavement et
d'aménagement du territoire
donc où en êtes vous sur cette réflexion
les régions notre région est prête à y
participer
quid de l'état quand quels moyens
rappelant par ailleurs que dans le cadre
des contrats de plan état région il n'y
a pas de volet mobilité donc besoin
d'une réponse et dernier sujet ça ne
concerne pas les finances c'est une
justement une décision qui est une
décision de bon sens dans les sacro
saints le routier dans la loi l'homme le
gouvernement a donné la possibilité de
créer des voies dédiées propre sur les
routes nationales et départementales
très bien je voulais simplement rappelé
ça a été le cas ici au sénat on l'a déjà
fait à savoir que des territoires
entiers sont de fait exclus de cette
possibilité de créer des voies propres
et donc d'accéder à la transition
écologique pourquoi parce que nous avons
des routes nationales des routes
départementales qui sont submergés par
un trafic poids lourds
incessants énorme un trafic pour une
grande partie qui est uniquement liés au
transit et ce trafic qui pourrait
parfaitement circuler sur les autoroutes
est aux routes qui se situe en parallèle
c'est le cas pour notre région à savoir
des poids lourds qui pourraient
continuer sur l'autoroute a10 mais qui
sortent pour prendre la nationale 10
pour économiser 50 euros de péage et qui
bien évidemment cause des problèmes
extrêmement importante d'insécurité
routière d'entretien bien évidemment
pour la collectivité des voix de
pollution de l'air et des sols
vous nous sommes nous évoquons les zones
de non traitement en agriculture avec 3
m 100 m et c c'est 300 mètres monsieur
le ministre sur les bords de nationale
10 pour les coopératives pour que nos
agriculteurs puissent faire des céréales
tracé donc ce n'est pas 3 mètres 50 m
c'est 300 m vega aux métaux lourds que
l'on retrouve à proximité
donc là il s'agit pas d'un problème de
finances publiques il s'agit simplement
de faire en sorte et c'était la
proposition que nous avions ici au sénat
dans le cadre d'un amendement c'est de
faire en sorte que là où les poids
lourds en transit peuvent prendre le
taureau ils apprennent et non pas les
nationales et départementales
j'ai interrogé là-dessus on n'est pas
encore arrivé je compte sur votre
soutien
notre préfète de région a été sensible à
la voile le connaît le trafic
elle est tout à fait prête à étudier une
demande de dérogation d'expérimentation
sur le sujet et je voudrais monsieur le
ministre que vous la souteniez dans
notre région bien évidemment mais pas
que il ya ici des collègues qui ont
exactement le même problème il ya une
discussion à avoir également avec les
sociétés d'autoroutes puisqu'il va
falloir négocier nouveau les contrats
donc là il ya des choses a faim il ya
urgence pour des raisons économiques des
raisons sanitaires et des raisons
environnementales nous ne voulons pas
territoires ruraux être exclue la
transition écologique
merci ma bonne foi qui est tout petit
peu sorti du cadre de son rapport sur
l'aviation il me semble
très bien j'en profite pour saluer
vincent capo-canellas ce qui nous
rejoint dans sa qualité de rapporteur
spécial deux ans de présidence mais je
n'en doute pas moi je n'y étais pas et
je remercie patrick chaize qui a bien
voulu me mets représentés ben je vous
laisse et répond à celle du président
alors peut-être sur le lait rien pour
commencer sur le sujet reparler d'un mot
sur xl airways aigle azur
parce que l'imputer aux acides de l'est
rien cette barrière est un raccourci un
tout petit peu convenable sénatrice pour
dire que si on prend les deux sujets
si on prenait les deux sujets aigle azur
c'était une compagnie qui était bien
établi sur un marché qui a choisi en
2007 de se diversifier et qui est sorti
de son modèle économique qui a fait des
choses étonnantes typiquement aller
concurrencer up et easyjet entre lyon et
nantes par exemple
bon sans succès donc a eu et des choix
entrepreneuriat qui ont amené à une
station de projet dso souvent sur plan
financier elle n'a pas été en mesure de
trouver les capitaux pour pour préserver
son emprise sur le secteur et xl airways
s'est traduit peut-être autre chose
d'abord une fragilité de l'actionnariat
de l'entreprise
et puis le la dynamique d'un secteur qui
se consolide autour d'acteurs qui sont
gros effectivement d'acteurs qui se sont
aussi construit sur des zones grises du
droit si on prend ryanair pour le dire
clairement ou d'autres opérateurs
ces opérateurs on bénéficie d'un cadre
réglementaire en europe qui leur a
permis de prospérer dans des zones qui
ne qui sont des zones grises du droit
européen et qu'on a pas su
collectivement suffisamment régulées et
qui ont fragilisé de façon assez durable
le pavillon français alors que faire
maintenant
d'abord nous on a essayé de positiver
sur le plan de la fiscalité ce qui était
entre guillemets des vrais des faux
argument jacques vincent capoue et non
en appui ont discuté assez longuement et
notamment en gardant à la fois air
france et klm et puis des pays
comparables notamment l'angleterre et
l'allemagne
sur l'aspect des taxes et des redevances
liées à l'activité aéronautique
aujourd'hui quand on regarde vraiment à
la fois le moyen long courrier
on a un hub de paris pour ne parler que
de l'huile qui est des coûts supérieurs
web jobstairs nam mais ce qui traduit la
politique des uns des très favorable à
l'aérien et et au ferroviaire
mais on est en deçà du coût des
allemands et on deçà du coût est
substantiellement de ça beaucoup de
londres donc en termes de compétitivité
des hubs du coût de la touche est on est
on est sensiblement dans dans une
moyenne européenne est en tout cas moins
cher que les allemands et que les
anglais voilà pour cette audition de
jean baptiste djebbari le secrétaire
d'état aux transports qui s'est donc
exprimé devant les sénateurs de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
cela sur son budget pour 2020 et au
lendemain d'une journée un petit peu
compliqué pour le ministre dont le texte
la loi sur l'orientation des mobilités a
hier était directement rejetée par le
sénat
restez avec nous à 18h ne manquez pas
allons plus loin avec rebecca fitoussi
très bonne soirée sur public sénat
[Musique]